THANK YOU FOR JOINING US FOR THE
FIRST COMMITTEE.
HEARING ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE STATUS OF BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
PRESENT THAT AT THIS HEARING AND
ALSO THOSE OF YOU WHO JOINED US
THIS MORNING FOR THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
WE HAVE A PRETTY LONG AGENDA
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO GET THROUGH
THIS IN A TIMELY MANNER BUT IN A
WAY IN WHICH WERE ABLE -- TO
TAKE -- EVERYONE'S TESTIMONY AND
VALUABLE INFORMATION THAT
THEY'LL BE SHARING TODAY AND
HOPEFULLY TAKE THAT WITH US TO
BEGIN YOU KNOW THE WORK.
THAT WE PICK UP AS WE START THIS
CONVERSATION.
THE FIRST.
COMMITTEE -- OR TESTIMONY THAT
WE HEAR WILL COME FROM THE LA
OFFICE AND THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TALL
ASK IF I LOOK -- WILL COME
FORWARD WITH THE LA OWES OFFICE
LUCAS MORROW HE'LL BE REVIEWING
YOUTH REINVESTMENT FINE AND PROP.
FORTY SEVEN AND THEN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD CURTIS NOT SEND.
WHO WERE PRONOUNCES RIGHT NOT TO
NAY [inaudible]
HEY GO [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
TALKING ABOUT BREAKING BARRIERS
PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION [inaudible]
RIGHT.
AND SO WE HAVE.
ABOUT TEN FIFTEEN MINUTES.
TO ADDRESS THIS A PARTICULAR
SUBJECTS OF THANK YOU AND IN THE
SAME ORDER PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- THE COULD
TOMORROW AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- SO THERE
SHOULD BE A HAND OUT IN FRONT OF
YOU WILL BE GOING OF OUR THREE
GRANT PROGRAMS RELATED TO THAT
YOU THREE INVESTMENT OCT THE
SECOND CHANCE ACT.
AND THE DRAMA RECOVERY CENTERS --
SO GOING ON THE FIRST PAGE OF
THE HANDOUT THAT YOU THREE
INVESTMENT GRANT PROVIDES
FUNDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
TRIBES FOR THE PURPOSE OF BY
VOTING LOW LEVEL OFFENDERS FUND
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM --
AND THE PROGRAM BEGAN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND IS
MINISTER BY THE BOARD TO STAY IN
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS BSE SEE.
DOT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET COULD THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
PROGRAM WITH THIRTY FIVE MILLION
IN GRANTS GOING TOWARDS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ONE MILLION FOUR
TRIBES.
AND ANOTHER ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ADMINISTRATION.
THAT TOO WE ALSO NOTE THAT --
THAT THIS IS YOUR MOST THESE
FUNDS JUST RECENTLY IN JUNE OF
TWENTY NINETEEN HOWEVER ROUGHLY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION FUNDING WAS NOT
AWARDED -- TO TO LACK OF
APPLICANTS THAT MET THE REQUIRED
CRITERIA.
AND THEN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET INCLUDES FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND -- WITH FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
GOING TOWARDS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED FOR TRIBES.
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED THE AUTHORITY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I RECEIVED FUNDING
AND EXAMPLES OF THOSE INCLUDE.
A PROGRAM IN CULVER CITY THAT
WOULD INCLUDE A RANGE OF AFTER
SCHOOL IN MENTORING PROGRAMS AND
A PROGRAM IN ALAMEDA COUNTY THAT
PROVIDES A RANGE OF SERVICES TO
AT RISK OR JUST A SIMPLE OF
YOUTH.
SUCH AS A LATE NIGHT SPORTS
LEAGUE CASE MANAGEMENT AND
MENTORSHIP.
IN ADDITION TO TRY TO SEE
FUNDING INCLUDING THE PENALTY
BILL POMO NATION IN MEDICINE A
COUNTY WHICH RECEIVE NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A
PLAN. TO REDUCE PROBATION
SUPERVISION AND DROPOUT RATES
AMONG TRIBAL YOUTH.
I DO THE REASON NATURE OF THE
PROGRAM THAT GRANTS HAVE NOT
OTHER GRANT PROGRAMS ARE NOT YET
BEEN EVALUATED HOWEVER THE SEC
IS REQUIRED TO CONTRACT. FOR
STATE WIDE OUTCOME EVALUATION OF
THE PROGRAM.
AND THAT WILL CONCLUDE IN MAY OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE GOING
ON TO THE SECOND PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT THAT SECOND CHANCE OCT
GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES FOR YOUR
GRANTS TO PUBLIC AGENCIES FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT.
AND DIVERGENT PROGRAMS WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
THE PROGRAM BEGAN IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND IS ALSO
ADMINISTERED BY THE SEC.
THE PROGRAM WE SEE 65% OF THE
SAVINGS IS OFTEN FROM
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN WHICH
WAS APPROVED BY VOTERS IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND REDUCE THE
PENALTIES FOR SORT IN NON
VIOLENT NON SERIOUS DRUG AND
PROPERTY CRIMES.
IN JUNE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BST SEE
APPROVED GRANTS TOTALING ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
FOR FIRST COHORT TO TWENTY THREE
PUBLIC AGENCIES.
AND IN JUNE TWENTY NINETEEN YES
HE APPROVED GRANTS CUDDLING
NINETY SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SECOND COHORT OF TWENTY THREE
PUBLIC AGENCIES.
EXAMPLES OF SOME OF THESE
RECIPIENTS INCLUDE LOS ANGELES
CREATE AND EXPAND SERVICES FOR
JUSTICE INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS.
AND THESE SERVICES INCLUDE CASE
MANAGEMENT HOUSE SCENE AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS SANTA ANA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH
RECEIVED FUNDING TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT DIVERSION
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND JOB
DEVELOPMENT AT EIGHT SCHOOLS.
THAT GRANT DO YOU PUT THE
GRANTEES MUST SUBMIT A NUMBER OF
EVALUATIONS TO BSE SEE INCLUDING --
PRELIMINARY EVALUATIONS TO
ASSESS THE PROGRAM'S AFTER TWO
YEARS OF THE GRANT.
AND A FINAL EVALUATION PUT TO
SET THE PROGRAM'S EFFECTIVENESS
THAT FIRST ROUND OF PRELIMINARY
EVALUATIONS IS DUE ON AUGUST OF
TWENTY NINETEEN GOING ON TO THE
LAST PAGE OF THE HANDOUT.
THAT TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTRO
GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES TO YOUR
GRANTS TO TRAUMA RECOVERY
CENTERS WHICH DIRECTLY ASSIST
VICTIMS IN COPING WITH THE
TRAUMATIC EVENTS SUCH AS
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH -- CARE
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT.
THESE ALSO PROVIDE TRAINING.
ON THE FACTS ABOUT A CRIME IN
THE TREATMENT OF TRAUMA. TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS THE GRANT PROGRAM
BEGAN IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD CAL BC
BEING.
AND THE PROGRAM RECEIVES 10% OF
THE SAVINGS RESULTING FROM
PROPOSITION.
FORTY SEVEN IN ADDITION IT
RECEIVES TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FROM THE RESTITUTION
FUND.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIS
FUNDING SUPPORTED SIXTY OR SEES.
A SIX YEAR HE'S RECEIVED FUNDING
IT SHOULD SAY OF ABOUT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHT T. R. C.'S ALWAYS SEE A
TOTAL OF ABOUT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
COUNTY HERE SEES IT WORKS OF ART
IN THE COUNTIES OF ALAMEDA LOS
ANGELES RIVERSIDE AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
ADDITIONAL TEASE YOUR SEATS
BOISE FUNDING AND THE COUNTIES
OF ALAMEDA LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO SAN JOAQUIN
AND SOLANO -- IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TELEVISI BE BEGAN
REQUIRING GRANT RECIPIENTS TO
SUBMIT PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
BASED ON THESE MEASURES CAL BTP
ESTIMATES THAT SEVENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WILL RECEIVE
SERVICES AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT TRAINING
SESSIONS WILL BE PROVIDED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THESE
THANK YOU.
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU WITH SOME
QUESTIONS -- WILL WANT TO THE
NEXT PRESENTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CURTIS NOTS IN A CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD.
FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
WORKFORCE BOARD I WANT TO THANK.
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO COME AND
SHARE SOME OF OUR WORK.
I'M GOING TO BEGIN WITH A QUICK
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE STATE
WORKFORCE MORE -- NEAR MY
TESTIMONY TO SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
THAT'S OUR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
STATE WORKFORCE BOARD GETS ITS
MANDATE FROM THE FEDERAL
WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITIES ACT -- WHICH WE
CALL WE WHICH A SIGN ALONG.
TWENTY FOURTEEN WE'LL OUTLINES
THE VISION AND STRUCTURE THROUGH
ITS WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED
AND ADMINISTERED REGIONALLY AND
LOCALLY.
THE PRIMARY ROLE OF THE STATE
WORKFORCE BOARD IS TO CONVENE
THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PARTNERS TO ENSURE A
COMMON VISION SHARED GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES UNDER WE OWE -- AND
ALIGNED APPROACH TO PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS IS ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA UNIFIED STRATEGIC
WORKFORCE PLAN WHICH IS BUILT
AROUND THREE POLICY OBJECTIVES
THAT GUIDE STATE POLICY AND
PRACTICE.
ACROSS THE PARTNER PROGRAMS AND
INFORM LOCAL POLICY AND SERVICE
DELIVERY.
THE FIRST IS FOSTERING THE MAN.
GERMAN SKILLS ATTAINMENT SO THAT
WORKFORCE EDUCATION PROGRAMS
ONLINE TRAINING CONTENT WITH THE
STATE'S INDUSTRY SECTOR NEEDS.
SECOND ENABLING UPWARD MOBILITY
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
THOSE WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT.
SO THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO GOOD JOBS THAT LEAD TO
LONG TERM ECONOMIC SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND ECONOMIC
SECURITY.
THIRD ALIGNING COORDINATING AND
INTEGRATING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT'S ECONOMIZING
LIMITED RESOURCES TO ACHIEVE
SCALE AN IMPACT.
SO WHAT WE DO IS ESTABLISH
ACCESS TO THE BEST JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA THE BUSINESS A WORKER
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ADDRESS
CURRENT AND FUTURE WORKFORCE
CHANGING DEMANDS.
THAT MOVE WORKERS AT AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MOVE NEW PEOPLE
IN.
WE CALL THIS UP SKILL BACK FILL.
USING OUR HIGH ROADS TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS AND HIGH ROADS
CONSTRUCTION CREWS PROGRAMS
WHICH WE JUST RECEIVED THIRTY
MILLION.
PER YEAR FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
SOME G. G. R. F. FUNDS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET.
WE ESTABLISH THESE PARTNERSHIPS
IN INDUSTRIES ACROSS THE STATE.
FOCUSED ON SECTORS AND REGIONS
MOST IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND AUTOMATION.
THAT'S THE DEMAND SIDE WE START
WITH THE BEST JOBS IN INDUSTRY
SECTORS THEY'RE DRIVING REGIONAL
EMPLOYMENT WITH WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS JOINTLY PLANNING FOR
THE FUTURE.
ON THE SUPPLY SIDE.
WE ARE WORKING TO IMPROVE
ALIGNMENT AND OUT COMES IN THE
WORK FORCE SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY WE'RE SUPPORTING
CBO THAT OUR MISSION DRIVEN.
THAT KNOW HOW TO WORK WITH
POPULATIONS IN COMMUNITIES THAT
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT.
SAID THOSE CBO'S ARE CRITICAL
COMPONENTS OF AN EFFECTIVE
WORKFORCE SYSTEM.
AB LEVEN ELEVEN IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THIS AUTHORED BY THE
CHAIR THE BREAKING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE.
IS FUNDED WITH FIFTEEN MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND DOLLARS AND IS
INTENDED TO SUPPLEMENT EXISTING
WORK FORCE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
BY PROVIDING SERVICES TO ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF IN.
OF INDIVIDUALS EITHER PREPARING
TO ENTER ARE ALREADY ENROLLED IN
WORKFORCE AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
THESE SERVICES MUST BE DELIVERED
THROUGH A COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN MISSION DRIVEN CBO'S
WITH EXPERIENCE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO TARGET POPULATIONS
AND LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S.
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT MEETINGS
WERE HELD THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN FEBRUARY AND MARCH OF THIS
YEAR.
AND IN JUNE WE ESTABLISH A
LETTER OF INTENT TO APPLY FOR
GRANTS. TO ENGAGE THE FIELD AND
GET A SCAN OF INTERESTED
APPLICANTS -- THIS IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT FOR THOSE WHO INTEND
TO APPLY FOR THE GRANT.
BUT IN OUR SCAN WE RECEIVED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN LETTERS
OF INTENT TO APPLY. FOR THESE
GRANT FUNDS WITH NEARLY FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ASK.
THE RFA FOR A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN
IS SCHEDULED TO BE RELEASED
LATER THIS MONTH.
SECOND OUR CORRECTIONS WORKFORCE
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT WITH CDC
ARE CAL P. I. A IN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION.
BUILT UPON THE FOUNDATION LAID
BY OUR FORWARD FOCUS PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED BY AB TWENTY SIXTY
BY FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEMAND
WHAT BETTER AS PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDED THROUGH PROP THIRTY NINE
IN HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS AND SOME OF OUR
WORKFORCE ACCELERATOR GRANTS.
FROM THIS PARTNERSHIP.
INTENDED TO BRING CDC OUR
TRAINING AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS
UNDER THE STATE WORKFORCE PLAN.
THE PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT GRANT
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WHICH CONTAIN
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS TO ALIGN IN
PRISON PROGRAMMING.
WITH POST RELEASE SERVICES FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND
JUSTICE INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS.
WE ALL OF THE FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES US TO UPDATE OUR STATE
WORKFORCE PLAN EVERY TWO YEARS.
AND EARLIER THIS YEAR.
WE SENT REGIONAL LOCAL PLANNING
GUIDANCE.
OUT THAT REQUIRED ALL FOURTEEN
LABOR REGIONS TO DEVELOP PLANS
ON ALIGNMENT AND LOCAL WORK FOR
SERVICE DELIVERY FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AND JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS.
WE SHOULD ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION IN PLANNING GRANTS FOR
REGIONS TO CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS
FROM WORK FORCE.
PUBLIC SERVICE PROVIDERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CBO'S TO DEVELOP
THESE PLANS.
WHICH THE STATE BOARD HAS
RECEIVED AND ARE FINALIZING
APPROVALS.
THE STATE WORKFORCE BOARD ALSO
RELEASED AN RFA LAST FALL FOR
THIRTY FOUR MILLION FOR REGIONAL
DIRECTS IN SUPPORT OF SERVICES
GRANTS.
AND THOSE GRANTS ARE HAVE BEEN
REVIEWED AND ARE IN VARIOUS
STAGES OF APPROVAL IN FUNDING.
THIRD IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE OUR
STATES CLIMATE GOALS WE NEED
WORKERS TO DO IT.
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS ARE TRANSFORMING THE
ECONOMY AND IN TRANSIT IN
TRANSFORMING THE ECONOMY.
WE NEED TO TRANSFORM THE WORK
FORCE TO DO THIS WE NEED TO LOOK
AT EQUITY. TO ACHIEVE EQUITY WE
HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO JOB
QUALITY A CLEAN GREEN ECONOMY
THAT ALSO LIFTS ALL BOATS WON'T
HAPPEN ACCIDENTALLY.
AND WE WANT TO DO IT
INTENTIONALLY.
CALIFORNIA ALONE CAN'T SOLVE
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT WE ARE MODEL
TO SHOW THE WAY.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF GREAT MODELS.
THAT COMPRISE THE CORE OF OUR
EQUITY CLIMATE AND JOBS PROGRAM.
THEY'RE NOT HUGE COMPARED TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
BUT WE FEEL THAT THEY SHOW US
THE WAY.
FIRST OUR HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS PROGRAM -- A LOT OF THIS
WORK STARTED WITH OUR
PROPOSITION THIRTY NINE FUNDING.
AND IS INTENDED TO CREATE ACCESS
TO STATE APPROVED CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIPS THEIR MULTI
CRAFT PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PARTNERSHIPS.
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED -- BASED
ON THE NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED MC
OVER THE PAST FOUR FIVE YEARS
WE'VE INVESTED IN BUILDING
TWELVE PARTNERSHIPS -- THAT
TOTAL ABOUT TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS WITH LOCAL BUILDING
TRADES COUNCILS JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS CBO'S
WORKFORCE BOARDS AND EDUCATION
PARTNERS -- WE SERVED OVER --
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
FROM DISADVANTAGED POPULATIONS
OF AVERAGE COME A COMPLETION
RATE OF 80% -- SOME PROJECTS ARE
90%.
OUR AVERAGE PLACEMENT RATE IS
ABOUT 70% WITH ABOUT HALF OF
THOSE -- PLACED AN ACTUAL
APPRENTICESHIPS THE OTHER HALF
ARE ENROLLED IN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION OR IN CONSTRUCTION
RELATED JOBS -- WE WILL EXPAND
THIS WORK -- WITH OUR SB ONE
FUNDS -- WHICH THE STATE
WORKFORCE BOARD HANDS HAS WHICH
INCLUDES.
A TWENTY FIVE MILLION OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS -- TO EXPAND
THESE HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREER -- MODELS.
THE SCALE OF EXISTING PROJECTS
AND TRANSFER THESE MODELS THAT
WE PILOTED IN PARTS OF THE STATE --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
THE OTHER -- SECTORS IDENTIFIED
IN THE SCOPING PLAN [inaudible]
SO -- IN ADDITION TO THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IN SB ONE DOLLARS
WE ALSO.
HAVE AS I MENTIONED EARLIER TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN G.
G. R. F. FUNDS -- TO EXPAND THE
HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION CAREERS --
MODEL TO FOURTEEN REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS IN ALL FOURTEEN
LABOR REGIONS -- WE'RE PREPARED
TO SERVE -- AT LEAST -- THREE
THOUSAND DISADVANTAGE
DISADVANTAGE WORKERS.
THAT'S PREPARE THEM FOR SAID
APPROVE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS --
NOT THOSE COSTS INCLUDE
INTERMEDIARY SUPPORT RECRUITMENT
COUNSELLING MENTORING SUPPORTS
INCLUDING STIPENDS MC THROUGH
TRAINING PLACEMENT RETENTION
TRACKING.
ON THE STATE BOARD ALSO HAS
TWENTY MILLION ANNUALLY FOR THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS.
N. G. G. R. F. FUNDS FOR HIGH
ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS.
WHICH WE PLAN TO EXPAND FROM THE
CURRENT. EIGHT TO TWENTY
PROJECTS.
IN SECTORS IDENTIFIED -- IN THE
SCOPING PLAN -- AND OUR OUR PLAN
THERE IS A SERVE AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND DISADVANTAGED WORKERS --
SERVE TO THESE TWENTY H. R. T.
PEAS -- INSISTING THAT LONG TERM.
SO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING OUR PHASE FOR BOTH
THE HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS HI RAJ TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS -- WE'RE
ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING OUR SB ONE H. R. C.
C. GRANTS ARE FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PRE
APPRENTICESHIPS.
AND WILL BE RELEASING THAT OUR
FATE LATER THIS YEAR. 85% OF OUR
FEDERAL WE OWE A FUNDS ARE FIVE
FORMULA OUT TO LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S.
AND THE REMAINING 15%.
AS FOR STATE OVERHEAD
ADMINISTRATION AND WE HAVE A
TINY SLIVER -- THAT WE USE AS
THE GOVERNOR'S DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING ARE WHAT WE CALL THE 15%
FUNDS.
BOB THIS WE ARE PROUD OF OUR
ACCELERATOR PROGRAM.
WHICH IS A WAY OF DOING
WORKFORCE IN INNOVATIVE AND
CREATIVE WAYS THAT ARE JUST NOT
SUPPORTED BY FORMULA DOLLARS THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD PROVIDES THESE MOST
FLEXIBLE FUNDS TO TEST
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS. TO
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES FACED BY
POPULATIONS WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT.
THE APPLICATIONS WE RECEIVE A
TYPICALLY THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE.
AND IN FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WE FUNDED TWENTY EIGHT
PROJECTS.
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
FIELD THAT INCLUDED COACHES WITH
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE FRIDGE
PROJECT.
THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING A
SEARCHABLE DATABASE FOR ALL
ACCELERATOR PROJECTS AND WILL
HAVE THAT AVAILABLE THIS YEAR IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ALSO.
SO WE'RE PLANNING TO RELEASE OUR
ACCELERATOR EIGHT POINT NO --
RFA THE WHICH WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AT THE END OF AUGUST.
AND WE ARE AGAIN PLANNING TO
RELEASE THE AB ELEVEN ELEVEN RFA.
LATER THIS MONTH -- WILL WILL
HAVE -- A LOT MORE IN
ANTICIPATED ASK -- THEN WE
ACTUALLY HAVE FUNDS AVAILABLE --
TO PUT OUT IN THE FIELD AND WITH
THAT I JUST WANT.
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS SOME OF
OUR PROGRAMS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS WELL WE PROVIDED A
LOT OF BACKGROUND MATERIAL
BECAUSE WE PUT OUT WELL OVER A
HUNDRED GRANTS -- A YEAR AND A
KIND OF COVER ALL THE THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THOSE -- IN A FEW
MINUTES IS DIFFICULT BUT BUT WE
DID PROVIDE AS MUCH BACKGROUND
INFORMATION AND ARE AVAILABLE --
TO DISCUSS ANY ANY OF THOSE
GRANTS OR PROGRAM THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
KALRA THANK MEASURES SUCH A
COMMENT TO CURTIS -- I
APPRECIATE THE THE REPORT OUT
AND AND IN PARTICULAR -- AS WE
MOVE TO THIS GREEN ECONOMY -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE JOBS ARE
BEING CREATED A QUALITY JOBS
THAT REQUIRES TRAINING.
AND THE AND THE THE THE SUCCESS
THAT PROP THREE NINE
PROPRIETORSHIP PARTNERSHIPS I'VE
I'VE HEARD A LOT LA COUNTY IN
OTHER PLACES ARE REALLY.
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT AND AND
WOULD JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW
CONTINUING CONSIDERING THE FOCUS
YOU ALREADY ARE ON IN TERMS OF
MOVING FORWARD -- TO TO THESE
GREEN JOBS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
MORE MORE READILY AVAILABLE --
AND AND TO CREATE THAT WORK
FORCE -- USING -- SOME THESE
VERY CREATIVE INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS I'VE JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK IS ALREADY
BEING DONE.
SAYS THE COMMENT THERE AND THEN
OF A GOT A QUESTION AND IS THIS
HAS TO DO WITH -- AND I THINK
ALL OF US WHO HERE IN DIFFERENT
WAYS OF BACK IN OUR DISTRICTS
WITH PROP FORTY SEVEN AND THERE
IS -- WITHOUT ANY DATA OR
EVIDENCE THERE SEEMS TO BE THIS --
EASY SCAPEGOAT HELLO CRIMES
GOING UP BECAUSE PROPERTY SEVEN
OR THESE DON'T BREAK INS ARE UP
BECAUSE PROP.
I'M HEARING COUNTSMEMBERS MY
OWN COMMUNITY TRYING TO USE IT
EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE THE
DATA TO BACK IT UP BECAUSE IT'S
AN EASY OUT -- AND I NOTICED
THAT WITH SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS --
THAT -- THE REPORTS AREN'T OUT
YET OR MAY NOT BE COMING OUT OF
THE THIS IS THE REASON THE YOU
THREE INVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM.
HOW COME THE PROGRAM OUTCOMES
REPORT WILL BE -- TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WILL GET ONE SOONER ON THE
SECOND CHANCE ACT GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH IS -- WHICH IS SPECIFIC TO
THE TO PROPERTY SEVEN WHICH IS
GOOD -- BUT I GUESS IS THE SENSE
OF HOW TO WE RESPOND IN A GUEST
A RETURN ON INVESTMENT WHICH
SOME PEOPLE ARE GONNA ALWAYS
QUESTION LIKE A PRETTY THIS
MONEY WOULD BE GETTING OUT OF IT --
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE THE
QUOTE TOUGH ON CRIME FOLKS ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO TRY TO FIND ANY.
LITTLE OPPORTUNITY -- TO
CRITICIZE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT IN
ADVANCE OF RECEIVING I GUESS
SOME OF THE REPORTS WITH.
AUGUST IS RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER NOW SO I GUESS I WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IF ANY
THOUGHTS YOU HAVE ON THAT -- ITS
OWN TERMS OF AN ANALYSIS WE
WOULD DEFAULT TO THESE ANALYSES
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING. TO GO
OFF OF OTHER THAN THIS
INFORMATION -- WE DO HAVE DATE
ON A WEBSITE ABOUT CRIME RATES --
BE HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
IS THAT YOU CAN SORT OF DISCUSS
THE TRENDS AND CRIME.
OKAY I THINK.
MISTER ROBERTS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND THIS ONE S.
THAT QUESTION WE DID COME IN --
DURING YOUR PRESENTATION BUT
LOOKING FORWARD -- TO DIALOGUE
AND AND DIFFERENT DATA COMING
FORWARD BUT ALSO -- DOT DATA
THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY CENTERS
AROUND ONE OF THE HIGHEST
POPULATIONS OF THOSE THAT HAS --
PROGRAMS A MEN OF COLOR THOSE
AREAS AS THE NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE MOVING THAT UP IN
COLLECTING THE DATA THERE'S SO
THAT WE'RE HAVING SOME IMPACT ON
THAT.
TO YOU CARE TO ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT MORE AND HOW WE CAN
GET SOME OF THAT INFORMATION --
SO WE ARE -- WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
THE PROCESS OF BEGINNING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I'M A LOT OF
TRAVEL ENTITIES AS YOU KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RECEIVED FUNDS
DIRECTLY -- FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO -- A NUMBER OF THE
WORK FORCE DOLLARS THE FEDERAL
WORKFORCE DOLLARS GO DIRECTLY TO
TRAVEL GOVERNMENT SO THEY DON'T
WE DON'T ALWAYS GET THAT DATA --
THROUGH OUR STATE WORKFORCE
EXCHANGE -- KNOWN AS CAL JOBS I
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO BUT IT'S
IT'S IT'S HARD FOR US SOMETIMES
OR YOU KNOW ACTUALLY SOMETIMES
WE FEAR THAT WE MIGHT BE DOUBLE
COUNTING -- SOME OF THOSE
OUTCOMES BECAUSE THEY MAY BE
DIVERT BEING DIRECTLY REPORTED
BY TRIBAL ENTITIES ABOUT TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE OF
THE FEDERAL FUNDING STREAMS
RATHER THAN PASSING THROUGH US
AS AS A STATE SO.
WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT --
WHOSE REPORTING WHAT DATA AND
THROUGH WHAT SYSTEMS --
SPECIALLY WITH WITH TRAVEL MONEY
WE HAVE A VERY SMALL SLIVER --
THAT -- OF OF FUNDS THAT GO --
TO THE CALIFORNIA -- THINGS
INDIAN DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE ONLY HAVE A
VERY TINY GRANT -- THAT GO TO
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES BECAUSE MOST
OF THOSE FEDERAL DOLLARS GO
DIRECTLY TO TO TRAVEL ENTITIES
BUT WE HAVE STARTED THAT
CONVERSATION -- IN OUR RESEARCH
SEEM OR TRYING TO FIGURE OUT --
HOW THAT REPORTING A GOES TO THE
FEDS AND EVEN IF IT GOES
DIRECTLY TO THE FEDS WE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT IT ALSO -- AS A STATE
WORKFORCE BOARD SO THAT WE CAN
WORK TO ENSURE -- BUT THERE IS
EQUITY IN AND GOOD OUTCOMES IN
TROUBLE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU JUST A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION AND MR CHAIR -- ALSO OR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
FEDERAL -- FUNDS ARE THERE
PARTICULAR TO THE FEDERAL INDIAN
RESERVATIONS WE STILL HAVE A
HIGH POPULATION OF URBAN INDIANS
LIVING WITHIN OUR CITIES WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE MIX IS THE HIGHEST -- STATE
WOULD NAY AMERICAN POPULATION SO
MAYBE EVEN DIALOGUE -- OUR DATA
THAT STARTS.
TO LOOK AT THE URBAN POPULATION
OF NATIVE AMERICANS WITHIN THE
CITIES THAT WE ALL RESIDE IT
WOULD BE A VERY -- WELCOMING
INFORMATION COMING OUR WAY
ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT AND QUESTIONS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL I'M
APOLOGIZING FOR COMING IN LATE
BUT I WAS ABLE TO CATCH A LITTLE
BIT -- WHILE PREPARING I AM
HAPPY TO SEE THAT QUITE A NUMBER
OF THE FOLKS WILL BE SPEAKING
TODAY ARE NOT ONLY FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BUT ALSO FROM THE
FIFTY FOURTH A SHOUT OUT TO NEW
EARTH -- AND ALSO -- VERY
EXCITED -- TO KNOW THAT THERE'S
CONTINUED INTEREST IN --
VOCATIONAL TRAINING AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
FUNDING AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT
TRICKLES DOWN -- I KNOW WHEN I
WAS AT THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WE HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED THE SECOND
CHANCE BOOT CAMP AND ALSO HIGHER
LA ACTS WHICH WORK TO CREATE A
PIPELINE. FOR A NUMBER OF THE
STUDENTS THAT WERE THERE IN --
TO LABOR ORGANIZATIONS AND ALSO
INTO CONSTRUCTION JOBS -- AT LA
ACTS. ONE THING THOUGH THAT I
THINK WE DON'T TALK A LOT ABOUT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING -- ARE SOME
OF THE LIFE SKILLS THAT ARE THAT
ARE NEEDED -- AND PROBABLY
DESIRED -- AND WE'RE SO FOCUSED
ON BOTH COLLECTING DATA AND THEN
PROVIDING FUNDING TO ACTUALLY
GET FOLKS INTO CAREERS -- BUT
THINKING ABOUT SOME OF THE SOFT
SKILLS -- THAT ARE EQUALLY
IMPORTANT AND THEN BEING ABLE TO
GET THE TRAINING AND THEN
ULTIMATELY BEING ABLE TO FIND
SUCCESSFUL EMPLOYMENT SO YOU
KNOW IF FINANCIAL LITERACY
FAMILY REUNIFICATION -- EXCEPT
ARE A SO DO YOU FIND THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE.
TACKLING APPROPRIATE LEAD DO YOU
THINK THAT WE COULD BE DOING
MORE.
AROUND THOSE ISSUES IN
INTEGRATING THAT INTO THE LARGER
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE HAVING
AROUND STATE FUNDING AND MAKING
AN IMPACT SURE YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- ABSOLUTELY AGREE -- A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS THEIR FIRST
IN OUR PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM -- LEARNING FROM SOME OF
OUR LESSONS -- FROM OUR AB
TWENTY SIXTY ARE PROP -- THIRTY
NINE PROGRAM -- ON ON
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS WHAT WE
FOUND -- IN LOOKING AT THE
PRELIMINARY DATA THAT WE
RECEIVED WAS THAT SUPPORTERS
SERVICES WAS ACTUALLY THE
GREATEST NEED.
AND SO WHEN WE SUBMITTED -- RBC
P. FOR THAT PROGRAM -- YOU KNOW
THE THE THE LARGEST CHUNK OF
FUNDS -- IN THAT PRISON TO
EMPLOYMENT GRANT PROGRAM WAS
ACTUALLY FOR SUPPORT OF SERVICES --
SECONDLY -- YOU KNOW WE ARE
LOOKING TO BUILD STRONGER
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CBO'S IN
COMMUNITIES -- WHAT WHAT WE SEE
IS THAT CBO'S ARE OFTEN BEST
PREPARED TO HELP DELIVER THOSE
SUPPORTERS SERVICES RIGHT RATHER
THAN YOU JUST KIND OF YOUR
TRADITIONAL C.T. E. R. R.
TRAINING AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS?
RIGHT THERE THERE ARE TRAINING
PARTNERS NO WE PARTNER WITH -- A
LOT OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
OTHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONAL --
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS -- TO
PROVIDE ACTUAL TRAINING -- BUT
RIGHT IT'S THE CBO'S RIGHT WHO
YOU KNOW.
HELP FOLKS WHO AFTER HOURS OR
BEFORE HOURS OR YOU KNOW IN THE
CASE OF OUR CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAMS DURING THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
RIGHT HELP THEM HELP MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE JOB READY AND
ARE GETTING THE SERVICES SO --
ABSOLUTELY AGREE -- WE WE ARE
MAKING -- A LARGER INVESTMENT
AGAIN AND I THINK PRESENCE ON
PLUMAS IS A GREAT INDICATOR OF
YOU KNOW AGAIN THE LARGEST.
SET OF FUNDS WAS IS DEDICATED TO
THOSE SUPPORT SERVICES.
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN RIGHT PARTING
WITH THOSE CBO'S -- TO HELP
DELIVER THOSE SERVICES RIGHT IN
ADDITION TO PREPARE THEM FOR AND
MAKE SURE THEY'RE SUCCEEDING.
IN TRAINING AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS -- YOU KNOW THE OTHER
THING THAT WE LOOK AT HIS JOB
RETENTION.
RIGHT AND AND ON THAT SIDE RIGHT
THAT'S MORE ON THE DEMAND SIDE
AND WE NEED TO BE DOING A BETTER
JOB OF WORKING WITH EMPLOYERS
FOR JOB RETENTION.
RIGHT A PERSON WHO'S FORMALLY
INCARCERATED A PERSON WITH
DISABILITIES RIGHT IT'S ONE
THING TO GET THEM TRAINING GET
THEM INTO A JOB.
RIGHT BUT WE NEED TO BE WORKING
WITH EMPLOYERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE MANAGERS WERE SUPERVISING
THESE FOLKS ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS.
RIGHT ALSO HAVE A LOT OF THOSE
SAME SKILLS -- SO THAT WE INSURE
RETENTION -- WITH OUR WITH OUR
WORK FORCE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
YES I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR OF
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
AND I KNOW IT'S NOT EASY WORK
IT'S HARD WORK THAT'S BEING DONE
AND AM SO NECESSARY. TO
APPRECIATE THAT ONE OF THE SAN
DIEGO IS IT IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT PLACE I'M SURE YOU
FIGURE THAT OUT BY NOW -- IN
TERMS OF PROGRAM YOU SEE A LOT
OF LA BUT YOU DON'T SEE A WHOLE
LOT OF SAN DIEGO.
AND THERE IS AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE WE FACE OF OF WITH THE
PRINT TO SHIP PROGRAMS.
IN SAN DIEGO MAKING SURE THAT WE
GET TO THE RIGHT KIDS WE ALSO
HAVE A REALLY SH -- DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE WITH AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALES GETTING INTO THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IN SAN
DIEGO IN THE AREA OF
CONSTRUCTION THAT ONLY SENEGAL
WOULD STATEWIDE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES -- WE'RE FACING AS A
BLACK CAUCUS IS LOOKING AT
VARIOUS CONSTRUCTION WORK SITES
EVEN HERE WITH WHAT'S GOING ON
ACROSS THE STREET.
AND NOT SEEING ANY FACES IN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN FACES ON THOSE
WORK SITES AT ALL.
AND AND WE BUILT OF FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE WITHOUT AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN FACE AT ALL ON THE WORK
SITE FOR THE USE THAT WAS DONE.
SO THERE IS A GROWING CONCERN
AND AND WHEN I GO TO I I
REGULARLY GO TO PRINT A SHIP
GRADUATIONS WITH LABOR.
AND I HAVE YET TO SEE AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN GRADUATE FROM AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM IN THE
LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS.
SO I'M YOU KNOW I'M KIND OF
WONDERING WHAT ARE YOU DOING
ANYTHING DIFFERENT BECAUSE
THERE'S A GROWING CONCERN THAT
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
OF NO CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THOSE
KIND OF THINGS THAT THERE IS
JUST A AN ABSENCE OF A OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AND I'VE DONE
SEVERAL THINGS TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE IN IT AND AND THAT'S BEEN
RELATIVELY SUCCESSFUL BUT THEN --
FORGET GET LABOR INVOLVED I
DON'T KNOW HOW INVOLVED THEY ARE
WITH YOU BECAUSE I KNOW WE HAVE
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE DOING
THINGS AND THEN THEY CAN'T GET
THE THE JOBS FROM LABOR TO
BASICALLY PARTICIPATE IN OUR
PRINT YOUR PROGRAM SO.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE BEING
MORE SUCCESSFUL -- I'D BE
INTERESTED IN KNOWING BECAUSE
THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE THAT HAS
BEEN RAISED IN OUR IN IN THE
SENATE COMMUNITY -- NOT BEING
REYES WHO IN SACRAMENTO THAT I'M
MEETING WITH SOME FOLKS ABOUT
THE CONSTRUCTION GOING ACROSS
THE STREET.
AND THERE ARE NO AFRICAN
AMERICANS ON THE WORK SITE.
SO IT IT'S BECOMING A STATEWIDE
ISSUE THE POPULATION SMALL BUT
IT'S NOT ZERO SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE ARE WHERE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE GOING TO
DIVERSIFY.
OF THE WORK FORCE ENOUGH THAT WE
SEE BEGINS THE BASES THAT ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
RIGHT -- SO WE DO PARTNER --
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES OF AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- ON ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS.
EXCUSE ME ONE OF THE AS PART OF
OUR HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS WE DO WORK QUITE A BIT
ON COMMITTED WORKFORCE
AGREEMENTS -- WITH BUILDERS AND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES -- TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS DIVERSITY
WITHIN THE WORK FORCE THEY'RE
USING -- ON CONSTRUCTION SITES
SO THAT'S ONE TOOL -- THAT WE
HAVE AND THAT WE USE AS PART OF
THIS A LARGE PART OF WHY WE'RE
PURSUING -- HI ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS -- IS BECAUSE THERE IS
AN EQUITY AGENDA THAT IS BUILT
INTO THAT -- THERE ARE YOU KNOW
A VARIETY OF OF OF REASONS WHY --
WE DON'T QUITE HAVE THE THE
EQUITY IN THE DIVERSITY -- OF
OUR CONSTRUCTION TRADES
WORKFORCE THAT SOMETHING -- THAT
WE PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH THEM ON AND SO WHAT WE DO
IN OUR PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS.
RIGHT IS IT WORK WITH CBO'S TO
DRAW FROM FROM COMMUNITIES RIGHT
WE CALL THAT YOU KNOW ARE.
THE CALL UP SKILL BACK FILM
RIGHT AS WE CAN MOVE IN A
WORKERS AB -- WHETHER IT'S IN
CONSTRUCTION OR IN PUBLIC SECTOR
JOBS OR OTHER INDUSTRIES WHERE
WE HAVE GOOD JOB QUALITY.
RIGHT WE WORK TO TO BUILD
WORKERS UP AND THEN WE WORK WITH
CBO'S RIGHT TO DRAW IN ON ON THE
BACK FEEL SIDE.
RIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
ARE READY -- IN DO HAVE -- THE
PRE APPRENTICESHIP SKILLS TO GET
INTO APPRENTICESHIP RIGHT
APPRENTICESHIPS HAVE CERTAIN
STANDARDS A LOT OF TIME BUT IF
YOU DON'T COME FROM A
CONSTRUCTION FAMILY IF YOUR
MOTHER FATHER WAS NOT A
CONSTRUCTION WORKER OR IN THE
BUILDING TRADES YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT FAMILIARITY.
WITH HOW THE TRADES WORKING --
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T KNOW THE THE
ENTRY LEVEL REQUIREMENTS -- OF
YOU KNOW OF A PARTICULAR TRADE
AND SO WHAT ARE PREPARE THE SHIP
PROGRAMS DO IS WORK THAT CBO'S
ARE ACTUALLY DELIVERING A LOT OF
THESE.
SERVICES FOR PRE APPRENTICESHIP
IN GETTING FOLKS READY AND THEN
WE WORK RIGHT WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN THE LOCAL FOR
PLACEMENT -- INTO APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS -- SO SO WE ARE WORKING
HARD ON THAT YOU KNOW THERE IS
STILL A LOT OF WORK TO DO AND WE
YOU KNOW WE'D BE HAPPY TO TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU -- ON THAT
AND HOW IT'S GOING INTO YOU KNOW
SHOW YOU SOME OF OUR OTHER
MODELS -- AND I'D BE ABLE IT IN
SAYING THAT AS WELL AS SEEING
WITH THE NUMBERS LOOK LIKE AT
THE END.
OF THOSE YOU CAN GET INTO THE
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS -- BECAUSE
LIKE I SAID YOU KNOW WE WE OFTEN
SAY EVERYBODY'S NOT GOING TO
COLLEGE THAT'S TRUE WE RISE NOT
GOING TO COLLEGE -- BUT WHERE
THEY GOING IT WOULD NOT OPENING
UP SOME OF THESE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM.
AND SO THAT'S OF MAJOR CONCERN
IN SAN DIEGO I AND I KNOW
THERE'S BETTER SUCCESS RATES IN
OTHER PLACES THEY TELL ME.
BUT WE ARE STRUGGLING IN SAN
DIEGO WITH OUR PRINTER PROGRAM
AND OUT AND WHETHER IT'S THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR DIRECTLY
WITH LABOR I THINK THEY'VE
STRUCK SOME ADDITIONAL
AGREEMENTS BUT NONE THE LESS AS
I SAID AS I GO TO THE
GRADUATIONS -- ON A REGULAR
BASIS I HAVE I HAVE YET TO SEE
FOLKS WHO LOOK LIKE ME
GRADUATING IN THOSE PROGRAMS AND
YET I KNOW THERE ARE LOTS OF
KIDS.
WHO NEED SOMETHING TO DO WHO
NEEDS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET INTO
A A GOOD PAYING JOB?
THAT HAS A CAREER YOU KNOW
THAT'S THE AND SO IF IT'S AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE ABSOLUTELY I'D
BE INTERESTED IN SEEING YOUR
NUMBERS AND WHAT YOU'RE DOING
SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR THIS LACKEY.
YEAH JUST REAL QUICKLY ON THAT
THAT PARTICULAR FRONT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT.
IN MY DISTRICT THERE'S BEEN SOME
GREAT PARTNERSHIPS AS A TO YOUTH
BUILD WHICH IS A REALLY GREAT
ORGANIZATION.
THAT HAS PARTNERED WITH OUR CITY
AND THEY HAVE SOME REALLY IS
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THAT HAVE -- BROUGHT PEOPLE IN
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE IRON
WORKERS.
AND DOCTOR WHERE WILL BE VERY
HAPPY TO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE
HER THAT ARE BEING VERY
SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATED IN THAT
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU LET ME UP AND TO HAVE
A QUESTION.
JT THE OVERVIEW OF ALL OF THE
FUNDING -- AVAILABILITIES THAT
ARE OUT THERE CERTAINLY
MENTIONING SOME OF THOSE THAT
WILL BE ROLLED OUT IN A VERY.
VERY SHORT FUTURE.
NEAR FUTURE -- THERE WAS A A SIX
MILLION DOLLAR OF LOCAL
JURISDICTION FUNDING THAT WAS
NOT AWARDED DUE TO LACK OF
APPLICANTS AND I'M SURE THAT
THAT.
KINDA RESONATED WITH EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM -- UGLY CONSTANT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT NOT ENOUGH
FUNDING.
AND CAN YOU CAN YOU ELABORATE ON
WHAT THE THAT CHALLENGE.
IS A LOOKING LIKE AND WHAT ARE
THOSE CRITERIAS IF YOU HAVE THE
INFORMATION ON IT.
SO I DON'T HAVE THAT SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ON THE CRITERIA THAT
WASN'T MATT -- I WOULD SAY THE
WAR ADDITIONAL GRANT APPLICANTS
THEY JUST DIDN'T MEET THAT
CRITERIA THAT WAS SET.
FOR AND SO THE FCC DID NOT AWARD
THE FUNDING FOR THEM SO ONE
THING IF WE COULD FOLLOW UP WITH
WOULD BE GREAT TO KNOW WHAT
THOSE CRITERIAS ARE.
AND THE WHITE IS THAT -- YOU
KNOW PARK ME BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OR OTHER LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
NOT MEETING THOSE.
CRITERIA IS AND THE FACT THAT
WE'RE LEAVING SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE FOR THIS
VERY IMPORTANT WORK.
CERTAINLY I'M SURE EVERYONE HERE
IS INTERESTED IN SEEING HOW WE
GET THAT ON THE GROUND
PARTICULARLY THE THE GROUPS ARE
HERE DOING THE REAL WORK AND THE
EXPENSE OF NETWORKS THAT THEY
HAVE.
AND THE LOCAL COMMUNITY SO THAT
WOULD BE ONE QUESTION.
I DID WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT THE
PUBLIC POLICIES TO CALIFORNIA
RECENTLY CAME OUT WITH A REPORT.
AS THEY WOULD CLAIM IS BECAUSE
THE FIRST DEEP DIVE.
LOOKING AT BOTH -- REALIGNMENT --
ONE ONLINE AND PROP FORTY SEVEN
AGAIN COULD ANY OF YOU MAYBE
COME ELABORATE ON SOME OF THAT
AND HOW IT TIES INTO.
SOME OF THE FUNDING -- THAT
YOU'VE HIGHLIGHTED HERE IN THIS
FIRST THE FIRST THE PANEL. TO
SORT OF OR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SO YOU ARE RIGHT PP I SEE
HAS DONE -- A LOOK AT PROP FORTY
SEVEN IN THE TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT TO SEE.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH OF THOSE
MEASURES CONTRIBUTED TO CHANGES
IN CRIME IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY DID IS
THEY TRIED.
PROJECT WHAT CRIME IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD HAVE DONE IF THOSE
MEASURES WEREN'T PASSED BY
LOOKING AT STATES OTHER STATES.
THAT HAD SIMILAR CRIME PATTERNS
TO CALIFORNIA BUT DIDN'T HAVE A
MEASURE LIKE PROP FORTY SEVEN OF
THE TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT.
HOUSE AND IN THEIR ANALYSIS THEY
FOUND THAT -- PROP FORTY SEVEN
IN THE TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
DID NOT APPEAR TO CONTRIBUTE TO
ANY INCREASES IN CRIME IN
CALIFORNIA -- THEY DID FIND SOME
EVIDENCE THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THOSE MEASURES MAY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO AN INCREASE IN
AUTO THEFTS -- BUT NO NO THEY
WERE ABLE TO DETERMINE ARE THEY
WERE ABLE TO SHOW THAT THERE IS
ANY OTHER.
INCREASES IN CRIME I WILL SAY
THAT SOME OF THE CRITICS OF PROP
FORTY SEVEN HAVE ARGUED THAT --
CRIMES AREN'T BEING REPORTED --
AND SO THEY WOULD SUGGEST THAT
DESPITE THE EVIDENCE CRIME IS
GOING UP BUT BECAUSE THERE'S NO
WAY TO ASSESS WHETHER THAT'S THE
CASE BECAUSE IT'S A LACK OF DATA
RATHER THAN DATA.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO ASSESS
WHETHER WHETHER THAT'S TRUE.
GOT A QUESTION REGARDS TO THE
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTERS -- HAVE
WE SEEN EN EXPANSION OF THOSE
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN
THE LAST FOUR FIVE YEARS.
ARE THEY THE SAME CENTERS ARE
THAT WE'VE HAD FOR SOME TIME I'M
JUST CURIOUS TO KNOW HOW -- WERE
ADDRESSING THAT THE TRAUMA
CENTER AND NEEDS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEING THAT
THERE IS A STRONG -- ASSERTIVE
EFFORT TO TRY TO FUND THE
CENTERS OF UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
THEY SAID THERE WERE AS I NOTED
EARLIER THAT PROGRAM STARTED
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THAT
WAS BEFORE THE SECOND FUNDING
STREAM OF THE PROP FORTY SEVEN
MONEY KICKED IN.
AND SO IT ORIGIN IT WAS JUST A
HANDFUL OF LOCATIONS -- WHEN
THAT FUNDING BEGAN -- THAT PROP
FORTY SEVEN PHONED IN WHICH IS
10% 10% THE PROPERTY SEVEN
FINING CAME INTO IT -- IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THAT INCREASE
THE NUMBER SUBSTANTIALLY.
BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE HAD --
NUMBER DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
COMING -- TO OUR OFFICE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEED TO EXPAND THESE
RECOVERY TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTERS.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND SO
THAT'S WHY I ASKED QUESTION.
I ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS FROM THE
PRESENTERS LIKE -- TO TO WRAP UP
WITH.
IN ON ITSELF THANK YOU FOR
GIVING US AN OVERVIEW OF THE
FUNDING AVAILABILITY AND I'M
SURE THAT THERE ARE SOME
PARTNERS HERE IN THE AUDIENCE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE INTERESTED
IN.
HEARING AND WHEN WHO WHERE WHAT
WHEN AND HOW.
ARE THEY MAY BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THOSE DOLLARS AND CERTAINLY
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE CRITERIA IS I THINK WE
WE WANT TO KNOW.
WHAT IT IS THAT WE NEED TO
CHANGE THEIR IN ORDER FOR THOSE
DOLLARS TO GET ROLLED OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THAT NEED
THEM?
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THEN ASK -- THE POLICY LINK --
MARK FILL PART.
THAT FOLLOWS THE FAMILIES THE
JOAQUIN.
I MEAN UNIONS CALIFORNIA DOMINO
OVER MODEL MODEL.
NATIONAL COMBAT IS NETWORK JERRY
DALE JR VALUE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD MEMBER NEPALI
COLLAPSE AT TO PLEASE A JOIN US
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HOLA WILL START PRESENTATIONS IN
THAT SPECIFIC ORDER YOU ALL
ABOUT FIVE SIX MINUTES EACH --
TO TO PRESENT
.
HI BUT WORK.
AND THAT [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU FOR HOSTING TODAY'S
HEARING AND CONTINUING IMPORTANT
ADVOCACY.
PUBLIC EDUCATION IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE TO HAVE MATH
POLICY AND SYSTEMS CHANGE ON
BEHALF OF BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
THEIR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
MY NAME IS MARK FILL PART I'M A
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF POLICY LIKE.
POLICYMAKERS A FOUNDING MEMBER --
AND ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS TO MEN OF
COLOR.
THE ALLIANCE IS A NATIONAL
NETWORK OF HUNDREDS OF ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS HAVE COME TOGETHER TO
ADVANCE RACE AN GENDER JUSTICE.
BY EXPANDING OPPORTUNITY IN
TRANSFORMING STATE AND LOCAL
POLICIES THAT ARE FAILING BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES.
CORONATED BY POLICY LINK THE
ALLIANCE HAS DEEP ROOTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH REPRESENTATION
OF FIFTEEN COMMUNITIES.
INCLUDING COOKS ALLOWED THOUGH
NOR YOU SALINAS FRESNO LA COUNTY
OAKLAND RICHMOND RIVERSIDE
SACRAMENTO SAN BERNADINO SAN
DIEGO SAN JOAQUIN SANTANA.
SAN JOSE AND CINEMA.
AS I REFLECT ON THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS AND THE PROGRESS AND
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE ALLIANCE OF
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR THEIR
LEGISLATIVE VICTORIES.
THESE VICTORIES HAVE -- BROUGHT
SO MUCH MORE TO COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE MORE
STUDENTSARE GETTING CONNECTED
TO THE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO THRIVE.
SAID BEEN PUSHED OUT OF SCHOOL
AND INTO THE PUNISHMENT SYSTEM.
OUR STATE IS GREATER POLICE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
LOS.
FEWER PEOPLE ARE FINDING
THEMSELVES IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WE'VE IMPROVED ACCESS TO
GOOD JOBS FOR WORKERS WHO ARE
LOCKED OUT OF OPPORTUNITY.
BUT THE REAL STORY OF THE
ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR IS THE ONE OF INDIVIDUALS.
FROM LEADERS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE WHO HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY RACISM AND JUST
POLICIES AND PRACTICES.
COMING TOGETHER AND BUILDING
COMMUNITY POWER TO CHANGE THOSE
LAWS.
SO WHEN I TALK ABOUT THE
ALLIANCE OFTEN LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT A YOUNG MAN BY THE NAME OF
BRENDA HARRISON.
THE LES BRENDA HARRISON FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF HIS COMRADES ARE HERE
TODAY.
BRANDON EXEMPLIFY WHAT THE
ALLIANCE IS ALL ABOUT HE WAS A
YOUNG MAN WHO HAD BEEN
REPEATEDLY VICTIMIZED BY SCHOOL
SYSTEMS.
ARE BY HARSH DISCIPLINARY
PRACTICES [inaudible]
HE WAS IN MANY WAYS CAST OUT.
AND FOUND A HOME WITH FATHERS OF
FAMILIES AND YOU'LL HEAR FROM
SAMMY IN JUST A MOMENT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
DISORGANIZATION.
FOUND A HOME AT FATHERS OF
FAMILIES FOUND A PLACE WHERE HE
BELONGED AND WAS INSTANTLY
POLITICIZED. TO CHANGE THE
SITUATION THAT HE HAD PLACED
HIMSELF AS HE GREW UP IN
STOCKTON.
HAVING BEEN SUSPENDED AND
EXPELLED MULTIPLE TIMES HE WAS
COMMITTED.
TO REVISING HARSH DISCIPLINARY
PRACTICES.
ADVOCATING FOR CHANGES IN THE
EDUCATION CODE THAT WOULD LIMIT.
THE ABILITY FOR TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS TO SUSPEND EXPEL
WITH RECKLESS ABANDON -- REALLY
PUSHING A POWERFUL AGENDA FOR
CHANGE THAT WAS BIRTH FROM HIS
OWN EXPERIENCE AS I LIKE TO SAY
BRANDON MATE BUT HIS MASS HIS
MESSAGE -- AND HE WAS OF A VERY
PROVOCATIVE AND POWERFUL YOUNG
LEADER.
THAT IS THE ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR A NETWORK OF
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS YOU
THINK COMMUNITY LEADERS
ADVOCATES RESEARCHERS.
AND OTHERS WHO ARE FORMING
POWERFUL PARTNERSHIPS TO DEEPEN
IMPACT AND BUILD THE COLLECTIVE
CAPACITY TO DRIVE CHANGE.
SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN YOUNG PEOPLE
LIKE BRANDON AND OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HAVE WORKED TO CREATE A VISION
FOR WORLD THAT'S ROOTED IN IN
UNITY.
ROOTED IN EQUITY.
ROOTED IN A QUALITY FREEDOM AND
JUSTICE THAT'S BASED ON MUTUAL
SUPPORT STRENGTH LEADERSHIP AND
LOVE.
WHERE THEIR VALUES?
AS WHOLE PEOPLE.
AND THAT ALLOWS THEM TO FEEL
SAFE AND FOSTERS THEIR COURAGE
TO BE ABLE TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
CHANGE THAT THEY HOPE TO SEE.
AND TOGETHER WE'VE COLLECTIVELY
ADVANCED.
SAFE AND THRIVING COMMUNITIES
WHICH HAVE ENDED CYCLES OF
VIOLENCE IN RELATIONSHIPS THAT
COMMUNITIES BY ADDRESSING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF HARM.
INCLUDING TOXIC MASCULINITY
POVERTY -- I'M JUST POLICING IN
AN EQUAL ACCESS TO RESOURCES.
WE'VE WORKED TO BUILD ECONOMIC
SECURITY SO NOBODY EXPERIENCES
THE INJUSTICE OF POVERTY WE
FOSTERED EDUCATIONAL EQUITY BY
DISMANTLING THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
AND WE'RE MOVING THE STATE FROM
MASS INCARCERATION TO DIVESTMENT
INDYCAR SERRATIA.
THIS IS THE VISION AND THE WORK
OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN GRASSROOTS
LEADERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS MOVEMENT WAS SPARKED BY
EXAMINING THE ISSUES THAT DEEPLY
EMPAT BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
BUT IT DIDN'T STOP THERE.
THE BARRIERS AND THE SYSTEMIC
INJUSTICES FACING BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR ALSO.
THE THE SAME THINGS THAT IMPACT
OTHER MARGINALIZED AND BOUGHT A
BOOK COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING GIRLS AND WOMEN
OF COLOR.
THOSE WHO IDENTIFY AS QUEER
TRANCE AND GENDER NON CONFORMING
AND CALIFORNIANS LIVING IN DEEP.
POVERTY.
BIRLIKTE VERY EARLY ON THE
FOUNDING OF THE ALLIANCE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE MOST POWERFUL
MANIFESTATION OF THE VISION FOR
OUR NETWORK WAS ONE THAT WAS
INCLUSIVE AND THAT ALLOWED THE
LEADERSHIP AND PARTICIPATION OF
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR TO BE AT
THE FOREFRONT.
WHILE PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR JOINED THE WORK
TO ADVANCE THE SOLUTIONS THEY
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES NEED.
WE'VE CREATED SPACE FOR THESE
LEADERS. TO BRING THEIR
EXPERTISE AND LIVED EXPERIENCE
TO BEAR TO WIN POLICY BILL POWER.
DEEP IN IMPACT AND DISMANTLE
RACISTS AND THEN JUST SYSTEMS.
ABOVE ALL THIS THIS MOVEMENT AS
PRIORITIZE THE VOICE AND
LEADERSHIP OF YOUTH OF COLOR WE
HELP YOU THINK COMMUNITY LEADERS
DEVELOP AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
CHANGE THAT THEY WANT TO SEE IN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS IN REGIONS.
AND OVER THE PAST EIGHT YEARS
WE'VE A BASS OVER A HUNDRED
BILLS WHICH HAVE BEEN SIGNED
INTO LAW.
THE SUCCESS OF THE REPLICA IS A
REFLECTION OF THE POWER OF YOU
THINK GRASSROOTS LEADERS AND A
TESTAMENT OF THEIR LEADERSHIP OF
CRITICAL PARTNERS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA FUNDERS FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR WHO YOU'LL HEAR
FROM.
A NETWORK OF FOURTEEN
PHILANTHROPIC AT THE TWO
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA OUT WORKING TO
ADVANCE THE CHANGE THAT WE'VE
OUTLINED.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE'S
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND ALL OF YOU WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING AND REALLY UP
HOLDING THIS -- GROUND BREAKING
BODY -- THAT HAS REALLY CAUGHT
THE EYE OF THE NATION -- IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS BUT IT CAN'T BE
MENTIONED ENOUGH THAT -- WE
REALLY OWE A DEBT OF GRATITUDE
TO VISIONARY LEADERS ASSEMBLY
SPEAKERS KAREN BASS AND OPERATE
AS THE INAUGURAL CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE SENTRY SWANSON
AND SOME OF THE MEMBERS WHO
PARTICIPATED LIKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VICTOR MANUEL PEREZ.
ALL REALLY CHARTED THE COURSE
THAT WE'RE ON IN THIS VERY
MOMENT.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE HAS BEEN --
CRITICAL PIECE TO THE SUCCESS.
THE WORK OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AND OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUNDERS FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR.
AND THIS VERY UNIQUE ORGANIZING
MODEL IS ONE THAT IS -- BEING
PARTICULARLY -- EXAMINED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THE MY BROTHER'S KEEPER ALLIANCE
AND ALL OTHERS WHO ARE LOOKING
TO ADVANCE THIS MOVEMENT FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY -- THIS MODEL ONLY
CURRENTLY EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE YOU HAVE ORGANIZING
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND IN THE
GRASS ROOTS.
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND AMONG
FUNDERS -- BUT OTHERS ARE TAKING
NOTE STATES LIKE LOUISIANA AND
FLORIDA ARE TRYING TO MAYOR WHAT
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED -- THIS
STRATEGY.
IS ALSO BEING REPLICATED FOR
OTHER POPULATIONS WHICH I THINK
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE -- GIRLS
AND WOMEN OF COLOR ARE BEGINNING
BEGINNING TO ORGANIZE IN THE
SAME WAY.
AND WE HAVE TO SUPPORT THOSE
EFFORTS -- BECAUSE OUR ULTIMATE
END GOAL IS JUSTICE -- AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE ALL SHARE.
THE FUTURE OF THE MOVEMENT FOR
THE BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR WORK
IN CALIFORNIA IS A BRIGHT.
ONE OUR NETWORK HAS FOUND COMMON
CAUSE WITH THE CONSOLATION OF
LEADERS THAT FULLY REPRESENT A
BROAD RANGE OF ISSUES -- FACING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ALL OVER
THE STATE.
IN ADDITION HE WORK HAS
EXPANDED BEYOND THE TRADITIONAL
SET OF ISSUES THAT -- ARE
COMMONLY UNDERSTOOD AS
CHALLENGES FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR.
SO RECENTLY THE ALLIANCE'S
CENTERED AND PRIORITIZE WORK
FOCUSED ON ENDING VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN COMBATING MISOGYNY.
AND DISMANTLING PATRIARCHY.
WE GOT INTO THIS WORK BECAUSE
THAT EXPERIENCE MEN WERE FACING
WITH VIOLENCE.
AT THE TIME THE ONLY WAY THAT WE
WERE LOOKING AT THIS WAS TO THE
THE ANGLE OF SEEING MEN AS
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE.
LOOKING AT LIFE EXPECTANCY FOR
MEN.
BUT THEN AS WE STARTED TO GET
DEEPER INTO UNDERSTANDING
VIOLENCE WE WE COULDN'T WALK
AWAY FROM THE FACT THAT -- IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES MEN WERE
CAUSING HARM.
AND THAT HARM THAT THEY WERE
CAUSING WAS PART OF UNRESOLVED
TRAUMA.
AND SO WE HAD TO GET AT THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THAT.
SO WE'RE ADVANCING POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS THAT WILL ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES.
THIS TYPE OF LEARNING COMES FROM
A DEEP RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR IN OUR
NETWORK THE DYNAMIC PARTNERSHIP
WITH LEGISLATORS -- AND THE
WILLINGNESS OF FUNDERS AND
OTHERS -- TO WALK WITH US ON
EXPLORING THESE ISSUES.
AS I WRAP UP I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP
AND SUPPORT.
YOUR COMMITMENT TO OUR YOUTH ARE
COMMUNITIES HAS INSPIRED
HUNDREDS OF LEADERS TO ENGAGE IN
A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHICH MANY
HAVE SEEN AS HOSPO.
AND NOT FOR THEM.
THESE LEADERS CONTINUE TO HAVE
FAITH IN THE POLICY MAKING
PRODUCT PROCESS BECAUSE OF THE
SPACE YOU'VE CREATED.
AND THEIR BELIEF AND YOUR
SERIOUS COMMITMENT TO A MORE
JUST SOCIETY.
I BELIEVE AND OUR PARTNERSHIP IN
OUR SUCCESS.
HAS BEEN PREDICATED ON AN
UNSHAKABLE BELIEF THAT TOGETHER
WE KNOW THAT WE WILL WIN THANK
YOU [inaudible]
MR NEWNESS -- NO SHAPE NOT MEANT.
TO ALEICHEM -- ONE OFFER --
THANKS TO BROTHER MARK. FOR LIVE
IN THE FINAL RENDON.
RENDON WAS MURDERED.
ON OCTOBER FIFTEENTH.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I WANNA OFFERED
THANKS FOR ALL THE LESSONS
BRANDED LEFT FOR US.
I WANT TO OFFER THANKS TO HIS
MOTHER.
LISA HARRISON WAS CONTINUE IN
HIS NAME THE STRUGGLE.
THAT'S SOME INDICATION OF US.
AS A STATE.
WHAT BETTER IN OUR VOICE?
AT THAT CUT DOUBLE RATE.
OUR GREATEST ALLIES ARE MOMS OF
COLOR.
WHO BRING THOSE THEIR BOYS BRING
THOSE THEIR HUSBANDS AFTER THEY
GET OUT OF THE JOINT?
AND SAY PLEASE HELP OTHER ONE
LOOSE MY SON.
WHEN I JUST DIDN'T HAVE THIS
ORGANIZED LIKE THIS?
BUT HER I JUST GOT TO SAY.
YOU KNOW THE LAST TIME I SAW
BRANDON WAS AT SATURDAY WHEN HE
WAS ACTUALLY ON HIS OWN TIME
RUNNING A HEALING CIRCLE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT OUR YOUNG MEN WE
WILL TELL THOSE STORIES ENOUGH.
HE WAS A PASSIONATE YOUNG MAN.
WOULD BE FILLED BY THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM SUSPENDED SEVERAL TIMES
PUSHED INTO INCARCERATION I KNOW
I WAS THERE WHEN HE CAME OUT OF
JUVENILE HALL.
KICKING AND SCREAMING TO OUR
AGENCY I WAS THERE THE FIRST
TIME WE TOOK A FLIGHT I WAS
THERE THE FIRST TIME HE
PRESENTED I WAS THERE AND YOU
WANT AND THE CHIEF OF PROVISIONS
OFFICE.
AND I SAID WE NEED TO GET ON MY
PROBATION IT'S TIME TO LET HIM
GO.
THAT DAY.
THAT DAY ONE BRANDON WAS MET
THAT EVENING HE WAS MURDERED THE
LAST THING I SAID TO HIM.
WAS I LOVE YOU ME HOPE.
IS THAT I LOVE YOU AND I'LL SEE
YOU MONDAY.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT YOU
MOVING TO THE CALIFORNIA DON'T
MEAN DOING ALL THIS GREAT WORK
BECAUSE EVERYONE WANTS NOW.
BACK THEN THEY DIDN'T LIKE
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE HOT THEY'RE
ALL ON THIS.
THAT'S THE STORY OF BOYS AND MEN
THE GOVERNOR IS IN IT.
BACK THEN THEY DIDN'T WANT A
GERMAN WE STARTED THIS WORK IT
WAS LIKE ALL YOU CAN DO IS YOUR
RIVERS RIGHT WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WERE BURIED OUR BOYS.
THERE'S NOTHING WHAT IS WHAT IS.
HE SAID HE SAYS TO ME THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE ONE OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN MY TOWN.
IN MY COUNTY NICE TO WHAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE BUT SAVE IN OUR
KIDS LIVES.
WELL THAT'S WHAT WE HEAR ABOUT
RIGHT NOW WE STARTED THIS WORK A
TWO ONE THEY ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
YOU CHAIRMAN AND THE SELECT
COMMITTEE FOR JUST ALLOW ME TO
JUST BREATHE A LITTLE BIT AND
SAY THAT ABOUT THAT MUCH.
OF ABOUT MY NEPHEW BRANDON
HARRISON MAY YOU REST IN PEACE
AND ALL THE YOUNG MEN WHO ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW AND HANG
HANG ON OUR DECISIONS RIGHT NOW.
HOW OLD ARE WE GOING TO BE?
IS A RADICAL TO THINK THAT OUR
YOUNG MEN DESERVE BETTER AND ALL
I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK IT'S REALLY WE NEED A
BAND THAT ARC OF JUSTICE WE NEED
TO MOVE IT.
SO WE STARTED THIS WORK ONE
BEFORE THAT WAS AN ALLIANCE WE
STARTED WITH THIS WELL AS HE
DOES NOW.
AS A MATTER OF FACT IT WAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT THE TIME THAT
CO FOUNDED THIS FROM THE
COACHELLA VALLEY SO WE'VE ALWAYS
HAD THIS CAN SHIP RELATIONSHIP.
BECAUSE IN THE END AND PART OF
THE STATE THE BACKBONE
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHERE THE MASS
INCARCERATION REALLY TOOK SHAPE.
AND WE WERE LOCKING UP BOYS AND
MEN FOR THE MOST RIDICULOUS OF
THINGS SO WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
THE ANALYTICS LET'S GO BACK A
LITTLE BIT.
AND REALIZE THE COMPLEXITIES OF
REALITIES THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY
FORCED OUR YOUNG MEN AND JUST
SURVIVE.
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO RIGHT NOW JUST
SURVIVE BUT THEN WHEN THE LIGHTS
CAME UP I FELT LIKE IT WAS -- IT
IT REALLY TRANSCENDED ANY SINGLE
ISSUE CAMPAIGN BECAUSE AT THE
HEART OF ANY IS ONE SINGLE ONE
OF THESE ISSUES YOU GO FIVE BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR AT THE ACTUAL
CENTER PIECE OF THIS.
SO WHEN WE STARTED THIS WORK ONE
BEFORE THAT WAS ACTUAL ON THE
LIGHTS FORM THE IDEOLOGY OF THIS
WORK WE MET AND WE START TALKING
WITH ELDERS YOUNG ORGANIZERS AND
AND FOLKS THAT WE'RE DOING
HEALING WORK AND WE BROUGHT IT
ALL TOGETHER AND ACTUALLY MADE
SOME GUMBEL OUT OF IT.
AND HERE WE ARE TODAY.
WHERE WE ARE TODAY SO EVERYONE
CAN FEED FROM THIS RIGHT
EVERYONE HAS A PLACE OF THE
TABLE SO I WANT TO JUST SAY THAT?
THE THE WORK IN STOCKTON HAS
BENEFITTED TREMENDOUSLY BY THIS
WORK IN YOUR BODY AT YOUR
DECISIONS STOCKTON HAS BEEN
TRANSFORMED STOCK AND AT ONE
POINT WAS THE MORTGAGE MELTDOWN
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD IT WAS THE
LARGEST METROPOLITAN CITY TO
FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY.
IN THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD.
IT WAS ACTUALLY A STATE WHERE
YOU AT A HIGHER IT WAS THE CITY
WE GOT A HIGHER CHANCE OF
GETTING SHOT MURDERED.
THEN YOU DID IN CHICAGO OR IRAQ
AT THE TIME.
AND THERE WAS WE CAME AND
PLEADED WE HAVE THE HIGHEST RATE
OF SCHOOL SUSPENSION WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST RATE POLICING IN SCHOOL
THAN CITATIONS GIVEN TO YOUNG
PEOPLE OF COLOR SO MUCH SO.
THAT THE DEAL J. ACTUALLY JUST
SETTLE WITH OUR DISTRICT AND
SAID THOSE POLICIES WERE
DISCRIMINATORY.
THERE WERE RACES POLICIES WHAT
THEY SAID SO HOW DO YOU HILL
FROM RACISM GOT A KNOWLEDGE OF
FIRST.
WE GOT A KNOWLEDGE OF WE'RE
GOING TO HEAL FROM IT FIRST.
AND THOSE WERE POLICIES BORN OF
THE SPIRIT TREATMENT IN THE
COLLECTED DIRECTLY TARGETED OUR
PEOPLE SO AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE HOUSING MARKET THE VIOLENCE
RATE.
THE EDUCATION HAVE THE HIGHEST
RATE OF ILLITERACY SO WHAT IS
THE ANSWER TO THAT CAN YOU
LEGISLATE LOVE.
GOOD WE'VE BEEN REALLY GOOD
ABOUT LEGISLATING HATE IN THE
STATE BUT I SEE IT HAPPENING NOW
WHEN THERE'S EVIDENCE OF THAT
MIGHT WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU ALL TALKED ABOUT
WE'RE REALLY RESONATED WITH US
BECAUSE WHAT WE SEE RIGHT NOW ON
THE GROUND.
IS THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY TAKING A
LOT OF THIS THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING AND TRANSFORMING OUR CITY
WE HAVE THE YOUNGEST AND FIRST
BLACK MAYOR IN OUR CITY THAT WAS
REALLY.
AREN'T OR GALVANIZING POINT IN
OUR CITY WE ARE ACTUALLY ONE OF
ELEVEN TOM RECOVERY CENTERS AND
HAVE AN EXCELLENT TRACK RECORD
TO PROVIDE THE HEALING SERVICES.
TO THE YOUNG MEN OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR WHO MAKE UP
CONSTITUTE THE HIGHEST RATE OF
BY THAT GUN BY THE HOMICIDES THE
QUESTION HOW MANY OF RECEIVED.
IMPERATIVE HEALING SERVICES NONE.
THE REACTION FROM THE STATE HAS
BEEN INCARCERATION IN AND
POLICING.
AND THIS ACTUAL BODY AT THAT
POINT TEN YEARS AGO WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT OF THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE STATE
BUDGET WAS AT AND NOW WE
ACTUALLY WHISPERING A UNIVERSITY
IN STOCKTON.
THERE'S WHISPERS OF THAT RIGHT
NOW SO IT'S GOING TO BE
INTERESTING AND THAT WASN'T
POSSIBLE BEFORE.
AS A YOUNG MAN I WILL SAY THIS
THAT ARE AT FIVE YEARS OLD I
STOOD UP TO DOMESTIC COULD TO
VIOLENCE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
AT THIRTEEN YEARS OLD PUSHED OUT
OF SCHOOL FIFTEEN YEARS ON THE
CLOSER TO JUVENILE HALL EVERY
SINGLE TIME ONE OF THESE MODES
ISSUES HAPPEN I WISH SOMEBODY
WAS THERE.
I WISH SOMEBODY WAS THERE
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO MAN THERE
MIGHT IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD MOMS
WORKING TWO OR THREE JOBS JUST
TO TRY TO SURVIVE.
ALL THE MEN HAVE BEEN WIPED OUT
BECAUSE THE WAND WOODS OF WAR
GETS MY COMMUNITY.
SO ALL THE MEN WERE GONE.
SO WE HAD TO FEND FOR OURSELVES
AND ORGANIZE OURSELVES.
AND SO EVERY SINGLE TIME WHEN I
WAS LIKE THIRTEEN YEARS OLD
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD CAN
INCARCERATED BY THE TIME I
BECAME A FATHER I WANTED
SOMEBODY TO HELP ME HOW DO I
BECOME A GOOD FATHER.
I DON'T HAVE ANY EXAMPLES.
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND SO I WAS SOMEBODY WAS THERE.
AFTERWARDS I GOT SHOT WITH A
TWELVE GAUGE SHOTGUN LEFT FOR
DEAD.
I WISH SOMEBODY WAS THERE FOR ME.
AFTERWARDS HAD CUT INCARCERATED
MYSELF BECAUSE HOW DO YOU NOT
HOW DO YOU STAY CLEAN IN A MUD
PUDDLE AS THEY SAY RIGHT.
THE REALITY IS IS THAT THE
GENERATIONAL RESPECTFUL
RECIPROCAL FORM OF VIOLENCE THAT
HAD GRIPPED OUR CITY GRIPPED OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD WAS REAL AND WAS
VERY NOW OVER AND OVER AGAIN THE
STORY OF BRANDON WAS PLAYED OUT
YOUR COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
ANY SETTLES DAY IN SAN DIEGO IN
SOUTH LA AND OUR RESERVATIONS.
AS WELL.
AND SO THIS WAS A THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNE LIKE NONE OTHER.
BECAUSE SOONER OR LATER AS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I THINK
WE'RE DEMONSTRATING TODAY SOONER
OR LATER WE GOTTA HAVE MORE
BACKBONE THE WISHBONE.
I'LL TELL YOU THIS THAT LASTING
SO WE'RE RUNNING THE TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTER.
THAT'S WORKING WITH YOUNG MEN OF
COLOR WE HAVE A HEALING SCHOOLS
WE JUST STARTED THE MCKINLEY AND
AND ARE NOW GOING TO SEVEN
SCHOOLS THAT'S THE ANSWER. TO
ACTUALLY THE PUNISHMENT AND
CONTROL MODEL THAT HAS REALLY
PUSH SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE OF
COLOR LIKE BRANDON OUT OF SCHOOL
AND TO REPEAT INCARCERATION
WEBER TOM INFORMED WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT A LOT OF THE FOLKS
WERE HERE EARLIER TODAY ON
PAROLE THERE RIGHT NOW VAST
BECAUSE THEY'RE LIKE OUT THERE.
WORKING THEIR FATHERS AT WORK
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT JUST
FELONS THEIR FATHERS AND I JUST
PRISONERS THEIR PARENTS AND THEY
WANT TO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
DIGNITY OF HAVING A ACTUAL GOOD
JOB NOT ONLY THAT BUT ALSO
DEALING WITH THE UNRESOLVED
TRAUMA PAIN AND SHAME THAT
THEY'VE SUFFERED WITH.
AND THEN LASTLY WE HAVE THE
LOWEST RECIDIVISM RATE IN OUR
COUNTY SO IT'S ACTUALLY IF
YOU'RE NOT COMPELLED BY THE
MORALITY.
OF IT THEN THE FINANCIAL ASPECT
OF IT SHOULD BE VERY CLEAR.
WE HAVE A SPEND SO MUCH MONEY ON
PUNISHING PEOPLE OF COLOR IT'S
TIME TO RECONCILE THAT AND WE'VE
STONE THAT IT'S A VERY
SUCCESSFUL WE PARTNER UP WITH
COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS -- AND I
THINK RIGHT NOW THE BRAND STORY
OF BRANDON IS ACTUALLY
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SCALE UP
BE BOWL THAT BRANDON WAS A BE
BRAVE AND COURAGEOUS.
IN THIS WORK LASTLY I'LL SAY
THIS THERE WAS A YOUNG MAN
WALKING BY OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO STOP YOU
COME BY OUR NEIGHBORHOOD CENTER
YOU'LL SEE.
YOU'LL SEE COMMUNITY THERE
YOU'LL SEE MOVEMENT YOU'LL SEE
HEALING YOU'LL SEE IT FOR
YOURSELF AND YOU'LL SEE A LOT OF
THE COMPLEXITIES THAT WE'D HAVE
TO STRUGGLE WITH THE NUANCES.
ABOUT WE CONFRONT THESE ISSUES
WE DON'T SHY AWAY FROM THEM THIS
YOUNG MAN CAVE MAN HE WAS
LOOKING IN THE MIRROR AND THEN
INTO THE OFFICE I SHOULD SAY.
AND HE COMES WALKING IN THE US
AS HE SAYS WHAT DO YOU OFFER
YOUR JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
[inaudible]
YOU NEED.
HE GOES HOW LONG YOU BEEN OR
JUST ABOUT ALWAYS.
I WILL TAKE A LOOK AROUND
ACTUALLY WAS A ME WAS AN ELDER
THAT CAME UP TO TAKE A LOOK
AROUND.
ANYONE LOOKED AROUND AND SAW
THIS PICTURE THIS LIVE PICTURE
OF A FAMILY THAT WAS CONNECTED
CHILDREN THAT WERE PROTECTED.
ELDERS THAT WERE RESPECTED.
AND HE SAYS I WANT THAT FOR MY
COMMUNITY.
CAN I GET THAT WE IGGY WAS GIVEN
SOME SEATS.
THE BILL ON THE TABLE HE LOOKED
ON THE SEAS LOOKED UP AT THE
ELDER.
LOOK DOWN AND WALKED OUT WITHOUT
THE SEEDS.
BECAUSE HE WAS TOLL FORTY NUMBER
ONE THE WORK THAT WE'RE HERE TO
DO MAY NOT BE REALIZED IN OUR
DEBT LIFETIME BUT LET'S START IT.
NUMBER TWO WOULD TAKES A LOT OF
WORK WITHOUT BOASTING A BRAG IN
THE BODY JUST GOT TO DO THE WORK
NUMBER.
THREE IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
HARD WORK AND IT'S NOT GONNA BE
EASY.
NOT EVERYONE BILL FOR IT.
WE'RE STILL THERE FOR THAT YOUNG
MAN WHEN HE COMES BACK BUT THE
QUESTION IS ARE WE GOING TO TAKE
THE SEEDS AND WORK IT TO
ACTUALLY PRODUCE THE KIND OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WOULD ALL OF OUR CHILDREN
DESERVE -- I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'M SORRY IF I
WENT OVER I JUST I APOLOGIZE --
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
CALPERS MODEL MODEL WITH
CALIFORNIA DOWN -- GOOD MORE
GOOD AFTERNOON ALBER MALDONADO
WITH -- WITH CALIFORNIAN DOWN
MAN AND ON BEHALF OF DOCTOR
ROSSI HE WANTED ME TO EXTEND
APPRECIATIONS TO TO TO YOU CHAIR --
GARCIA AS WELL AS THE THE CAN
THE COMMITTEE HERE.
ALL AND JUST ONE OTHER ONE OTHER
NOTE FROM DOCTOR ROSS -- YOU
KNOW WELL HE CAN'T BE HERE HE
SENT HIS REGRETS HE WANTED ME TO
CONVEY -- TO TO BOTH THE THE
ASSEMBLY COME SELECT COMMITTEE
ON BOYS A MINUTE COLORS WELL
IT'S WERE PARTNERS THAT ARE THAT
ARE HERE WITH US TODAY -- THAT
WHILE WE'VE BEEN WITH YOU FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS WE REMAIN
COMMITTED FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS --
TO REALLY YOU KNOW -- ACT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH WITH FOLKS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE SUPPORT OUR
OUR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
SO ON THAT NOTE I JUST REALLY
WANT TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A
JOURNEY IN IN SHARING HOW THE IN
DEL MAN HAS COME INTO -- OUR
WORK AROUND BOYS MEN OF COLOR --
AND SO REALLY OVER THE LAST
DECADE -- YOU KNOW WE REALLY
PARTNERED AND YOU KNOW WITH WITH
A LOT OF THE FOLKS HERE IN THE
ROOM AS WELL AS THE THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE TO REALLY GET
IT WHAT ARE SOME OF THE ROOT
CAUSES -- THAT ARE YOU KNOW
CONTRIBUTING TO THE STRUGGLE OF
GENERATIONS OF BOYS AND YOUNG
MEN OF COLOR ESPECIALLY THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN BOB MOST
DISENFRANCHISED -- SO WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD FROM FROM SAMMY
ABOUT BRANDON STORY AND BRENDAN
HARRIS AND CERTAINLY HAD A BIG
IMPACT ON THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT AS ONE OF OUR
PRESIDENT YOU COUNCIL MEMBERS --
HE AT ONE POINT AS WE WERE
ASKING BRANDON ABOUT WHAT WHAT
WHAT THE STATE SHOULD LOOK LIKE
HE CHALLENGED US TO THINK
THROUGH AND AND AND AND COME UP
WITH WHAT IS THE EQUIVALENT OF
THE HARVARD FOR YOUTH ORGANIZING
WHAT IS THE EQUIVALENT --
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
BUILD THEIR LEADERSHIP SKILLS SO
THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET
DEEPLY INVOLVED -- IN IN IN IN
IN CHALLENGING AND AND AND AND
STRUGGLE AND IN STRUGGLE.
ALL SO JUST A LITTLE BIT OF A
BACKGROUND ON THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT IS A PRIVATE HEALTH
FOUNDATION OUR MISSION IS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. FOR
UNDERSERVED INDIVIDUALS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY IN MY VIEW TO
PROMOTE FUNDAMENTAL IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE HEALTH STATUS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE DON'T FOCUS ON
PRESCRIPTIONS WE FOCUS ON ON
FIXING BROKEN SYSTEMS AND
OUTDATED POLICIES.
WE DON'T FOCUS ON THE INDIVIDUAL
BUT WE DO FOCUS ON THE LARGER
COMMUNITY AS AN ECOSYSTEM OF
HEALTH AND HOW TO BUILD
COLLECTIVE VOICE.
POWER AND ADVOCACY WE WORK WITH
CITIZENS AND ELECTED LEADERS
ACROSS THE STATE TO FIND LASTING
SOLUTIONS FOR SCALE WILL IMPACT
THE DRIVE HEALTH AND RACIAL
JUSTICE.
SO I THAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS YOUNG PEOPLE
AND OUR PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS
OVER THE LAST DECADE TO BETTER
ADDRESS THE WELL DOCUMENTED
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES.
THAT EXIST ACROSS A BROADER WAY
OF A RAY OF ECONOMIC AND HEALTH
DOMAINS.
ADVERSELY AFFECTING CALIFORNIA'S
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
THESE DISPARITIES HAVE DEVELOPED
AND PERSISTED OVERTIME IN THE
CONTEXT OF HISTORICAL AND
STRUCTURAL RACISM.
THAT IS SHAPE POLICIES SYSTEMIC
PRACTICES INSTRUCTED PROGRAMS IN
WAYS THAT CREE DISADVANTAGES FOR
CERTAIN GROUPS.
VS HISTORY ANY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF
DISADVANTAGE HAS MET THAT SUCH
INEQUITIES HAVE PERSISTENT
PROFOUND AND LONG LASTING
GENERATIONAL AFFECTS THAT IMPACT
ALL LEVELS OF SOCIETY.
THE SUBGROUPS THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OUR LOW INCOME BOYS
AND YOUNG MEN OF COLOR.
IN RECOGNITION OF THIS PROFOUND
ADVERSE EFFECT OF RACE AND
GENDER ON THE HEALTH OF POOR
COMMUNITIES THE CALIFORNIA DEL
MEANS -- IDENTIFIED STRATEGIES
TO CLOSE THE HEALTH GAP FOR BOYS
AND YOUNG MEN OF COLOR AS A
STRATEGIC OBJECTIVE OF OF TCP.
WE REALIZE THAT WE CANNOT HAVE
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA UNLESS
MEANING FULL CHANGE HAPPENS TO
ADDRESS THE NEGATIVE HEALTH
TRANS EXPERIENCE BY BOYS AND
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR.
IN AUGUST TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS APPROVED
A STRATEGIC PLAN THAT HAS NOW
INVESTED MORE THAN FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS PROGRAM.
THOSE INVESTMENTS INCLUDE GRANTS
TO CBO'S DATA CONVENING BRING IN
OUR COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
TOGETHER TO REALLY ADDRESS THE
POLICIES AND SYSTEMS AND
PRACTICES.
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO DISPARITIES
OUR FOCUS AREAS HAVE INCLUDED --
REDUCING CHRONIC ABSENCE KEEPING
KIDS HEALTHY GETTING KIDS BACK
ON TRACK AND INTO SCHOOL
ADDRESSING.
ADDRESSING SAFETY AND JUSTICE TO
THE LANDS OF YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
AND ULTIMATELY CONNECTING YOUNG
PEOPLE TO THE HEALTH SUPPORTS
THAT THE NEED -- FOR FOR A
CORPORATE CIVIL THAT HAVE GUIDED
OUR WORK ON BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR -- INCLUDE.
OUR I ACTUALLY LET ME LET ME
START THAT OVER MY BAD -- BEFORE
COURT PRIORITIES THAT GUIDE OUR
WORK ON BOYS AND YOUNG MEN OF
COLOR -- ROUTE ONE BOYS AND
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR ARE IMPORTANT
ASSETS TO CALIFORNIA AND THEIR
FAMILIES TWO BOYS ME POSITIVE
CONNECTIONS TO ADULTS GENERALLY
THROUGH MENTORSHIP AND MEN
SPECIFICALLY. THREE BOYS AND
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR MUST BE SEEN
ENGAGED AS CONSUMERS AS
ADVOCATES AND AS LEADERS AND FOR
POLICY AND SYSTEMS CHANGE
EFFORTS MUST BENEFIT.
THE LIFE CHANCES OF BOYS AND
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR.
OUR BOYS A MINUTE COLOR WORK
EXPLICITLY CALLED OUT REYES AND
COMMITTED TO LIFTING UP.
THE VOICES OF YOUNG PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN AN INTENTIONAL IN
STRATEGIC WAY.
IT WAS REALLY ROOTED IN THE IDEA
OF FOCUSING ON THE MOST EXCLUDED
POPULATIONS WITH AN EXPLICIT
FOCUS ON RACIAL JUSTICE OUR BOYS
THEM IN A COLOR WORK.
HAS REALLY TRANSFORMED THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT
SPECIFICALLY AND HOW WE APPROACH
OUR WORK IT PAVE THE WAY FOR US
TO TO DEEPLY INVESTING YOUTH
LEADERSHIP IN ORGANIZING AND
VOICE. TO PUT TWO BY INCUBATING
STATEWIDE YOUTH MOVEMENTS.
FOR OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO GET INVOLVED IN ISSUES
THAT MOST IMPACT THEM.
A ALSO AS MARK MENTIONED EARLIER
PAVE THE WAY FOR T. C. E. TO
WORK WITH SPECIFIC GROUPS LIKE
QUEER AND TRANS YOUTH SYSTEMS
IMPACTED YOUNG PEOPLE IMMIGRANT
YOUNG PEOPLE AS WELL AS NATIVE
YOUTH ACROSS THE ACROSS THE
STATE.
ARMED BY CREATING PATHWAYS
SUPPORTING LEADERSHIP AMONG THE
QUOTE ON QUOTE MOST IMPACTED
THIS WORK HAS LED TO DEEP
SUPPORT FOR LOCAL AND STATEWIDE
STRATEGIES. TO ADDRESS POLICY
THROUGH AN INTERSECTIONAL LENS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE YOUTH
AND ADULT ORGANIZER THAT SUPPORT
THEM.
IN MANY WAYS BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR HAS SERVED AS A LEARNING
LABORATORY LABORATORY FOR THE
CALIFORNIAN DOWN ME. TO REALLY
THINK THROUGH OUR INTER
GENERATIONAL AN INTERSECTIONAL
APPROACH ON POLICY IN THERE TO
CHANGE STRATEGIES.
A FEW HIGHLIGHTS.
ARM AS MENTIONED EARLIER BOYS IN
A COLOR HAS PROVIDED THE
BACKBONE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR COORDINATED BY POLICY LINK
SCHOOL DISCIPLINE WITH ONE OF
THOSE CATALYZING ISSUES EARLY ON
THAT REALLY.
CONNECTED YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
ACROSS THE STATE TO REALLY
ADDRESS ISSUES TO GET YOUNG
PEOPLE IN IN IN SCHOOL AND ON
TRACK TO GRADUATE.
OF SOME SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE SEEN AS WELL AS
PROMISING MOMENTUM.
ON THAT I JUST WANT TO LIFT UP
AS I BEGIN TO CLOSE IS.
AS WE THINK THROUGH SCHOOL DID
SCHOOL SUSPENSIONS AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE REALLY TAKEN UP THE
MANTLE OF ADDRESSING A PUNITIVE
APPROACH AND ARE MOVING MUCH
MORE TOWARDS A RESTORATIVE IT
NOW AND AN UPSTREAM APPROACH.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME RECENTLY CALLED
FOR THE END OF THE GIVE YOU
THINK CARTS REGION AS WE KNOW IT
AND WE WERE OR SEEN
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
INCLUDING SAN FRANCISCO -- AND
LA ADVANCING -- SIGNIFICANT
DIVERSIONARY APPROACHES -- AND
SO THERE ALSO IS ALONG THE SAME
LINES THE MOVE TO REALLY MOVE
PUBLIC RESOURCES AWAY FROM HARM
HARM AND TOWARDS RESTORATION
HEALING AND YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
THE IT THE IMPACTS OF
GENERATIONAL TRAUMA AS NOTED
EARLIER HAVE HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON ON OPPORTUNITY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE.
A COUPLE OF OTHER AREAS THAT I
WANT TO LIFT UP.
IS THE EMERGENCE OF
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP AS
NOTED HERE -- WE'VE SEEN YOU
KNOW REALLY REALLY ROBUST
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AT THE
CBO LEVEL CERTAINLY LET UP BY
POLICY LINK IN THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
AMONGST FUNDERS -- WHERE FUNDERS
HAVE REALLY COME TOGETHER BOTH
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
FUNDERS FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR?
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL TO THE
EXECUTIVE THE LIGHTS FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR AND CERTAINLY
AS MENTIONED EARLIER -- WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA -- YOU KNOW
REALLY CHAMPIONING THE MY
BROTHER'S KEEPER EFFORT.
THERE'S ALSO REALLY STRONG
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS MEN OF COLOR.
IN REALLY FORGING A STATEWIDE OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
FIND THEIR VOICE -- AND FOR US
TO ADVANCES DENOBLE STRATEGIES --
SO IN CLOSING.
I JUST WANTED LIFT UP THAT BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR REALLY HELPED
US.
BOMB TO REALIZE THAT WE NEEDED
TO TARGET OTHER POPULATIONS AS
WILL BE ON DISADVANTAGED BOYS
AND MEN YOUNG MEN OF COLOR WE
REALLY STARTED TO ENGAGE OUR
YOUNG WOMEN IN AN EVER CALLED
SISTERHOOD RISING -- ENGAGING
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN YOUNG PEOPLE
AS WELL AS UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH --
SO I THINK FOR ME.
OF THE LAST THING THAT I'LL SAY
IS THAT THE BIG LESSON LEARNED
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR FOR
THE ENDOWMENT WAS THAT WE REALLY
CAN'T LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND AND SO
WE REALLY AS WE THINK ABOUT OUR
WORK FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
THE CHALLENGE FOR US IS HOW DO
WE THINK THROUGH -- NOT LEAVING
ANYONE ELSE BEHIND ANY OTHER
CALIFORNIANS SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE TIME IN AN OPEN --
TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT THEY
BI<c.cyan>.</c>
ACCENT QUESTIONS WILL GO ON NEXT
NEXT PRESENTER MISTER DALE.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON --
THE CHAIR AND THE THE MEMBERS ON
A THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY --
JERRY TELEMANN.
THE FOUNDING MEMBERS OF THE
NATIONAL COMPILERS NETWORK AND
SO WHEN IT KNOWLEDGE MY
ANCESTORS -- COME FROM -- MAY HE
GO FROM QUITE IS BUT ALSO --
THAT BELONG COULD BE TAKEN --
NATIVE FROM OF TEXAS SIR MY
RELATIVES.
BEEN THERE DIDN'T CROSS THE
BORDER BEEN THERE ALL ALONG.
AND THE THE BEEN THERE FOR MANY
GENERATIONS BUT I WAS RAISED IN
COMPTON SO I GREW UP IN COMPTON
WHAT SOUTH CENTRAL LA.
SOME STRAIGHT OUTTA COMPTON --
AND RATE IS REYES NO BLACK BROWN
NEIGHBORHOOD WAY WAY BACK AND
AND PART OF MY HISTORY PART OF
MY OF OF YOU KNOW MY IT TEACHING.
IT WAS DURING THE FIRST.
YOU KNOW THE RIOTS THERE.
MIGHT BE AN IN HIGH SCHOOL A IN
IN THOSE RIOTS AND AND BEING
VERY AFRAID TO WALK HOME -- NOT
BECAUSE OF THE OTHER FOLKS THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE NATIONAL GUARD
POLICE WITH JACK US UP AND SO WE
HAD REPAIRED OUR LAST PERIOD TO
SEE WHO'S GONNA WALK WITHIN
SPECIFIC CYZICUS SPECIFICALLY.
NUMBER THE GIRLS WOULD SAY WOULD
YOU WALK US HOME BECAUSE THEY
THEY WITH THE THE THE POLICE AND
THE NATIONAL GUARD WOULD WITH
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT THEM SO.
AS A YOUNG BOY WE HAD TO THINK
ABOUT THINGS LIKE THAT VERY
EARLY ON AND SO SAYS SPECT OF
JUSTICE IN.
AND AND TRAUMA -- WAS JUST PART
OF WHAT I THOUGHT LIFE WAS IN
AND AND GREW UP THAT WAY AND
DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS PART OF
THE THE THE THE PROCESS -- I WAS
ABLE TO GO ON YOU KNOW IF OF MY
SACRIFICE MY MOTHER IN THE SEMI
MENTION MOTHERS IN AND THE
GRANDMOTHERS IT REALLY ARE THE
BACKBONE OF THE PRAYER AND ALL
OF THAT YOU KNOW.
THAT OF THE REALLY SAVED US BUT
I WAS ABLE TO GO ON AND AND AND
BEGIN TO DO THIS WORK WAY BACK
IN THE SEVENTIES AS A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST IN -- BUT BUT
REALIZE THAT THE WHAT THEY WERE
TEACHING ME WAS NOT REALLY
HELPING US.
REALLY THEY WERE THEY WERE
TEACHING US -- TO TO TO DIAGNOSE
AND AND MEDICAID -- OUR
POPULATION AND NOT REALLY DEAL
WITH WE REALLY WHAT WAS GOING ON
IN.
AND AND AND AND WE FOUND AND
WORKING A NUMBER OF US IS THAT
WAY BACK IN THERE THE THE
EIGHTIES AFTER WE'VE BEEN
WORKING A LONG TIME AND
COMMUNITIES THAT.
THAT THE INEQUITY WAS THERE WE
STILL NOT GETTING SERVICES.
WAS STILL NOTHING GETTING THINGS
OF A CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE FOR
US.
AND SO WE DECIDED TOGETHER
NUMBER OF US -- MEN DECIDED
TOGETHER BECAUSE IT WAS A
DUALITY WAS GOING AWFULLY FELT
IN EQUITY GOING ON A COMMUNITY.
BUT AS AS AS MENTIONED EARLIER
WE ALSO FELT THE SHAME.
THAT A LOT OF THE THEHURT THAT
WAS GOING ON WE'RE GOING ON BY
OURSELVES THAT WE WERE.
BEING DOMESTICALLY VIOLENT CHILD
ABUSE IS GOING ON SEXUAL ASSAULT
WAS GOING ON GANG VIOLENCE WITH
KILLING OURSELVES.
AND AND WE CAME TOGETHER NUMBER
OF US MEN CAME TOGETHER BACK IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WE SAT IN
A CIRCLE WE KNEW ENOUGH.
TAUGHT BY GRANDMOTHERS THAT WE
START WITH PRAYER.
WE START WITH PLAN WE ASK CREATE
ANY ANCESTORS HELP US OF OUR
PEOPLE HEARD.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW TO HELP THE
SYSTEMS THAT HELP IN THIS
EDUCATION NOT HELPING US
[inaudible]
YOUR GUIDE.
WE LOOKED AT FIRED ASK FOR SOME
HELP.
AND THE AND IT WILL BE WE ASK
FOR THAT WE WE WE WE DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR WE WE
WANTED ANSWERS TO HELP US IN.
AND SO WE WENT AROUND THAT ROOM
AND BEGIN SHARING WHO WE WERE
WAS OUR INTENT IN THE SECOND
BROTHER IN SAID I WANT HELP MY
COMMUNITY BUT THE PROBLEM IS.
I'M BROKE.
I DID HAVE A DEAD.
I EXPERIENCE A LOT OF TROUBLE BY
THE POLICE AND SO I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO LOVE MY KIDS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO BE CLOSE TO
MY WIFE.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO HEAL ALL
I DO IS DRINKING GET HIGH.
AND I'M A LAWYER.
ON THE SUCCESSFUL.
ONE AND AS WE WENT AROUND THAT
ROOM ANOTHER WAS THERE WERE SO
CALLED SUCCESSFUL REALIZE THAT
WE WERE ALL.
WE WERE THE LEADERS WITH THE
POLITICIANS WITH THE LORD IS
WITH THE SOCIAL WORKERS AND WE
WERE ALL MESSED UP.
THAT'S WHAT THAT DAY.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
IS THAT THE MOST REVOLUTIONARY
THING WE NEEDED TO DO WAS HE
LOST SALES AS MEN.
BECAUSE WE ARE BRINGING THAT
TRAUMA THAT IT DIDN'T COME TO US
THROUGH ALL THE OPPRESSION THE
RACISM IT WILL BRING IN A TOP
HOMES AND FAMILIES.
AND THE EDUCATION WAS NOT GOING
TO SAVE US A JOB WAS NOT GOING
TO SAVE US THAT WE HAD
INTENTIONALLY DO OUR HEALING
WORK WITH INTENTIONALLY LEARN
ABOUT THE SACREDNESS OF WHO WE
REALLY WERE.
RECOVERED THE SACRED IDENTITY OF
WHO WERE BLACK BROWN NATIVE MEN
CALL THAT BACK AND THEN CHOOSE
TO LIVE THAT.
AND THAT WAS THE IMPETUS OF THE
NATIONAL COMPOSITES NETWORK.
THAT WE AS MEN DECIDED THAT WE
WERE GONNA STEP BUT BEFORE ANY
CAMPAIGNS ON ANYTHING ANYBODY DO
IT WE DECIDED TO DO IT.
AND THE YOU KNOW SAMMY CAME
ALONG A NUMBER OF OTHER BROTHERS
CAME ALONG AND AND JOINED US AND
WE PRAYED AND WE MADE
COMMITMENTS IN THE OTHER COMMIT
WE MADE.
IT'S GOING TO PASS THIS ON TO
THE NEXT GENERATION.
SO FOR THIRTY YEARS WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS WORK AND WE
INCORPORATED AND AND AND NOW --
WE OUR FOCUS IS ON HEALING.
OUR FOCUS IS THAT WE DON'T HEAL.
YOU KNOW WHATEVER IS NOT
TRANSFORM GETS TRANSFERRED.
YOU GIVE SOMEBODY A JOB YOU CAN
GIVE EDUCATION YOU CAN MAKE A
POLITICS.
RIGHT BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
WOULD HAVE POLITICIANS SO -- WE
ALL GOT HERE AND WE KNOW THIS
WILL BE POLITICIANS BECAUSE
BECAUSE WE'VE WE FIND NOW OUR
COMMUNITY SUFFERING FROM TRAUMA
FROM FEAR.
WE WE WORK THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY BUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT AND
OTHER OTHER FOUNDATIONS IN AND
ARE PART OF THE NETWORK HERE.
AND AND SO THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING REALLY IS IS HOW DO WE
BUILD CAPACITY IN PART OF
BUILDING CAPACITY IS WE HAVE TO
CHALLENGE THE SYSTEMS.
AND I WANT TO LIFT UPBECAUSE I
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
SAYING WE NEED MORE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES WE NEED MORE
SOCIAL SERVICES BUT LET ME JUST.
CHALLENGE THAT BECAUSE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE FOUND AS OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM HAS OVER
MEDICATED AND AND AND AND OVER
DIAGNOSED OUR KIDS SO IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT GIVING MORE FUNDS.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT DOING MORE
SOCIAL SERVICES NOT JUST YOU
KNOW UNLESS YOU DO THE WORK LIKE
FATHERS AND FAMILIES AND
ENCOURAGES SOME OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT DO THEIR OWN
INTERNAL KEELING WORK INTO THEIR
OWN.
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS WORK AND RE
TRANSFORM EVERYTHING THAT ALL WE
DO IS REPLICATING THE OPPRESSION.
WE DO A LOT OF WORK IN SCHOOLS.
AND WE'RE FINDING IS SCHOOLS THE
BREEDING GROUND FOR MANY TIMES
THE THE LACK OF INTEGRITY THE
KIDS HAVE.
BEGIN TO ASSIMILATE THEM INTO A
PROCESS AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
IS IS GOOD BUT IF YOU'RE NOT
DOING ANY TYPE A TRANSFORMATIVE
JUSTICE IN THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES IN THE WAY EDUCATION
IS GIVEN.
ALL WE'RE DOING IS BANDAID.
SO WE IN OUR PROCESS WOULD WE
LIFT UP IS CHALLENGING SYSTEMS
TRANSFORMING SYSTEMS AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF MODELS THAT WE CAN LIFT
UP IN THAT WAY -- YOU KNOW IN IN
IN MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES AND
AND WE PROVIDE A LOT OF CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE FATHERS AND
FAMILIES AND OTHERS ACROSS THE
THE THE STATE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IN THE SCHOOLS WE'VE BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE TO IN IN THE IN YOUR
DISTRICT TO SENATE GARCIA TO
WORK IN THE COACHELLA DISTRICT
AS WELL.
AND YOU KNOW THAT SOME OF THE
REPRESENTATIVE HERE TODAY AND WE
FOUND THAT YOU KNOW WHEN A
DISTRICT IS WILLING TO DO A DEEP
DIVE.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS YOU GOT TO
START WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT TO
THE MINISTRY ALL THE WAY DOWN
AND REFORMULATE HOW THEY SEE OUR
KIDS.
GOOD MANY TIMES OR EVEN LIKE OUR
KIDS THEY'RE EVEN SEE OUR KIDS
BUT THE OTHER THING IS THEY
DON'T SEE OUR FAMILIES.
THEY DON'T SEE THE TRAUMA THAT
THEY GO TO AND NOW WE HAVE KIDS
THAT ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE ICE.
AND AND AND IMMIGRATION IS ALL
AROUND THESE KIDS WE'RE SEEING
YOUNGER AND YOUNGER KIDS
SUFFERING FROM FROM ANXIETY
DISORDERS FROM THE FROM
DEPRESSION.
FROM SUICIDAL IDEATION.
YOU KNOW AND AND THEY GOT TO GO
HOME AND NOBODY'S HELPING THE
PARENTS NOBODY'S HELPING THE
FATHERS WE GET A LOT OF FATHERS
THAT COMING OUT OF PRISON.
AND AND SOMEBODY WAS ASKING OKAY
SO AS THE CRIME RATE GOING UP
WHAT THE CRIME ISGONE UP THAT
THAT'S THAT'S THE IMPLICATION ON
THE SYSTEM THEY DIDN'T DO GOOD
BY THEM WHEN THEY'RE INSIDE.
RIGHT.
SO SO SO WHAT IS IT IMPLICATING
WE SEE THIS IN AND SO A LOT OF
OUR WORK IS ON HEALING WE YOU
KNOW WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE.
TO BE SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT.
THESE LAST TWO YEARS TO DO A A
LISTENING TO WHAT YOU WANTED TO
TEN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
AS SURVEYED -- AND AND DID
LISTENING GROUPS WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH THE YOUNGSTERS WITH
THE ELDERS AND ELDERS RIGHT.
AND AND THEN AS ADAM IN A CIRCLE
AND ASK THEM WHAT YOUR FORMS OF
STRESS WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO YOU
STRUGGLE WITH.
AND SO WE NOW HAVE A HAVE A
REPORT LIMóN REPORT BUT I WANT
I WANT TO SHARE SOME THINGS WITH
THE YOUNG PEOPLE SAID WHAT THE
COMMUNITY SAID THAT A STRUGGLE
WITH IN TERMS OF STRESS.
THEY SAID WE ARE BIRD WE'RE
BURDEN BY SYSTEMS WE'RE BURDEN
BY COMMUNITIES WE'RE BURDEN BY
BY -- ESTABLISHED WITH THAT
DON'T UNDERSTAND OUR TRAUMA
DON'T UNDERSTAND OUR PAIN.
WE HAVE PARENTS AND GUARDIANS
THAT IS STILL STRUGGLING WITH
THEIR OWN TRAUMA AND THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO CONNECT WITH US THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO GUIDE TO NURTURE US
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT HEALED
THEIR GENERATIONAL PAIN.
AND CAN BARELY SURVIVE THEY SAID
WE THE AS YOUNG MEN OF COLOR WE
STRUGGLE TO ADAPT TO RAPIDLY
CHANGING DIVISIVE MILITARISTIC
SOCIAL WORLD THAT EXPECTS A LOT
FROM US.
BUT OFTEN DISCRIMINATED DOES NOT
NOT PROVIDE GUIDANCE NURTURANCE
OR EVEN A SPACE FOR US TO BE.
AND WE OVERWHELMINGLY GOT FROM
THEM WE NEED A PLACE TO BE.
JUST TO BE.
WE WANTED PLACE TO BE WHAT WE
COULD FEEL SAFE WITH IS GETTING
OLD STORES IN ELLE'S ELDERS IN
THERE.
THAT WE CAN TALK TO THE WE CAN
ASK ABOUT HOW DO WE CROSS THIS
RITES OF PASSAGE BRIDGE.
AND THE OTHER THINGS THEY SAID
SYSTEMS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT CIVIC
AND HEALTH CARE THAT.
THAT THAT ARE CONNECTED TO WITH
THAT DON'T DISCONNECT US FROM
WHO WE ARE AND DON'T PUNISH THIS
FOR BEINGWHO WE ARE.
SO THEY STRUGGLE FROM THE TRAUMA
AND AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY THAT WE TALKED ABOUT HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU COPE.
LOT OF NUMB WE SAT DOWN WE DON'T
THINK ABOUT IT WE JUST TRIANGLE
ON LOT OF US JUST WILL BATES
SMOKE SOME WEED.
YOU KNOW JUST TRY LISTEN TO
MUSIC TRYING AND AND AND
SOMETIMES IT COMES OUT WITH
THEIR WOUNDED MISS BEGINS TO
WILL NOT.
SO THAT THE VIOLENCE THE DRUGS
THE ALCOHOL ALL OF THAT STUFF AS
WELL.
AND AND SO PART OF OUR EMPHASIS
AND AND I WHAT I WANT TO LIFT UP --
THE BROTHERHOOD OF ELDERS OUT OF
OAKLAND.
AFRICAN AMERICAN A GROUP THAT
WE'RE WE HAVE A COLLABORATION
WITH THEM WE COLLABORATE WITH
NATIVE GROUPS CAN DETECT
COLLABORATE WITH THE BROTHERHOOD
VALDRES WE HAVE HAD WE HAD
WANTED TO LONG BEACH BECAUSE IN
IN THE LISTENING TO IN LONG
BEACH THE SAID THAT THE BLACK
BROWN WAR.
GOING ON RIGHT.
SO WE HAD TO GO IN AS BLACK AND
BROWN FOLKS AND SAY NO LET'S SIT
TOGETHER LET'S TALK TO LET'S
HILL TO GET RIGHT WE NEED TO
BRING MORE OF THAT COLLABORATION
AND SO -- ONE OF ONE OF OUR
FOCUSES IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS IS
TO BUILD A HEALING INSTITUTE WE
NEED TO HAVE AN ORGANIZATION WE
NEED TO HAVE A FOCUS WHERE
HEALING GOES ON ON GOING AND
THEN WE BILL COMBAT CAPACITIES
IN COMMUNITIES.
THE TRAUMA CENTERS OR IMPORT BUT
I'M A TELL YOU I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE OTHER TRAUMA CENTERS
BUT NOT ANOTHER ONE LIKE LIKE
FATHERS OF FAMILIES.
YOU KNOW AND SO YOU CAN BUILD
THAT KIND OF MODEL WHERE THE
HEALING IS GOING ON INTERNALLY
AND PLUS YOU BRING TRAUMA THAT I
SEE TO TRAUMA CENTERS BUT DOING
TRAUMA CENTERS BY THEMSELVES.
SOMETIMES WE JUST RE EXACERBATE
OF THE TRAUMA RIGHT SO SO I WANT
TO LIFT UP THE ASPECT OF HEALING
THAT WE NEED TO TO REALLY --
PLACE FUNDS AND SUPPORT EFFORTS
THAT ARE CULTURALLY BASED
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF OUR OWN
HEALING CAPACITY IN OUR OWN
CULTURE THAT WE CAN LIFT UP THAT
WE CAN BUILD ON THAT IS TRAUMA
INFORMED AND NOW EVERYTHING IS
FROM INFORMED.
BUT THE PROBLEM WITH TROUBLING
FORM IS NOW YOU CAN USE THAT IN
A RACIST WAY AS WELL.
RIGHT SO IT CAN'T JUST BE TRAUMA
FORM HAS TO BE HEALING SENATE.
AND AND AND I'M GONNA YOU KNOW
IT I'LL I'LL END.
BY BY BY SHARING A STORY.
OF THIS YOUNG MAN THAT THAT CAME
OUT HE HAD BEEN LOCKED UP FOR
FOR YOU NOT YOUNG IS FIFTEEN
YEARS.
HE BEEN THE SHOOT WE HAD BEEN
LOCKED DOWN IN THE SHOE FOR
FLOAT TWELVE OF THOSE FIFTEEN
YEARS.
ANY SAYS WITH IT WITH YOU KNOW
THIS HE GOT OUT ONE HOUR A DAY
HE WOULD PRAY.
HE WOULD PRAY THAT DURING THAT
HOUR THAT HE WOULDN'T GET YOU
KNOW STAB THOSE KILLED OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT SO YOU PRAY
EVERY DAY.
THAT AND BELIEVE IN PRAYER UNTIL
I GOT LOCKED UP IN THE SHOE HE
SAYS AND AND EVERY DAY I WOULD
BE SO SCARED OF MORE SCARED TO
BE IN MY LIFE AND IT FINALLY
CAME OUT AND WE CAME OUT HE CAME
TO SEE ME.
AND HE CAME TO SEE ME YES I
HEARD YOU CAN YOU YOU CAN HELP
IT MY HEALING AND AND HE SAYS
BUT WHAT I'M STRUGGLING WITH
RIGHT NOW IS -- THE P. O.
FINALLY GAVE ME PERMISSION TO GO
SEE MY KIDS.
IS THIS AN APPLE OR SCARED THAT
I'VE EVER PAID.
I'M MORE SCARED THAN IT WAS IN
THE SHOE.
BECAUSE I'M AFRAID BY KIDS WON'T.
PHRASE MY KIDS WILL LIKE ME I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO BE A FATHER.
I DON'T NOT EVEN.
EVEN APPROACH THEM I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO ASK FOR FORGIVENESS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO BE A BAND
BECAUSE I WAS LOCKED UP WHEN I
WAS FOURTEEN AND I FEEL LIKE I'M
STILL.
FOURTEEN AND I SAID SOME COME
HERE AND HOW DID.
HE SAYS YOU KNOW YOU THE FIRST
MAY HAVE THE CIVIL HUGGED ME.
YOU KNOW.
SO THE REALITY OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR.
IS SOMETIMES THAT CONNECTION.
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED.
BUT WE GOT TO COMMIT WE GOT TO
COMMIT TO FEEL.
WE GOT A COMMITTED TO HEAL.
AND WE GOT TO COMMIT TO LEAD NOT
JUST IN PROGRAMS NOT JUST AND
JOB DEVELOPMENT BUT WE GOT A
BREAK THE GENERATIONS OF TRAUMA.
AND RECAPTURE THE SACREDNESS OF
WHO WE ARE THE NATIONAL COMBAT
THIS NETWORK IS DOING THAT WE
HAVE.
A WONDERFUL EXAMPLES AND FATHERS
AND FAMILY COACHELLA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU'LL HEAR FROM
THEM A BIT LATER BUT WE HAVE
WONDERFUL EXAMPLES OF HOW THIS
WERE AND NOW.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE EVIDENCE YOU AN
EVIDENCE BASE WE GOT EVIDENCE.
OKAY WE WE'VE GOT A STRONG
EVIDENCE BASE RESEARCH A
CONTINGENT THAT WE HAVE AND
YOU'RE NOT JUST A VERY HAPPY TO
BE HERE AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE LEADERSHIP THAT YOU PROVIDE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR LAST SPEAKER HERE FOR THIS
PANEL IS MISTER BETHANY COLLAPSE --
TELL ABOUT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD MEMBER HI GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN THAT'S AND
COMMITTEE.
ON IF THEY LEGALIZE SO SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER AT COACHELLA VALLEY
TO FIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT -- YOU
SERVE AS THE TRUSTEE
REPRESENTING AREA THREE WHICH
COVERS THE UNINCORPORATED AREAS
THE VOICES -- THAT'S PART OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THE WEST
WAS COMMUNITIES THAT DIVIDE INTO
DOES OUR SHORES SULTAN CITY AND
SALTON SEA BEACH.
IN AND TRYING TO COMMUNITIES
THAT A ARE PART OF IMPERIAL
COUNTY.
I GREW UP IN -- OASIS IN WHICH
IS THE COMMUNITY THAT ARE
PERCENT.
WITH TWENTY THREE WHEN I FIRST
CAME BACK ANDI DECIDED THAT I
NEEDED TO BE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT.
ARE THAT REYES ME AND YOU KNOW
THE GOOD AND THE BAD IN IN AND
HELP IN ENSURING THAT WERE ABLE
TO CREATE A SYSTEMIC CHANGE.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW THAT BRINGS
ME TO EIGHT YEARS AGO.
WHEN ALL THIS YOU KNOW BE OF
BOTH MEN OF COLOR -- YOU KNOW
WORK STARTED BEGINNING I I WAS A
JUNIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL -- AND
SUMMER GOING INTO MY SENIOR YEAR
GOT INVITED TO COME SACRAMENTO
AND YOU KNOW NOT DIDN'T THINK
THAT EIGHT YEARS LATER I'D BE
HERE SITTING DOWN THINKING THAT.
YOU KNOW WHEN I WHEN I GOT
CALLED BY REX YOU KNOW NEXT
SUMMER GARCIA PHONE BE UPON A
TALKING ABOUT THE LAST TEN YEARS
I MIGHT MY FIRST REACTION WAS
YOU KNOW TEN YEARS AGO.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN WE WORK HAVING
BEEN WORKING ALONG YOU KNOW WHO
WAS THE OTHER THE KITTY NOW BUT
IT IT IT DIDN'T IT MATTERS
BECAUSE I'M A BENEFICIARY OF OF
THE BOYS MEN OF COLOR.
A WORK THAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING
FOR THE LAST YOU KNOW TEN YEARS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES -- INFERRING
THAT WE WILL HAVE MENTORSHIP BUT
HAD THE PRIVILEGE.
AT THE TIME YOU KNOW YEARS AGO
WE HAD A MAYOR OF OUR CEILING
OKAY Là I AM IN MAYOR GARCIA
WAS THE MAYOR THAT -- YOU SAW
EVERY DAY WITH THE WRITING HIS
BIKE OR WHO YOU KNOW KNOCKING
DOORS AND SHOWING UP TO THE
NONPROFIT AREAS IN -- TALKING TO
YOU ALL RIGHT UP HIS VISIT HAVE
GOT LOW'S WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF
RICE IS GOOD BUT I WHICH IS A
GROUP THAT BROUGHT ME UP AND
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME EVER
THAT I EVER.
I GOT ASKED ABOUT YOU KNOW TO
GET INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I WAS
GONNA DO IN COLLEGE I KNEW I HAD
TO GO TO COLLEGE -- I WAS MY DAD
WOULD HAVE LIKED IT IN THAT THE
THE ORDER -- BUT I HAD NO IDEA
RIGHT WHAT WAS NEXT RIGHT AYE WE
NORMALIZE A LOT OF STUFF THAT
GOES ON IN HER FAMILY'S WHETHER
IT'S INNER CITIES A RURAL
COMMUNITIES -- WE'VE NORMALIZE
THE FACT THAT THERE'S NO PARKS
IN YOUR COMMUNITIES AND WE
NORMALIZE THAT WE HAVE TO DRIVE
TWENTY MINUTES INTO THE CITY TO
BUY POTABLE WATER.
I AND WE HAD NORMALIZED THE FACT
THAT OUR OUR OUR OUR SCHOOL.
DIDN'T DIDN'T UPPER IS WELL
ENOUGH TO GO -- TO COLLEGE RIGHT
IN -- IN ALL THESE THINGS WERE
NORMALIZED AND IT TOOK A MINUTE
TOOK MENTORS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT US AS YOUNG
FOLKS AT THE TIME WE HAD A CORD
OF ABOUT TWELVE FOLKS AND WE
STARTED ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS
WE HAD A YOUTH PARTIES BY ACTION
RESEARCH GROUP AND WE START
ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS ON IT IS
THIS NORMAL FOR TO BEGIN WITH
RIGHT IS.
THIS OKAY -- AND AND THE ANSWER
IS NO RIGHT THE ANSWER IS NO AND
AND WE WERE OUGHT WE WERE TAUGHT
TO LOVE OURSELVES -- AND WE WERE
TAUGHT TO ADVOCATE FOR CHANGE
AND WE'RE TIRED TO BE PART OF
THE CHANGE RIGHT AND AND IT
WASN'T GONNA BE HAVE IT WAS
GONNA HAPPEN JUST BY US.
BEING FRUSTRATED RIGHT AT FIRST.
I REMEMBER WHEN MY FIRST
COMMITTEE INVOLVEMENT IT A LOT
OF ANGER CAME UP RIGHT BECAUSE I
FELT SORT OF A A NOR RIGHT IN
SCHOOL GOING TO COMMUNITY
MEETINGS I I WAS ANGRY THAT I
DIDN'T HAVE PULLED WATER I WAS
ANGRY THAT WE HAVE PARKS AND AND
I WOULD.
AGREE THAT WOULD HAVE A LIBRARY
OR GREG RECREATION AREAS BUT YOU
KNOW FAST FORTY YEARS LATER I
IT'S IT'S OUT OF LOVE FOR
COMMUNITY THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS -- IT'S IT'S NOT
A LOVE THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE NORTH
SAMMY HERE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO TO
LEGISLATE LOVE IN AND THAT'S
VERY MUCH POSSIBLE TO THE POP
FORTY SEVEN OF FUNDING AT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY INVITES GOOD
HISTORY WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
GREAT WORK WITH.
UNETHICAL BUT IS NOW WE'RE JERRY
TALES HERE IN -- AND YOU KNOW A
B. WHO ARE MISS GONZALEZ FROM
OUR DISTRICT WILL BE SPEAKING
MORE ON ON ON THE ACTUAL YOU
KNOW DEVELOPMENT OF THAT GRANT
AND HOW WE'VE BEEN ABLE -- TO
HOW WE'VE BEEN ABLE IMPACT OUR
ADMINISTRATORS ARE TEACHERS OUR
STUDENTS BUT SURE THIS GROUP
QUIT BEING A LAST WEEK I GOT A
CHANCE TO MEET WITH MATT MICHAEL
DALE.
AT HIS OFFICE AND I WILL OVER
THE FINDING THE ONE THING STOOD
OUT TO ME A LOT RIGHT IT WAS --
UNDER THE PROPERTY SEVEN GRAND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO AMAZING
WORK IT'S IT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT A WAY THAT NOW WE'RE
GONNA.
A REAPPLY AND HOPEFULLY CONTINUE
DOING HIS WORK -- WITH WITH THE
NATIONAL COMPILERS NUMBER BUT
ONE THING THAT IN THE TRAINING --
THAT THERE WOULD THERE'D BE DO
UP PRE AND POST QUESTIONS AND
ONE OF THE PRE QUESTION ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS WAS -- EAT WHY DO
YOU THINK YOUR STUDENTS ACTIVE
FINE RIGHT AND A PART IN THE PRE
TO THE TRAINING THE MORE THE
ANSWER FOR MOST OF THE TEACHERS
BY A LOT BUT NOT BY A SMALL
MARGIN BUT BY A GREAT MARGIN WAS.
THAT THESE KIDS ARE JUST DEFINED
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO WRITE THE
THEY DON'T CARE -- THEY JUST
WOKE UP AND THEY'RE JUST GOING
TO BE WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO
RIGHT AND THAT WAS THE THAT WAS
PRE AND POST -- IT IN AND I LOOK
AT THAT AND IT WAS A DRAMATIC
DIFFERENCE IT WAS ACTUALLY IT
WAS LIKE OF OF THE ANSWERS THAT
WAS NOW 2% -- GOING FROM ABOUT I
WANNA SEE SOMEWHERE AROUND 35%
OF THE ANSWERS BEING THAT AND
THEN AFTER THE TRAINING AND
TEACHING ARE TEACHING THE
TEACHERS THAT.
ABOUT UNDERSTANDING HOW THEY
GREW UP AND WHERE THEY GO WHERE
WHERE THEY COME FROM THE
STRUGGLES THAT THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH WHETHER IT'S TAKING
THEIR KIDS THE THEIR YOUNGER
BROTHER SISTER TO THE SCHOOL AND
ENSURING THAT THEY GET TO SCHOOL.
AND THEY MIGHT BE A LITTLE TARDY
AND THIS ZERO TOLERANCE POLICIES
JUST DON'T WORK WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND ENSURING THAT WE
AS A COMMUNITY ARE YOU PUT
ADVOCATE FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES
AS LAW.
I THINK SOMETIMES -- SITTING
DOWN IN THE DISTRICT AND WHEN I
READ -- STUFF THAT WE WILL HAVE
TO WORK WITH THE ETHICAL.
A LOT OF TIMES IT'S GREAT -- FOR
INNER CITY SCHOOLS BUT AND RULES
COMMUNITIES WE WE HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT VERY DIFFERENT
STRUGGLES -- THAT YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADVOCATE --
FOR YOU KNOW AS I MENTIONED --
COULD TELL ABOUT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
IT WORST WERE MADE FLAT LEVEL
SCHOOL OF MIDSIZE SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAVE ABOUT FOURTEEN
WOMEN TO SCHOOLS FOR MIDDLE
SCHOOL FOR HIGH SCHOOL THAN ONE
CONTAMINATION ADULT SCHOOL --
AND AND WE REPRESENT THE AREAS
OF COACHELLA THAT AMOUNT MAKE ON
NORTH SHORE OASIS IN THE WEST
WAS THERE THAT I PER HASN'T
PRESENTED IN A LITTLE BIT OF
WITHIN CITY BLOCKING TESTED OF
INDIO -- BUT WE YOU KNOW THAT
THAT AREA WHEN ITSELF BUT YOU
KNOW FOR OTHER MY MANY PEOPLE
DOES NAMES BUT IT GOES FROM
HAVING SIDEWALKS TO EVERY.
ON EVERY ROAD TO GOING IN IN AND
YOUR CULTURE COMMUNITIES WERE
MANY FIRST GENERATIONS --
IMMIGRANT LIKE MYSELF GREW UP IN
AND YOU DON'T HAVE ANY SIDE
WALKS BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
SUPERVISOR PARROT BET IS AWESOME
ADDRESS YET MANY OTHERS HAVE
BEEN PAVING THE ROAD AND NOW
IT'S OUR DUTY I LIKE TO AND THAT
WAS A LOT NOW IT'S OUR DUTY AS
AS YOUNG.
FOLKS TO GO BACK IN THE ROAD TO
BEING PAVE WE HAD THE SIDEWALK
AND THE STREET LIGHTS AND YOU
KNOW INSURING THAT WE HAVE --
PROPERTY STOP THINGS THAT WE
COULD SEE AND AND AND AND ROADS
THAT AREN'T SO BUMPY.
IT ENDED LIKE NUMBER MUST WITH
THEY'LL SAYS IS IT'S BEYOND THAT
IT NEEDS TO BE TRANSFORMATIVE
ADJUSTED THAT THE PRO SO WE NEED
TAKE IN OUR SCHOOLS -- A WE NEED
TO WHAT WORKING AWAY WERE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WORK WITH OUR SCHOOLS IN
ENSURING THAT WE EDUCATE -- THE
SUPERINTENDENT OUR DISTRICT THE
ADMINISTRATORS THE TEACHERS --
BECAUSE THAT IN A DAY THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL THAT THAT ARE
STUCK IN WORKING WITH OUR TICKET
WITH THE KIDS MOST OF THE DAY
ALL OUR TEACHERS AND ENSURING
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO WORK WHAT
WHILE WITH OUR WITH OUR TEACHER
FRIENDS IN ENSURING THAT THE
THAT THE UNDERSTAND.
WHY IT IS IMPORTANT IT'LL GOAL A
LONG WAY -- YOU KNOW BUT I DID A
AYE YOU KNOW AS I MENTIONED A
EIGHT YEARS AGO I I WAS.
I WAS A STUDENT AND I ACTUALLY
GOT INVITED TO THIS MY SECOND BE
ABLE SEE PANEL IN TWENTY TWELVE
AND SO SEVEN YEARS AGO.
I WAS A STUDENT PANELISTS
TALKING ABOUT THE WHAT WAS IT
LIKE GETTING ON MY BUS AND GOING
INTO MY HIGH SCHOOL SO I TALKED
ABOUT IN ALTHOUGH THE ROLE THAT
WE TAKEN.
AND NOT AND BUT SEEM PANEL IT'S
MY THOUGHT THERE WAS THERE AND
ALIVE I TOOK IN A LOT OF THINGS
WELL IT WHILE IT WAS IN A DIRECT
LESSON FOR ME A HE YEAH I
REMEMBER HIM TALKING ABOUT --
ISSUES LIKE OUR NAME RIGHT I I
USED TO CALL MYSELF IN A TALL
THE I LET PEOPLE COMING UP
TOLLEY BECAUSE THAT'S HOW YOU
PRONOUNCE IT AND ARMS HE KNEW
YOU NEED BE PROUD OF WHO YOU ARE
IN A CHANGE THAT I CRACK PEOPLES
THAT THE LEAD IN -- AND THEN
ANOTHER ASPECT OF IT WAS -- I
REMEMBER GOING TO COLLEGE AND
BEING A FIRST YEAR IN COLLEGE
AND I I DIDN'T STUDY FOR A TEST
AND I PUT MY NAME IN IT AND I
THOUGHT I YOU KNOW I YOU KNOW I
I I I I'M NOT THE SMARTEST KID
BY FIGURE OF ITS.
OF A BUBBLE THEN I COULD I COULD
JUST I COULD DO GOOD -- BUT IT
TURNED OUT TO BE A FILL IN THE
BLANK TEST AND I HAD TO PUT MY
NAME.
AND THERE WAS NO BUT THERE'S
THERE WAS NO KEY WORD MY BOX OF
BUT I PUT MY NAME AND I ENDED UP.
TAKING THE TEST BACK AND I WENT
UP TO PROFESSOR AND I APOLOGIZE
TO HER AND I SAID YOU KNOW I'M
SO SORRY AND PROPELLING OPEN HOW
TO REACH OUT AND HOW DO.
YOU KNOW WILL MAKE A WORK WILL
MAKE IT WORK BECAUSE AT THE END
THEY WHEN I PUT THAT THE LEGAL
OUTSIDE CARRY MY ANCESTORS WITH
ME AND I I WAS IN THE I WOULD I
DON'T HAVE THE THE I I HAD THE I
HAD.
YOU KNOW PRIDE THAT I KNEW THAT
I COULD AND JUST YOU KNOW PUT
WHATEVER AND GET A WHATEVER
GREAT IN IT AND STUFF THAT YOU
KNOW WE HEAR FROM OUR MASTERS IN
OUR ELDERS SPEAK -- YOU KNOW AT
THE END THE THAT WAS IN DIRECTLY
FOR ME BUT I WAS ABLE TO GRASP
IT AND A LOT OF YOUNG FOLKS HERE
ARE YOU KNOW THEY'RE ABLE TO
LISTEN TO THESE WORDS AND THAT
THE IN THE DAYS A YEAR FROM NOW
TWO YEARS FROM NOW.
IT'S GONNA BE IN THEIR MIND AND
THEY'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO CHANGE
IT BUT TODAY WE CAN'T CELEBRATE.
I CAN'T CELEBRATE MYSELF OF THE
FIFTH ACCESS STORY.
IT HAS TO BE DONE WHEN WE BRING
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS WITH
THOSE -- TWO AT THE IN IT AT THE
END IT IS THIS WORKING TO
CONTINUE.
MORE INVESTMENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I NEED TO BE MADE --
TORE GONNA TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE
ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM THE RUINS OF THE
INNER CITIES BECAUSE OF THAT DAY
IT'S IT'S WE TALK ABOUT THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
BUT THAT WE'RE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS IT'S IT'S VERY
VERY TELLING AND LIKELY SHIP
LIKE.
I KNOW THAT WITH YOUR WORK AND I
WORK IN THE COMMUNITIES WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO GO A LONG WAY
AND WE'RE HERE TO LEND A HAND.
AND YOU KNOW JUST THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q..
ANY QUESTIONS FOR ANY OF THE
PRESENTERS HERE ON THIS PANEL
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DOCTOR WEBER OF I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU -- FOR FOR HONESTLY
SHARING OF THE JOURNEY THAT
YOU'VE BEEN ON AS WELL AS THE
JOINING THAT WE NEED TO TAKE --
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW WE ARE --
TRANSFERRING DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE TO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
AND I HAVE GREAT CONCERN ABOUT
THE MOVE AND I'M HOPING THAT
SOME OF YOUR INVOLVED WITH IT
BECAUSE I AS CHAIR OF THE THE
PART THAT PART OF THE BUDGET I
INSISTED THAT THERE.
IS A COMMUNITY ADVISORY GROUP --
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES FOLKS IN IN
EVEN IN THE CONVERSATION WANT TO
SIMPLY MOVE THE ONE AGENCY TO
THE NEXT AGENCY.
WITH THE SAME PEOPLE AND THE
SAME KIND OF THING THAT'S TO
OCCUR AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE I THINK YOU TALKED
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S MUCH
DEEPER.
OF AND IF WE'RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY TRANSFORM OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM SO THAT IT DOES
ADDRESS THE CRITICAL ISSUES WE
FACE RATHER THAN JUST SIMPLY
CHANGING THE LOCATION FROM WHICH
A PERSON.
GETS A PAYCHECK.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GIVEN
ANY THOUGHT TO THAT ANY OF YOU
ABOUT THAT -- BECAUSE WE ARE
PERFORMING THAT WAS IN THE
BUDGET NAP INSISTED THAT IT BE
THERE MAINLY BECAUSE I DIDN'T
SEE THE DEEP CONVERSATIONS BUT
SHOULD BE OCCURRING WHEN YOU
MAKE SUCH A MAJOR MOVES.
AND PEOPLE AT EXPECTATIONS BUT
THERE WAS NO PLAN AND I WAS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND THAT'S
RIGHT.
UP THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
DOCTOR WEBER AND YOU KNOW AS AS
SOMEONE WHO'S REPRESENTING --
COMMUNITY OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE -- POURED OVER THIS AT
LENGTH -- YOU KNOW I I'D LIKE TO
ALSO SAY WE WE SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS -- YOU KNOW I THINK THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR FIRMLY BELIEVES IN THE THE
IN THE CLOSURE OF YOUTH PRESENCE --
WE BELIEVE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE --
DO NOT NEED TO BE INCARCERATED --
AND WE WE SEE THIS TRANSITION AS
SOMETHING THAT COULD HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE -- BUT WITHOUT THE
OVERSIGHT WITHOUT THE DEDICATED
KIND OF COMMITMENT TO SHRINKING
THE POPULATION WITHOUT ANY
CONTROLS AROUND THE BUDGET -- WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT IT COULD BE
BUSINESS AS USUAL -- THAT
INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THE VERY
DEEP -- STRUCTURAL HARMS AND AND
THE THE VERY DEEP -- BRACE
RACISM THAT EXISTS THAT ALLOW SO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR TO BE
IN THAT PARTICULAR POSITION FOR
THE SAME CRIMES THAT WHITE KIDS.
COMMIT -- YOU KNOW WE STE WE
BELIEVE THAT -- WE JUST NEED TO
DO AWAY WITH IT ALTOGETHER --
AND SO -- YOU KNOW WE WE STAND --
IN IN THAT COMMUNITY OF CONCERN
WITH YOU -- WE ARE THANKFUL FOR
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND FOR
SOME MODICUM OF OVERSIGHT WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE
STRENGTHENED WITH WE WOULD LOVE
TO SEE ON THE LEADERSHIP OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTED.
BY DJJ -- AS PART OF THE
OVERSIGHT BODY -- WE WE WE HOPE
THAT WILL HAPPEN BUT WE DON'T
KNOW.
AND I SAW I DON'T SEE A CULTURAL
COMPONENT WHICH IS OF RIGHT.
WHICH IS SOMETIMES SO ESSENTIAL.
TO UNDERSTAND THE THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE BUT MORE
IMPORTANT AS YOU POINTED OUT.
THE UNDERSTAND THE STRENGTH THAT
COMES FROM UNDERSTANDING WHO YOU
ARE.
AND I'VE VISITED OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN GHANA ONCE AND
I WAS.
I WAS OF A JUVENILE HALL SAYS
SITUATION WHEN I WAS THE
VISITING ONE OF MY TIMES AND AND
I WAS AMAZED AT THAT THE PREMISE
UPON WHICH THE ORGANIZATION WAS
BUILT THAT WHEN KIDS ARE ARE.
ARE ARE PLACED IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM OR DO SOMETHING
THAT IS WRONG THEY HAVE TO GO
BACK AND HE'LL THE FAMINE AND SO
MUCH OF THE EFFORT WAS TO TALK
ABOUT.
HEALING THE FAMILY BECAUSE IF
THE FAMILY WORKED IN THE CULTURE
WORKED THEN YOU'D GET THE
OUTCOME THAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE WHICH IS A RESPECTFUL
ENGAGE YOUNG PERSON AND SO WHEN
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
THEY GO BACK AND LOOK AT WHAT
THEY DID WRONG WHAT WAS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE CULTURE THAT
CAUSES YOUNG PERSON NOT TO
RESPOND IN THE WAY THAT THEY
SHOULD.
A TO THE VALUES THAT WE IN THE
COMMUNITY ITSELF IT'S AN ON IT'S
IT'S QUITE A CHALLENGE BECAUSE
WE LIVE IN A KIND OF A SOCIETY
THAT DOESN'T WE DON'T OPERATE ON
VALUES.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T WE DON'T WE
DON'T GIVE OUR KIDS THAT THE THE
FEELING THAT YOU ARE NOW EIGHT
WEBER AND THAT MEANS SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T DO THAT AND SO.
UP YOU KNOW AND SO AS A RESULT
THAT THAT THAT THAT PIECE IS
BROKEN.
IS NEVER PUT BACK AND THEY JUST
KIND OF BUMP AROUND WITHOUT A
ANCHOR -- DOUBLE GOAL THE DAY'S
SUPPOSED TO CHEAT AS A MEMBER OF
A FAMILY IN A COMMUNITY.
SO I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
THAT NOT BEING THERE AND SO I'M
I'M HOPING THAT YOU FOLKS WILL
BE WATCHING GEN THAT YOU WILL BE
SHARING WITH US I'D STILL WHICH
I CHAIR THE PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET
SO.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
ASKED TO HAVE THINGS COME BACK
TO US SO THAT WE GET A CHANCE TO
REALLY ASSESS -- WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN WHETHER NOT IT'S
REALLY GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE?
IT'S ALSO ARE CONCERNED WITH
THAT AS WELL BECAUSE I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW THE THE SYSTEM THE
SYSTEM.
REALLY HAVE NOT.
BEEN SOMETHING THAT HAS HELPED
US TO TO REALIZE THAT THE TRUE
SACREDNESS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
KILLING POWER THAT WE HAVE.
AND I AND I THINK IT WOULD
REALLY WHERE WHERE THE FOCUS
NEEDS TO BE IS AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL AND WE FOUND IN SCHOOLS
THE YOUNGSTERS CAN HEAL
YOUNGSTERS -- YES THAT THAT THEY
KNOW HOW THEY THEY'RE THE
CLOSEST TO EACH OTHER THEY THEY
CAN DETECT WHEN ONE OF THE
PARTNERS IS OFF SCALAR.
TALKING ABOUT SUSE I MEAN THAT
YOU KNOW SO SO HOW DO WE EMPOWER.
YOUNG PEOPLE HOW TO EMPOWER
GRANDMOTHERS IN MY THAT MEAN
THERE'S YOU KNOW BECAUSE IN
WEIGHT WHEN I GREW UP IN AND
HAVE NO HEALTH CARE MY MY
GRANDMOTHER HE'LL MEGAN AND THE
END.
OF A LADY DOUBTS SO I THINK THIS
STILL THAT WE NEED TO RE FRAME
THE WAY WE LOOK AT THIS AND AT
THE THE OTHER PART.
IS THAT YOU TO WHERE WE DO A LOT
OF CAPACITY BILL OUT OF TRAINING
BUT WE DO A LOT OF FUN TRAINING.
TO LOT OF THE WORK WE DO IS ON
TRAINING PEOPLE IN THEIR
MENTALITY.
AND YOU KNOW A LOT A LOT OF
TIMES IN WE'RE TALK ABOUT
SERVICES WE DON'T TALK ABOUT.
TA DOLLARS A TRAINING DOLLARS A
CAPACITY BUILDING DOLLARS WE
JUST SAY LET'S IS TRANSFERRED TO
ANOTHER SYSTEM THAT WAY.
SO DEFINITELY WERE INTERESTED
AND AND YOU KNOW AND WE'LL BE
WATCHING BUT ANYTHING YOU COULD
PROVIDE IN TERMS OF SUPPORTIVE
OF MAKING SURE THAT HAPPENS -- I
THINK WOULD BE A WELCOME THANK
YOU ALL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES SOME NUMBER CALLED.
THANK YOU MICHELLE I THINK ALL
OF YOU -- IN IN.
TERMS OF TALKING ABOUT BY THEIR
INDIVIDUAL STORIES OR THE
MOVEMENT THAT'S BEEN CREATED
OVER.
THE LAST DECADE WHICH HAS BEEN.
QUITE REMARKABLE -- THINK IF HE
CAN THINK ABOUT -- HOW MANY
DECADES AS CANNELLA JUSTICE
SYSTEM HAS BEEN BUILT -- AND THE
SYSTEMS EVEN THOSE THAT PURPORT.
TO BE THERE TO HELP -- IT HAD
NOT BEEN DESIGNED THAT WAY AND
IT KIND OF CREATES AS MOMENTUM
THAT IS REALLY HARD TO STOP.
AND TO IT I'M JUST VERY GRATEFUL
THAT IN IN PRETTY SHORT ORDER OF
COURSE OBVIOUSLY INBAL HERE FOR
THE NEXT PANEL THE WORK TO BE
EASY WE STILL HAVE YET TO DO.
OTHER WE ALL OF KNOWLEDGE BUT
REMARKABLE IN A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME TO CHANGE THE
MENTALITY -- IN OUR COMMUNITIES
IN THIS BUILDING -- I GET A LOT
OF CREDIT. TO THE LEGISLATORS
THAT WERE HERE A DECADE AGO
BECAUSE FOR THEM TO BE ABLE.
TO TAKE THOSE INITIAL STATS WITH
ALL OF YOU.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW IT BOTH
COURAGEOUS AND AND HOW CYNICAL
PEOPLE WERE SKEPTICAL AND
CRITICISM THAT WAS RECEIVED --
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE
TO COME HERE AND JOIN A
LEGISLATURE THAT IS HAS ALREADY
HAS THAT.
MOMENTUM BUILT THANKS TO ALL OF
YOU SO MANY OF THE FOLKS HERE
THE AUDIENCE AND OF COURSE MY
COLLEAGUES.
THAT I SHARE THE DíAS WITH AND
SO -- I HAS ONE DOG OF THANKFUL
I AM AND YOU KNOW WHAT ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU THE MISTER
THEY'LL YOU SAID AS I GET ALL
CSU DON'T SEE OUR CHILDREN.
I I THINK THAT'S A BIG PART OF
WHAT WHAT DOCTOR WEBER IS
TALKING ABOUT IS CHANGING THAT.
MENTALITY IN OF IDENTITY -- AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT EVEN WHAT'S
WHAT CAME OUT IN THE NEWS RIGHT
NOW WHICH I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US ARE REALLY SURPRISE ABOUT.
ABOUT THESE BURKE BORDER PATROL
OFFICERS AND HOW THEY'RE
SPEAKING AND TALKING DOWN. TO
THOSE THAT ARE BEING
INCARCERATED ALONG OUR BORDERS.
THEY DON'T SEE THE HUMANITY IN
THOSE.
IN THOSE MOTHERS AND FATHERS
THEY DON'T SEE THE AMENITIES AND
THOSE CHILDREN AND BABIES I
DON'T SEE THEM.
FORGET EQUALS THEY DON'T EVEN
SEE THEM AS HUMAN.
AND THAT IS WHAT.
WE'RE CONTENDING WITH WILL MERGE
MANAGE MOVEMENT TO TURN THIS
SHIP OF INCARCERATION AROUND.
IS THAT -- WE'RE TRYING TO
INSTILL THE HUMANITY IN OUR OWN
CHILDREN BUT WE FIRST UP IS
STILL IN OURSELVES.
AND THE WORK YOU'RE DOING IS
DOING THAT THERE'S NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT.
AND I'M JUST A YOU KNOW I I
THINK THAT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
REGARDLESS.
OF THE OBSTACLES WE FACE THE WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT IT'S IT'S GENERATED NO WILL
TAKE A GENERATION OR MORE. FOR
THIS WORK TO REALLY STEP SEVEN
BECAUSE IT'S SO INGRAINED IN OUR
SYSTEM IN OUR HUMANITY OF WHO WE
ARE AND HOW WE LOOK AT ONE
ANOTHER BECAUSE OF MY AS
INDICATED YOU KNOW.
THE BEFORE YOU KILL ANYONE ELSE
OF THE HERE SELF AND I THINK
THAT.
THIS IS LIKE A DISEASE INFECTED
OUR NATION ARE VERY MUCH SO
INTENTIONALLY -- BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT GENOCIDE IS.
GENOCIDE IS NOT JUST PHYSICALLY
STRIPPING ONE OF THEIR LIVES OF
THEIR LIFE OR STRIPPING THEIR
CHILDREN AWAY -- IS STRIPPING
THE IDENTITY AWAY THE CONNECTION
WITH OUR HISTORY WITH A CULTURE
WITH WHO THEY ARE BECAUSE YOU
CAN EITHER DO IT PHYSICALLY OR
YOU COULD DO IT MENTALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY.
AND THAT GENOCIDE HAS HAS
SLIPPED INTO THESE COMMUNITIES
OF THESE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT YOU
NOW ARE ARE HEALING.
AND IT DOES TAKE TIME TO DO THAT
AND YOU KNOW AS SUB ARE PART OF
OUR BOARD MEMBER I'M NOT DALY
GALARZA.
BEAUTIFUL NAME -- WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE PAVING OF THE ROADS
AND WHAT HAVE YOU I THINK THAT'S
A REALLY GREAT ANALOGY --
BECAUSE IT TOOK SO LONG JUST TO
GET THOSE ROADS PHYSICALLY PAVE
IN YOUR COMMUNITIES THANKS THE
WORK REPRESENT AS YOU HAVE LIKE
LIKE -- ARE CHAMBERS GARCIA AND
OTHERS -- BUT THAT'S THAT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL LIKE THAT THA
GETTING YOUR MOSTLY TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE SMOOTHLY THAT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL BUILDING BLOCK.
AND NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU
WHAT'S ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT
YOU NEED IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE LAST TEN
YEARS YOU ALL HAVE BEEN PAVING
THE ROADS THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PAID A LONG TIME AGO.
YOUR YOUR PAVING ROADS THAT HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED.
AND I THINK NOW IS THE NEXT TEN
YEARS AND AND MANY DECADES TO
COME IT'S ABOUT WHAT ELSE WE
HAVE TO BUILD IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BEYOND THOSE BASIC NECESSITIES
OF JUST FUNDAMENTAL IDENTITY AND
AND FEELING VALUED AND SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF
YOU IS A LONG WAY OF SAYING
THANK YOU. TO ALL OF YOU AND
OTHERS HAVE BEEN DOING THE WORK
IN A IT WAS CLEARLY TO OUR CHAIR.
DOCTOR WEBER AND OTHERS THAT
HAVE BEEN DOING THE WORK BEFORE
I GOT HERE AND I'M IS GRAVELY
PART OF THE TEAM.
VERY WELL SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AS WELL.
A POWERFUL TESTIMONY THAT -- YOU
GENTLEMAN GIVE -- THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FOR PARTICIPATING WITH US WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PANEL.
AND WE HAVE A CHAT WHO IT WOULD
CENTER AT THIS YEAR HELP
FOUNDATION.
SLIGHT CHANGE -- WE WILL HAVE
QUESTION MURPHY ALL SMITH WITH
LIBERTY HILL FOUNDATION'S
PRESENT AFTER -- FOLLOWED BY
HARRY GRAMMAR NEW WORTH.
ANTHONY ROLL BLISS YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION IN.
A BE GONZALEZ EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS FOR COULD TELL BY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU EVERYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE ALSO FOR A YOUR A
PARTICIPATION.
WE WILL BE HAVING A PUBLIC
COMMENTS AFTER THIS PANEL.
OF FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE HERE
WOULD LIKE TO CHIME IN.
ADD TO THE CONVERSATION AS WELL
AFTER THIS LAST PANEL -- WE CAN
BEGIN [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE YOU WANNA.
THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR OF BEING
HERE TODAY AND I WILL KEEP MY
REMARKS BRIEF OF THAN I HAD
ANTICIPATED. FOR TWO REASONS.
FIRST IS I THINK MUCH OF WHAT
YOU PROBABLY NEED TO HEAR HAS
BEEN SAID -- PARTICULARLY IN THE
SECOND PANEL -- TODAY.
AND SECONDLY BECAUSE ONE OF MY
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITIES.
IN THIS WORK IS TO BE A GOOD
FATHER MYSELF.
AND AS OUR HIS ROOM LATE MY
PHONE IS BUT THEN BECAUSE I HAVE
TWO YOUNG BOYS TO PICK UP -- WHO
PICKING A DEBT TO SHOW UP?
AND I WILL MAKE SURE THAT I GET
THAT DONE -- TODAY ON TIME.
I'M SO THAT I AM LIVING UP TO
THE VALUES WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT DOES RELATES TO BOYS AND
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR -- IN
CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS CHET YOU WOULD ON THE
CO PRESENCE HERE HEALTH
FOUNDATION THE CENTER IT'S YOUR
HEALTH -- WE ARE FOUNDING
MEMBERS AND THE MANAGER THE
CALIFORNIA FUND IS FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR.
COLLABORATION OF SENIOR LEADERS
FROM FIFTEEN OF FOUNDATIONS
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT AND LIBERTY HILL
FOUNDATION WHO ARE REPRESENTED
HERE TODAY -- AS WELL.
OUR COLLECTIVE BE MOC WORKERS
GUIDED BY LIFE BECAUSE FRAMEWORK.
A CRADLE TO CAREER APPROACH TO
IMPROVING OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS
THE LIFETIME OF BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR A HEARING CALIFORNIA.
AT THE CENTER IN ADDITION TO
ADMINISTRATING CIPM ALL SEE WE
HAVE RESPONDED TO THE
RECOGNITION.
THAT OUR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
FACE INSTITUTIONAL BARRIERS TO
OPPORTUNITY FROM CHILDHOOD TO
ADULTHOOD WITH PROGRAMS IN THIS
IS LIKE MY BROTHER'S KEEPER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO BILL BLACK.
AND A POSITIVE JUSTICE
INITIATIVE WHICH IS ELEVEN
COUNTY EFFORT TO TRANSFORM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT IS COMMITTED TO IMPROVING
EDUCATIONAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC OUTCOME FOR YOUTH
OF COLOR -- AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IN CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS
OF THEIR GENDER ALTHOUGH
COMMENTS TODAY HERE ARE REALLY
FOCUSED.
ON BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE STAFF TO SEE A BMO SEES
REGIONAL ACTION COMMITTEES AND
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS TO ALIGN.
AND LEAD COMMUNITY SPECIFIC
PARTIES THE PROMOTE EQUITY
INCLUSION OF BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR.
BY ENSURING THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
COMPLETION OF COLLEGE DEGREES.
DISMANTLING AND TRANSFORMING
YOU'VE JUST TO SYSTEMS.
PROMOTING DISSIPATION ECONOMY BY
MAKING EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
ANNOUNCEMENT OR OPPORTUNITIES
MORE ACCESSIBLE.
I JUST WANT TO NOTE BUT I KNOW
YOU HEARD TODAY.
FROM THE FOLKS FROM THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITY
ACT.
THE DEPARTMENT LABOR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ONE THING THAT'S
ONE ON THE SCHOOL THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO DO GOING FORWARD AS WE
THINK ABOUT THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
THE KIND OF INCENTIVES THOSE
SYSTEMS HAVE SIR NOT SIMPLY
FOCUSED ON DISLOCATED WORKERS
BECAUSE THEY ARE PERFORMANCE
SYSTEMS.
NOT TENDS TO MAKE THEIR WORK
WITH DISADVANTAGED YOUTH LESS
KIND OF INTERESTING TO THEM AS
THEY TRY TO PRODUCE GOOD NUMBERS.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN MEASURE THE
WRONG THINGS.
SOMETIMES YOU SIMPLY MEASURING
WHETHER YOU GOT FOLKS WHO MAY
HAVE LOST THE JOB ANOTHER JOB.
THE MOST POWERFUL THING YOU CAN
DO WITH WE OWE IT IS TO GET
FOLKS WHO HAVE CONTINGENT WORK
OR WHO HAVE NEVER INTO THE WORK
FORCE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THAT PARTICULAR EXPERIENCE.
SO.
EVEN AS WE THINK ABOUT
MEASUREMENT THESE ARE WE THINK
ABOUT THE POWER OF THOSE
PARTICULAR SYSTEMS OF A CORNICE
LEGISLATURE GOING FORWARD. TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE INCENTIVES TO
ENSURE THAT THE METRICS THAT WE
ARE ACTUALLY PAYING ATTENTION TO
ON METRICS THAT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
AND THAT'S PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR WHO
SHOULDN'T BE LEFT OUT A
WORKFORCE WITH THE BUILDING A
NEW STATE BUILDING.
NEXT DOOR OR WHETHER YOU'RE
BUILDING HOUSING IN A REAL YARDS
OF SACRAMENTO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIX THE HOMELESS PROBLEM IN LOS
ANGELES WE NEED THESE YOUNG MEN
TO HELP REBUILD A SOCIETY.
THAT HAS LOTS OF NEEDS AND THEY
HAVE THE TALENT THE TOOLS THE
INTENTION THE INSPIRATION TO DO
SO SYSTEM SHOULD NOT BE AN
OBSTACLE.
THE MAKING THAT HAPPEN SO I JUST
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT POINT
GOING FOR BECAUSE I THINK --
OTHERWISE WE LEFT A LOT OF GREAT
LEGISLATION WHICH DOESN'T
TRANSLATE INTO CHANGES IN
PRACTICE IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
IT'S ACTUALLY NEED.
THAT'S WHERE WE START OUR BELIEF.
THAT'S WELL WORK COMES FROM
THAT'S THE THE THE PLACE THE
CENTERING THAT WE DO AROUND THE
WORK OF THE FOUNDATION AND WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES MORE BROADLY.
SO YOU KNOW THE QUESTION OF US
RESPOND TO WHAT WE KNOW WHAT
ABOUT THE NEXT TO EXTEND -- TEN
YEARS LET ME START BY THAT.
OFTEN MY RESPONSES QUESTION BIKE
KNOWLEDGE I'M SURROUNDED HERE
TODAY BY ADVOCATES OF VARIOUS
STRIPES WHO DOING GREAT WORK.
THE LIFE OF BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR CALIFORNIA FUND IS FOR A
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ITSELF AND CLEARLY
ADVOCATES WHO WORK IN COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE
WHAT TOGETHER BY THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT SUCCESSFUL FUTURE FOR
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES THE VISION
TALENT AND CUT REASON OF ALL OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE -- THIS WORK
AND THE RELATIONSHIP IN
CONNECTION TO THIS BODY.
AND THE BODIES IT'S CONNECTED TO
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE GOT TO CONTINUE.
AND ABOUT ALL THE YEARS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN FUNDING THE BUILDING
OF INSTITUTIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST
BUILDING OF PRISONS IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
OUR COMMITMENT TO BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR SHOULD MERE OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE BUILDING OF
THAT PARTICULAR SYSTEM.
IF WE DID IT FOR THIRTY YEARS WE
SHOULD BE FOR TALKING ABOUT.
THIRTY IF WE SPEND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO CREATE THAT HARM
REPARATION CITIES COMMUNITIES
SUGGEST WE SHOULD SPEND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FIXING THE HARM THAT
WE'VE CREATED IN CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AND SO I THINK THE NEXT
TEN YEARS I'D LIKE TO SEE.
SUSTAINABLE YOU KNOW FUNDING AND
A COMMITMENT TO A LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP TO GET THIS JOB
WORK FOR THE NEXT GENERATION OF
FOLKS WHO SIT IN YOUR SEAT --
SIT MIND OR NOT HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION GOING FULL.
SECOND WHILE THERE'S A LOT TO BE
PROUD OF IN OUR COLLEAGUE MARC
PHILPOTT TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE
HUNDRED PLUS BILLS THAT WE HAVE
A FOCUSED ON WE SEE A SHIFT IN
THE WAY THE YOUNG PEOPLE WERE
LEAVING THE SEPARATE.
ALL THINKING AND ACTING AND THEY
NEED PERMANENT LEGISLATIVE
ACTION.
HELLO WE KNOW THAT THIS GOOD THE
LEGISLATION THAT PRECLUDES
EXPLOSIONS TO SCHOOLS ABOUT TO
EXPIRE. NINE THAT'S NOT A
PROBLEM TO FIX.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED THROUGH THAT WASN'T THE
KIND OF KIND OF INFORMATION THAT
SUCCESS THAT SUGGEST THAT TO BE
A PILOT PROJECT.
RIGHT THAT'S NOT A PILOT.
THAT WAS PERMANENT HARM THAT WAS
DONE IT NEEDS PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS AND SO WE NEED POLICY
NOT.
NOT NOT SET TO SUNSET AT SOME
POINT.
BUT ACTUALLY MAKES A PERMANENT
CASE FOR WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
FOR OUR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
GOING FORWARD FUNDING FOR THAT
IS IMPORTANT.
I'M GONNA QUICKLY SAY THAT I'D
BE REMISS AS SOME OF THE THE
MAJORITY ABOUT WORK IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY A CALIFORNIA TO
ACTUALLY KNOW THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN.
AVAILABLE FUNDING BETWEEN OUR
LARGER COMMUNITIES ON AND
WEALTHY COMMUNITIES ON THE COAST
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA AS WELL -- I TESTED
IN THE YEARS GOING FORWARD BUT
YOU DO ALL YOU CAN TO HIM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WERE SOME
EQUITY.
I IN EQUITY IS NOT THE SAME
AMOUNT SOME FAIRNESS AND HOW WE
THINK ABOUT RESOURCE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE FACING A
DIFFERENT POLITICAL AND SOCIAL
ENVIRONMENT MANIPULATE SOME
MAKING CHANGE HAPPEN.
YES THIS IS BLUE CALIFORNIA WITH
A LOT OF WRITTEN THE STATE THAT
WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THE CHANGES THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE.
THIRD THE STATE HAS IMPORTANT
ROLE TO PLAY IN BE PURPOSING
EXISTING FUNDS FROM HARMFUL
PITIFUL SYSTEMS TOLD OF ELEMENT
OF A MORE EXPANSIVE CONSUMER OF
CARE FOR SYSTEM.
IMPACTED A YOUNG PEOPLE.
THAT'S JUST MY WAY OF SAYING
THAT YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO
DO NOT JUSTICE FUNDING TO CREATE
THE KIND OF INCENTIVES THAT
FORCE COUNTY TO DO THE THINGS
THAT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT TODAY.
AND I ACTUALLY DON'T BELIEVE I'M
A FORMER COUNTY WELFARE DIRECT
THEM A FORMER CHILD WELFARE
DIRECTOR IN ALAMEDA COUNTY PROUD
PUBLIC SERVANT BUT I BELIEVE
THOSE SYSTEMS WILL NOT DO ALL
THEY CAN.
UNLESS YOU CREATE THE KIND OF
INCENTIVES -- AND MANDATE
REQUIRE THAT THEY ACTUALLY DO SO
AND IT'S WITHIN YOUR POWER TO
ACTUALLY MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND WE
WOULD CALL ABOUT HIS BODY TO
MAKE SURE THAT IS INDEED AND IN
FACT.
WHAT TAKES PLACE?
WE HAVE THE RESEARCH WE HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE THE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS PARTNERS GREET EXPAND
THESE ALTERNATIVES AND PROMOTE
NEW THINKING ABOUT WHAT A
BELOVED COMMUNITY FOR ALL YOUTH.
LOOKS LIKE WHEN IT IS FULLY
ACTIVATED -- AND IS LEVERAGING
THE POWER IN THE KNOWLEDGE OF
COMMUNITY GROUPS THEMSELVES
FOURTH WE TO PRIORITIZE MOVING
UPSTREAM.
WE GOT TO WORK WITH YOUNGER AND
YOUNGER KID.
NO IT'S OKAY AND IT'S GREAT TO
SAY THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
KIDS WHO ENGAGE IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT MANY OF THOSE
KIDS WERE ONCE.
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
WE KNOW HOW THAT HISTORY AND HOW
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE A TRACK YOU
HEAR A LOT OF TALK TODAY ABOUT
ACES AND TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
WELL YEAH LET'S TALK ABOUT A
FIFTH AND FOURTH GRADERS.
AND LET'S NOT DO IT IN A WAY AND
I THINK.
THE COMPOUND IS NETWORK OF
COLLEAGUES THE SAID IT WELL
LET'S LET'S NOT PATHOLOGY
BECAUSE THEM IN THIS NOT MAKE
THEM NO PROBLEM.
LET'S JUST MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE KIND OF SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES THAT YOUNG PEOPLE NEED
TO BE ON A HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT
THE TRACK AND I THINK THAT OUR
LIFE COURSE FRAMEWORK ACTUALLY
POINTS OUT.
EXACTLY WHAT THAT IS.
I SAID A MUCH I WAS UGH UGH --
COUNTY WILL FOR DIRECTOR -- AND
I ONE OF MY FAVORITE THINGS
ALWAYS BEEN YOU CAN'T SERVICE
PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY.
YOU GOT TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY.
OPPORTUNITY IS THE HELIUM AND IN
EVERYONE'S LIFE BELOW.
RIGHT AND THAT'S ABOUT EDUCATION
THAT'S ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES TO
WORK THAT'S ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT O ACTIVITIES THAT
FOLKS ACTUALLY NEED I REALLY
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT WE NEED
TO BE VERY FOCUSED.
ON MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ALL AVAIL
AVAILABLE FOR YOU FOR KIDS AS
WELL.
I HAVE MORE TO SAY ABOUT US ONE
AT ONE END WITH JUST TWO THINGS.
I WANT TO ALSO ENCOURAGE JUST AS
DO WHAT WE WHAT WE SAY WE WILL
ALWAYS DO WHAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE UNDERSTOOD WELL
UNSCREW ARGUMENT TODAY.
AND THAT IS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PLACE BOYS AND YOUNG MEN A CALL
OF THEMSELVES AT THE CENTER OF
THE WORK THAT WE ARE ENGAGED IN.
THEIR VOICE THEIR KNOWLEDGE
THEIR EXPERIENCE.
IS ESSENTIAL TO OUR ABILITY TO
BE EX A SUCCESSFUL GOING FORWARD.
IS NOT A KIND OF HIP FUNKY COOL
TRENDY THING TO DO IT IS A
NECESSITY IT IS A REQUIREMENT
FOR SUCCESS.
AND WE BELIEVE WE GOT TO BE ABLE.
TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
I AM A REALLY QUICK PERSONAL
STORY BEFORE I AGAIN I MAKE MY
EXIT TO GO PICK UP MY TWO YOUNG
MEN MY FOURTEEN YEAR OLD.
IN MY LIVING YEAR OLD WITH
TEXTING ME LIKE CRAZY.
ABOUT COMING TO GET THEM.
I'M A MAN WHO WAS CLEARLY IN THE
MIDDLE PART OF MY LIFE -- IN
MANY YEARS AGO -- I GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL AT A REFORM
SCHOOL IN NEW YORK CITY ON THE
PRISON ISLAND KNOWN AS RYKER'S
ISLAND WHICH WE HOPE TO CLOSE --
IN THE YEARS AHEAD.
AS WELL -- WHAT WHAT I REALLY
HOPE THAT COMES OUT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS?
THIS IN A BETTER SENSE OF
CONNECTION OR A BETTER
ARTICULATION OF OUR COMMITMENT
TO THIS WORK.
IT REALLY IS THAT IN THE FUTURE
THERE WILL BE NO STORIES LIKE
SOME OF THOSE THAT YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY.
THAT THE TRANSFORMATION OF THE
SYSTEM IS NOT SOMETHING WE WILL
HAVE TALKED ABOUT.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
HAVE DONE.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME HERE TODAY AGAIN PARDON ME
FOR SCOOTING OUT.
BUT I WILL GO HOME TO GET MY
BOYS TAKE CARE BUSINESS BY THE
THANK YOU.
SO MUCH OUR NEXT A CENTER WILL
BE -- SHANE MURPHY GOLDSMITH THE
LIBERTY OF FOUNDATION HI.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SPENDING
SO MANY HOURS WITH US I
APPRECIATE YOU LASTING TILL THE
VERY END AND SITTING THROUGH
HOURS AND HOURS FAMILY.
YOUR TIME AND I KNOW YOU'RE BUSY
SCHEDULES -- SO YOU CHAMBER
GOLDSMITH PRESENT CO LIBERTY
HEALTH FOUNDATION I ALSO SERVE
ON THE POLICE COMMISSION WHICH
OVERSEES THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT I'M NOT SPEAKING AND
I CAPACITY BUT A FOR
IDENTIFICATION PURPOSES ONLY --
SO LIBERTY HEALTH -- PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS IN LOS ANGELES
THAT ARE FINDING INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS BY ENGAGING THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTED AND
SOLVING SOME OF OUR MOST
INTRACTABLE PROBLEMS LIKE THAT
YOU KNOW JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND I'M ALSO OF THE PROUD
CULTURE OF CALIFORNIA FUNDERS
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND BEEN WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE SINCE ITS
INCEPTION AND THAT'S A BEVERLY --
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE AND SO I'M
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE NEXT TEN
YEARS AND HOW WE CAN TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA FROM BEING THE
BIGGEST DEALER OF KIDS IN THE
WORLD. TO BEING THE BIGGEST
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD -- AND WANT TO SHARE THE
STORY OF LOS ANGELES WHERE WE'VE
CREATED A NUMBER OF MODEL
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES THAT -- WE
HOPE OTHERS CAN.
LEARN FROM AND EXPAND -- SO YOU
MAY NOT KNOW THAT A LOS ANGELES
PLANS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO INVEST
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN EACH OF THOUSANDS OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN.
IMAGINE THE THE NURTURING AND
THE GROWTH THAT COULD HAPPEN BY
INVESTING THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
KIDS.
BUT IN LA INSTEAD OF INVESTING
IN NURTURING OUR KIDS ARE
ACTUALLY GONNA INVEST SIDE AND
INCARCERATING THEM THAT'S HOW
MUCH WE'RE GONNA PAY PER YEAR TO
INCARCERATE A KID.
SO IN LOS ANGELES WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY KIDS IN JAIL
YOU TONIGHT THAT'S A FEW
THOUSAND A YEAR WE ARREST OVER
TEN THOUSAND KIDS SO WERE ON THE
WE ARE THE BIGGEST L. LA ITSELF
IS THE BIGGEST DEALER IN VEGAS --
ARRESTING MARKETS IN ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD.
AND 95% OF THE KIDS WHO ARE IN
JAIL IN LOS ANGELES ARE BLACK
AND BROWN BOYS.
AND AS THE NUMBER OF KIDS IN
JAIL LOS ANGELES HAS GONE DOWN
OVER THE YEARS.
OF THE PROPORTION OF THOSE KIDS
WERE BLACK AND BROWN HAS GONE UP.
SO RACIAL EQUITY BECOMES REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE START TO
TRANSFORM THE SYSTEM.
AND MOST OF THE KIDS WERE
ARRESTED INCARCERATED -- IN LOS
ANGELES IN FACT 80% OF THEM ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION SO THE
STATE HAS HAS DECIDED THAT MINOR
OFFENSES LIKE PETTY THEFT --
SCHOOLYARD FIGHTS TRUANCY THINGS
LIKE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A
DIVERSION AND THE LOS ANGELES
80% OF THE KIDS WE ARE RESTING
DON'T NEED TO BE ARRESTED
ACCORDING TO STATE LAW -- HAVE
YOU VISITED DO YOU TH STEALTH.
YEAH I HAVE I WAS THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER FROM ELEVEN YEARS OR
NOT SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
SO YOU KNOW -- IN MY EXPERIENCE
IN VISITING YOUTH JAILS IS THAT.
JUST FINDING SUCH EXTRAORDINARY
KIDS BRILLIANCE.
OF POETS AND HILARIOUS STORY
TELLERS AND HARD WORKING KIDS
YOU JUST WANNA PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
KIDS HAVE BEEN ABANDONED AND BY
EVERY SYSTEM THAT SET UP TO
SUPPORT THEM.
AND WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT THESE
KIDS IN THAT NO KIDS BELONG
BEHIND BARS.
SO THAT'S WHY WE LAUNCHED
INITIATIVE AT LIBERTY HELL TO
AND YOU CAN CONSERVATION AS WE
KNOW IT AND BUILDING YOU
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM IN ITS PLACE.
AND WE'RE GONNA USE A STRATEGY
WE CALL SHRINK CLOSE IN INVEST
SO WE WANT TO SHRINK THE NUMBER
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE ARRESTED --
BY 50% IN THE NEXT THREE TO FIVE
YEARS WE WANNA CLOSE THE NUMBER
OF YOUTH JAILS -- BY HALF IN THE
NEXT THREE TO FIVE YEARS AND WE
WANT TO BRING IN OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO INVEST A DO
YOU DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM THAT
WE'RE BUILDING I'M FROM SCRATCH.
AND THIS IS ALL HAPPENING
THROUGH THE LEADERSHIP OF YOUNG
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZERS MANY OF WHOM ARE IN
THIS ROOM AT THIS TABLE WHOARE
LEADING THE WAY.
BRING IT TOGETHER OP
PHILANTHROPY ELECTED OFFICIALS
GOVERNMENT LEADERS THAT WITH
UNDER THEIR VISION OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE DEVELOPED AND
FIGHTING LIKE HELL FOR THIS
VISION -- TO SHRINK CLOSE INVEST.
SO WE HONOR THE CONSEQUENCE OF
YOU THE RESTORATION OF VIRAL
HERE I WON'T GO THROUGH ALL OF
THEM I CAN TELL YOU YOU KNOW
FROM MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE MY
LITTLE BROTHER WENT TO JAIL HE
WAS A KID AND HAS BEEN IN AND
OUT OF JAIL AND HOMELESSNESS
EVER SINCE.
AND HE DESCRIBES THIS
ENVIRONMENT OF A YOUTH JAIL LIKE
IT'S LIKE AN MMA ARENA WERE
LITERALLY THE KIDS ARE THERE TO
TRAIN ON HOW TO FIGHT AND WIN.
AND THE SKILLS THAT THEY LEARN
QUITE ADEPTLY IN JUVENILE HALL
AND YOUTH JAILS THIS THE SKILLS
THAT THEY LEARN TO SURVIVE ARE
THE SAME EXACT.
SKILLS THAT WHEN THEY COME ON
THE OUTSIDE CAN DESTROY THEIR
LIVES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND I DON'T I JUST CANNOT FOR
THE LIFE OF ME FATHOM WHY WOULD
BE PAYING ALL THIS MONEY TO
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT LIKE THAT
FOR KIDS.
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY WHAT KIND OF
ONE OF THE ELEMENTS OF A YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM OR IF YOU
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES THAT ARE
SO IMPORTANT -- SO WE'LL GO
THERE ALL THOSE BUT IT'S ALL
BASED ON THE RESEARCH AND THE
BRAIN SCIENCE THAT TELLS US THAT
WHAT WE KNOW WHICH IS KIDS ARE
DIFFERENT THAN ADULTS AND THEIR
THE WAY THEY THINK ABOUT
CONSEQUENCES THE AND ESPECIALLY
LONG TERM.
CONSEQUENCES THE RISK TAKING
BEHAVIORS -- THE KINDS OF
PRACTICES THAT CAN HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE VERSES MAKE THEM
FEEL SO ASHAMED THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO BE SELF DESTRUCTIVE.
THAT'S ALL IT REALLY CRITICAL IN
DESIGNING PROGRAMS FOR KIDS AND
WE KNOW THAT.
THAT YOUTH JAILS DO NOT HAVE ANY
OF THAT AND FOR THE MOST PART
AND THAT THERE REALLY LEAVING
OUR KIDS WORSE OFF THAN THEY
FIND THEM BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THESE PRACTICES WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THE REALITY IS MOST OF
THESE KIDS -- ID ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR DIVERSITY DON'T AB IN JAIL
THEY DON'T NEED TO BE ARRESTED
AND THE PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE IT OUT IN THE COMMUNITY
ARE GOING TO HAVE THESE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES ARE TO BE
MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE AT SERVING
OUR KIDS.
AND IN FACT INSTEAD OF PAYING
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO INCARCERATE OUR KIDS
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
TODAY THE PARTICULAR YOUTH
DIVERSION IS ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER KID.
SO FOR FIVE THOUSAND BUCKS YOU
SAVE A LOT OF MONEY AND YOU THE
KID IS WAY LESS LIKELY 2% OF A
IT -- LESS LIKELY TO BECOME
HOMELESS TO BECOME POOR -- TO TO
FIND THEMSELVES IN OF UNSAFE
SITUATIONS -- SO THE HEART OF OF
THE OUR STRATEGY IS REALLY YOUTH
DIVERSION WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT TODAY SO THAT'S A A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BASED
PROGRAM WHERE KIDS ACTUALLY COME
FACE TO FACE AND WHEN POSSIBLE
WITH -- THE VICTIM IF THERE IS A
VICTIM IN MOST CASES THERE IS
NOT BUT IF THERE IS THEY'RE ABLE
TO REALLY -- BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AND MAKE AMENDS AND THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR DEVELOPING
BRAINS -- TO INSTEAD OF JUST
FEELING ASHAMED AND LIKE THEY'RE
BAD PEOPLE AND THEY CAN NEVER DO
BETTER AND THAT BECOMES A SELF
FULFILLING PROPHECY -- A REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY ENABLES THEM TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANY HARM
THEY'VE DONE AND MAKE IT BETTER --
WHICH IS HEALING FOR THEM -- AND
SO THESE DIVERSION PROGRAMS ARE
ARE WILDLY SUCCESSFUL THE
RECIDIVISM RATES ABOUT 11%
WHEREAS IF THEY GO GET ARRESTED
AND GO TO JAIL IT'S MORE LIKE
33% -- SO OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS AS A RESULT OF ALL THIS
WORK WE'VE SEEN TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS AND HOPE THAT IT LIKE I
SAID IT CAN BE REPLICATED
ELSEWHERE AGAIN AS A RESULT OF
ORGANIZING BY YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION AND MANY OTHERS WHO
ARE HERE.
AND NOT HERE -- WE SEE THAT OUR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SUPPORTS
HIS VISION THE HEAD OF THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT SAYS SHE
DOESN'T WANT THESE KIDS IN JAIL
THE CHIEF OF POLICE SO I SPEND A
LOT OF TIME WITH SAYS HE DOES
WANT TO BE ARRESTING THESE KIDS --
PHILANTHROPY IS LINING UP TO
FUND THESE STRATEGIES -- AND AS
A RESULT WE'VE SEEN -- SEVERAL
MILLION DOLLARS INVESTED IN A
YOUTH DIVERSION DEVELOPMENT
SYSTEM THAT WE'RE CREATING IN
LOS ANGELES THERE'S A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
LIBERTY HILL AND THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT TO DO CAPACITY
BUILDING IN SUPPORT SO THAT
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS CAN.
THAT THAT ARE WORKING
COMMUNITIES WITH THESE KIDS
ALREADY CAN SCALE UP AND GET
GOVERNMENT FUNDING TO CREATE A
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM AS A
REAL ALTERNATIVE WE HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE OBAMA
FOUNDATION WHICH CHAT TALKED
ABOUT -- AND THAT COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH --
AND THEN OF COURSE THE YOUTH OF
REINVESTMENT FUND THAT YOU ALL
CREATED LAST YEAR HAS BEEN A
HUGE SUCCESS IS INVESTED --
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION IS ABOUT TO
ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ACROSS THE STATE AND
PUTTING IN THE DISTRICTS OF MANY
OF THE FOLKS ON THIS COULD --
COMMITTEE.
AND HOPE IT GETS RENEWED IN
YEARS TO COME -- AND THEN AND
THEN SB FOUR THIRTY NINE WHICH
IS MITCHELL'S BILL LAST YEAR
THAT'S A BEING IMPLEMENTED IN LA
COUNTY NOW THAT CREATES A
MINIMUM AGE OF ARRESTING CARS
ORATION OF ELEVEN SO THE KIDS
ELEVEN UNDER CAN'T BE --
INCARCERATED WERE ACTUALLY
WORKING ON THE SANDALS TO AND
REYES THAT AGE -- ABOVE THAT IN
FACT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH
IS THE LARGEST IN THE NATION IS --
ABOUT.
TO BREAK A DEAL WHERE THEY WILL
STOP ARRESTING KIDS ON THEIR
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL CAMPUSES -- SO TRUMP
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SUCCESS AND
WOULD LOVE TO PARTNER WITH YOU
TO TO DO THAT ALSO WHERE TO TAKE
OUR LESSONS ELSEWHERE AND I WILL
SAY THAT. FOR ME THE MOST
AMAZING PART OF THIS WORK IS
JUST THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
LEADING THIS WORK WHO HAVE BEEN
IN JAIL HIS FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN IN JAIL AND OUR OVERCOMING
TREMENDOUS -- OBSTACLES TO FIGHT
TO OVERTURN THE SYSTEM -- AND WE
CAN DO THIS WE CAN ACHIEVE THIS
IT MIGHT SOUND -- AUDACIOUS BUT
THE REALITY IS THAT WERE REALLY
ON THE PRECIPICE OF ENDINGS
INCARCERATION AS WE KNOW IT IN
LOS ANGELES IN CALIFORNIA AND IF
THERE'S ONE THING THAT YOU TAKE
AWAY FROM ALL THIS I WHAT I FROM
MY REMARKS I WOULD SAY IS THAT.
THE ONLY REASON THAT WE ARE
RESTING THOUSANDS OF KIDS IN LOS
ANGELES IS BECAUSE THE RESOURCES
ARE NOT BEING INVESTED IN A
COMMUNITY BASED DIVERSION
PROGRAM THE DIVERSION PROGRAMS
EXIST.
I JUST NEED RESOURCES AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN MAKE THOSE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IN LOS ANGELES AND
THROUGH THE STATE.
LEGISLATURE SO THAT THESE KIDS
WON'T GET ARRESTED IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS TERRY GRAMMAR.
I AM THE FOUNDER OF NEW WORTH
ORGANIZATION OUT OF LOS ANGELES --
JUST SITTING IN BACK OF THE ROOM --
A LITTLE OVERWHELMING.
LISTENING TO EVERYONE.
SPEAK ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE HAVING IN OUR COMMUNITY ON
THAT WE'VE HAD YOU KNOW.
A LEGACY OF THAT OUR COMMUNITY
FOR SO MANY.
SO MANY HUNDREDS OF YEARS -- I
TRUST THAT -- IN THESE NEXT
COMING YEARS TEN YEARS WE CAN
REALLY MAKE AN IMPACT.
A REALLY STRONG IMPACT ON ENDING
YOU THINK CAR SERRATION -- IN IN
TRANSFORMING IT ALL -- I AM HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT
TRANSFORMING OUR JAILS.
INTO COLLEGES.
AND I BELIEVE IT'S TIME.
NOT AT EVERY JAIL COULD BE
TURNED INTO A COLLEGE
[inaudible]
BUT THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE IN
SOME PLACES THAT ARE RATE REALLY
BEAUTIFUL.
AND THAT'S TAXPAYERS PAY FOR
THOSE PLACES AND DOM AND I THINK --
TAKING THOSE BACK IF THEY ARE
CLOSING RIGHT NOW TAKING THOSE
BACK AND PUTTING THOSE BACK INTO
THE HANDS OF THE PEOPLE AND
TRANSFORMING THEM INTO VOLUNTARY
SCHOOLS.
IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO SO WE
CAN'T REOPEN THEM AGAIN EVER.
AND SO LAST YEAR IN COUNTIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT HOUSE
JUVENILE OF THAT HOUSE A
JUVENILE FACILITIES.
MORE THAN 90% OF THE JAIL'S WERE
LESS THAN HALF FULL.
IN FACT ONE WAS ONLY AT 16%
CAPACITY.
THE ANNUAL COST OF INCARCERATING
A YOUNG PERSON IN JUVENILE HALL
IN CALIFORNIA HAS DOUBLED OVER
THE PAST EIGHT YEARS.
WITH BUDGET WITH JUVENILE HALLS
AND KANSEN RANCHES DRASTICALLY
UNDER UTILIZED THE COST TO
INCARCERATE A YOUNG PERSON IS
STILL RISING AND CONTINUES TO
RISE.
IN SOME COUNTY -- SPENDING MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YOUNG PERSON TO BE A
CAR INCARCERATED AND A LOT OF
TIME THAT FOR STATUS OFFENSES
STATUS OFFENSES ARE -- VIOLATION
OF PROBATION.
AND WE'RE PAYING THAT AS
TAXPAYERS -- THROUGH THE WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE I'M OVER THE
PAST FIFTEEN YEARS.
IN IN DETENTION FACILITIES
PLACEMENT HOMES JUVENILE HALLS
AS WELL AS A IN OUR OWN ARTS
LEADERSHIP CENTER IN CULVER CITY
WE'VE PROVEN THAT INVESTING IN
YOUNG PEOPLE BY PROVIDING A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA PROGRAM.
JOB TRAINING PLACEMENT FULL WRAP
AROUND SERVICES ENABLES LASTING
CHANGE IN THEIR LIVES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES LIVES AND IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES -- IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WE SERVE SIXTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE ACROSS THE LIVING
CAMPS IN LA COUNTY.
CURRENTLY THAT NUMBER HAD BEEN
REDUCED THAT SHANE SAID EARLIER
TO ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE CURRENTLY THERE
IS IT'S IT'S REDUCED QUITE A BIT
SINCE THEN AND THAT'S JUST IN
EIGHT YEARS.
SO WE CAN STILL WE CAN CONTINUE
TO DO THIS -- AND SO AS A
RESPONSE AT AND AS A RESPONSE --
WE PARTNER WITH LA COUNTY AND
WE'RE TRANSFORMING OF FOUR OF OF
FORMER YOUTH CAMP RIGHT NOW INTO
A VOLUNTARY RESIDENTIAL
VOCATIONAL COLLEGE.
AND IT'S THE FIRST TIME IT'S
EVER BEEN DONE IN HISTORY.
AND THE LOCATION THAT WAS ONCE
THERE TO INCARCERATED YOUNG
PERSON IS NOW BEING REPURPOSED
INTO A COLLEGE CAMPUS.
SERVING YOUNG MAN FROM EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ON TRACK TO ADULT
KERR SERRATION OR HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE'RE DOING THIS OR
OPERATING THIS WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS -- IN IT AND
IT WILL BE FULLY FULLY OPERATED
BY COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
SO NOT ONLY WILL THIS SCHOOL
HAVE BEEN NOT ONLY WITH A SCHOOL
BE A HAVEN TO TRANSFORM LIVES --
FOR YOUNG MEN WHO DESERVE A
SECOND CHANCE.
DESERVE A THIRD CHANCE DESERVE
SOMETIMES A FOR CHANCE.
IT WILL BE IT WILL GIVE THEM A
TANGIBLE CAREER TRAINING DENTAL
CAREER TRAINING IN A GUARANTEED
JOB PLACEMENT.
IF YOU ASK AND HOW DO YOU
GUARANTEE A JOB LONG RUN AROUND
ALL OVER TOWN AND PUT TOGETHER
AN EMPLOYMENT ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
THESE ARE FOLKS THAT ARE
COMMITTED. TO WALK WITH US
THROUGH THE JOURNEY OF THIS
PROGRAM.
AND NOT ONLY WILL THEY ADVISE US
ON WHAT ARE SOME OF THE MOST UP
TO UP TO DATE SKILLS YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED THEY ALSO.
HAVE PROMISED TO BRING SOMEONE
ON OF THE PRINT IS PAID A PRINT
IS ON THE OTHER SIDE.
OF THE TRAINING ITSELF -- AND
IT'S A SIX MONTH PROGRAM.
SO -- I'M HERE TODAY TO SUGGEST
THAT WE DO NOT STOP THERE.
WHAT THE WHAT IF WE JUST
DUPLICATED THIS MODEL ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
OUR VISION FOR THE NEXT TEN
YEARS TO SEE THIS HAPPEN AT
LEAST AT THREE MORE JUVENILE
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
TAKE THE VERY PLACE.
TO TAKE THE VERY PLACES THAT
ONCE INCARCERATED YOUNG PEOPLE.
FLIP THEM LIKE PEOPLE FLIP THE
TV'S I MEAN UNDER THE HOUSE ON
TV RIGHT.
INTO THESE BEAUTIFUL LOCATIONS
THAT WILL BE REDESIGNED TO
EDUCATE YOUNG PEOPLE.
EACH FACILITY IS PROJECTED TO
PROPERTY RIGHT NOW WE BECAUSE
WE'RE WE'RE DOING THIS ART THE
FACILITY COSTS ABOUT ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR TO
OPERATE.
WITH A ONE TIME COST OF A SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER FACILITY TO
RENOVATE WHOSE EXTRAORDINARY
IMPORTANT THAT A YOUNG PERSON
DID NOT WALK INSIDE ANOTHER
PLACE THAT RE TRAUMATIZE.
SO WE'VE GOT IT CAN'T GONZALEZ
OUT WE'VE GOT IT -- DO YOU WON'T
EVEN SEE ANY CINDER BLOCK ON ANY
OF THE WALLS WHEN WHEN WE'RE
DONE WITH THAT.
AND YOU'LL FEEL LIKE THOSE SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR A MONTH YOU KNOW
RETREAT SENATE CENTER FOLKS
AVAILABLE GO TO YOU KNOW EVERY
EVERY IF WE WANT TO FEEL LIKE --
A PLACE OF HEALING UPPING
BROTHER JERRY TAIL SAID EARLIER
YOU KNOW WE NEED WE NEED TO BE
WE NEED HEALING INSTITUTIONS.
AND LIKE I SAID EARLIER NOT
EVERY PLACE CAN BE TRANSFORMED
IN A WAY IT'S NOT FOR EVERY
LOCATION.
BUT CALIFORNIA'S GOT SOME
BEAUTIFUL YOUTH PRISON I MEAN
THEM TO THEM THANK YOU FOR THE
BEAUTIFUL PLACES.
AND PEOPLE ASK ME ALL THE TIME
WILL YOU KNOW WHY NOT DO THE
COMMUNITY WE NEED TO BE DOING
THIS IN THE COMMUNITY.
TO OF THIS WITHOUT TAKING AWAY
ANYTHING ANY TO BE DONE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
IT IT'S IT'S IT'S JUST LIKE A
FOOT SOLDIER WAS ON THE
BATTLEFIELD BECAUSE OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS A LIKE
BATTLEFIELDS.
OVER POLICED WE GOT WAR ZONES
AND THEY GO DOWN ON THE
BATTLEFIELD YOU DON'T DO
OPERATION ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
YOU TAKE THEM OFF THE
BATTLEFIELD SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY
CAN HEAL SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY
CAN BE REHYDRATED SOMEWHERE
WHERE THEY CAN REST.
LOT OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
TIGHT SIXTEEN YEARS OLD LOOKING
SOMETIMES LOOKING LIKE AN OLDER
THE OLDER THAN ME OKAY.
AND I'VE GOT A LOT OF GRAY AND
SO THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S THE
NEED TO ALLOW OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO REJUVENATE.
FROM THIS LEGACY OF OF OF
PAINTING FROM OF THAT WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED I WISH I HAD WHEN I
WAS SIXTEEN I SPENT FIVE YEARS
ON JUVENILE PROBATION -- AND IN
WITH THE TEENAGE FATHER I DON'T
HAVE ANY WOULD TURN TO SERVE MY
WORK TODAY IT'S ALL ABOUT GIVING
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE EXACTLY WHAT
I WISH I HAD AT THAT TIME IN MY
LIFE.
AND SO -- SO WE PROPOSED.
TO RUN THREE CONSECUTIVE.
BUT THREE YOUR PILOTS OVER THE
COURSE OF A TWELVE YEAR PERIOD
EACH SIDE HAS. ONE YEAR PLANNING
PERIOD BUILT IN.
AND THEN OUR GOAL IS TO ONCE
THAT PILOT IS COMPLETE EACH
FACILITY HAS A FULLY SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING MODEL THAT WILL ENSURE
ITS SUCCESS FOR MANY YEARS TO
COME.
SO THAT THIS EQUATES TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT TWELVE
YEARS TO TRANSFORM THIS.
SO -- SO WE'RE ALREADY DOING
THIS WE ALREADY WERE ALREADY
WORKING ON A PROOF OF CONCEPT A
MODEL IN LOS ANGELES.
THIS COULD BE REPLICATED AS WE
HAVE BEEN REPURPOSE IN CAN'T
GONZALEZ IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LA
COUNTY OVER ALMOST THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
WELL WE ARE ALSO CURRENTLY SIX
MONTHS AWAY FROM A FULL REMODEL.
AND GRAND OPENING OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CAREER INSTITUTE
WHICH IS.
CALLED THE FORMER CABINET SALAS.
AND WITH APPROPRIATE FUNDING WE
CAN FORM PARTNER CHAPTERS WE CAN
THAT COMPRISE OF STRONG
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE.
IN THIS WAY WE CAN BENEFIT IN
EMPOWER ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL LEADERS.
WE WILL IDENTIFY THREE SITES
PRIORITIZE.
DO WITHOUT DETECTION CENTERS
KANSEN RANCHES WITH UNDER 50%
CAPACITY AND IN THOSE COUNTIES.
IN IN THOSE COUNTY THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR DIFFERENT WAY IN
SOME INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS.
WITH THIS MODEL WE STABILIZE AND
REBUILD OUR COMMUNITIES ADDING
HIGHLY SKILLED TRADESPEOPLE AND
PROFESSIONALS TO THE WORK FORCE
OF THEIR TOWNS IN THERE BY.
A MORE ECONOMIC STABILITY ACROSS
THE STATE UTILIZING EMPTY
BUILDINGS THAT NO LONGER SERVE A
PURPOSE -- SO A HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS JUST A
FRACTION OF THE COST.
OF BECAUSE RIGHT NOW YOUNG
PERSON IS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YOUNG PERSON OVER
TEN YEAR PERIOD THAT'S FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT ONE
YOUNG PERSON. FOR ONE CHILD.
SO WHILE CAN CALIFORNIA'S
COUNTIES HAVE TAPPED INTO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN STATE GRANTS TO BUILD AND
EXPAND YOU IN A LOT DEL
FACILITIES OVER THE PAST DECADE.
THERE'S BEEN THERE'S BEEN NO
SUCH FUNDING ALLOCATED TO
CONVERT JAILS AND TO CENTERS TO
UPLIFT EDUCATE.
THROB PROPOSED THAT THERE'S A
BETTER WAY AND IN EDUCATION AND
RADICAL INNOVATION OVER
INCARCERATION.
IN IN IN IN SO DOING SO CREATING
AN ECO SYSTEM INSIDE OF THIS
PLACE SO.
WE ENVISION THAT THE CONTROL THE
THE THE THE TRAITS CAUGHT THE
TRADE COURSE ISN'T IN PATHWAYS
THE MENTORS AND TEACHERS BE
PEOPLE FROM LIVED EXPERIENCES.
AND IT'S AFFECTED PEOPLE
AFFECTING PEOPLE TO AFFECT
CHANGE A CALL.
IN IN IN AND IN THE END OF THOSE
THAT GO ON TO GRADUATE.
FROM THE CONSTRUCTION COURSES
GOING TO BUILD THE NEXT ONE SO
THERE'S AUTOMATIC.
HALFWAY INTO WORK.
AND IF IN IN THAT'S BEEN THAT'S
BEEN THE ISSUE OF OF GETTING
THEM INTO SOME OF THESE JOBS IN
LOS ANGELES WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE NOT THEY DON'T HAVE A PROPER
PATHWAY INTO.
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND OTHER
PATHWAYS THIS GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD AN
ECOSYSTEM IN WHICH THEY HAVE
AUTOMATIC JOB TO CONTINUE TO DO
THIS THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- SO.
WITH THAT SAID -- JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMMITMENT. TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND A A LOOK
FOR TO WHAT WE DO IN THESE NEXT
TEN YEARS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I LIKE YOUR
IDEA ABOUT THE EMPLOYMENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE IN.
PRACTICE SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
TAKE A LOOK AT BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR -- ADVISORY GROUP
AND AND YOU KNOW TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER LOOKING AT SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PROMINENT.
CORPORATE INDUSTRIES -- TO PLAY
A ROLE RIGHT WOULD BE THE TECH
INDUSTRY OR OR WHAT THAT WOULD
HAVE THAT RIGHT SO THANK YOU FOR
A STIMULATING THAT THAT THAT
THOUGHT AND THAT.
TENSION IDEA TO PURSUE A WOMAN
WANT TO THE NEXT SAYS SPEAKER --
THAT IS ANTHONY ROLL THIS WITH
THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION
[inaudible]
SORRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THEM AT THE WORLD IS THAT
THE JUSTICE COALITION AND HOME
BUT FOUND THIS CALIFORNIA.
AND I WISH I WAS SPEAKING TO A
MORE HOSTILE CROWD HOME BECAUSE
I WANT TO SAY THAN PAYING.
THAT -- I THINK -- PEOPLE IN
THIS BUILDING THAT ON IN THIS
ROOM NEEDS TO HEAR -- BUT AS ONE
OF THE START OFF ON WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE VISION IN THE
NEXT TEN YEARS FOR BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR -- AND IN CALIFORNIA
AND BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO GO
BACK AND TALK ABOUT THE HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF
CALIFORNIA'S WAR -- AGAINST BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR IN PEOPLE COLOR
IN GENERAL -- AND I THINK THAT
THE START WITH THE VERY BUILDING
THAT WE'RE IN -- WE'RE COMING
INTO THE ENTRANCE ON THE EAST
SIDE OF THE BUILDING -- I
NOTICED THERE WAS LIKE A OF A
ENGRAVED ON THE WALL OF THIS
BUILDING THERE'S LIKE A MURAL
AND THERE IS LITTLE PANELS AN
EXTENSIBLE PANEL THAT LIKE
SCENES FROM CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY
AND ONE OF THOSE SCENES THERE
THE LOOKS LIKE A YOUNG NATIVE
PERSON.
BUILDING -- OF LIKE WELL LOOKS
LIKE WALLING BRICKS TO A WALL IN
FRONT OF A MISSION WHILE THE
CATHOLIC PRIEST WATCHES OVER HIM
AND THEN ANOTHER PANEL THERE'S A
CATHOLIC PRIEST WELL A NATIVE.
YEAH THE SECOND YOUNG NATIVE
PERSON ON ON THEIR KNEES LIKE AN
OMINOUS OBJECTIVE POSITION WHILE.
A PRIEST OF GIVING HIM A
BRANCHES SOMEDAY AND IT LOOKS
LIKE OF THE OBVIOUSLY IT'S A
POSITION OF DOMINANCE AND
SUPERIORITY OVER THAT.
AND THAT PERFECTLY EXPLAINS
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY -- THEN ON
UNDER HERE YOU HAVE RONALD
REAGAN STATUE AND HAVE COLUMBUS
IS THAT YOU AND FRANKLY I THINK
THIS WHOLE BUILDING NEED TO
REACH A MAKE OVER I THINK ANY TO
BE TORN DOWN.
ON EVERY BILL INTO SOMETHING
THAT THAT THAT REALLY --
CAPTIVATES OUR PEOPLE'S HISTORY --
IN OUR VALIANT AND WHEN WHAT
WHAT ARE WHAT OUR FUTURE IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE IN CALIFORNIA --
SO WHEN PEOPLE ASK ABOUT
AMERICA'S INSATIABLE THIRST FOR
WAR IT WAS PERFECT IT HERE AT
HOME AGAINST NATIVE PEOPLE BLACK
PEOPLE PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
GENERAL -- CHINESE PEOPLE
EVERYBODY THAT WAS IN WHITE ON
THE WAR MACHINE WAS PERFECTED
HERE AND TAKEN OVERSEAS AFTER --
AND JUST QUICKLY ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY ARMED AS
SOON AS CALIFORNIA BECAME A STAY
IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE OF THE
FIRST LAW THAT PASSED WAS AN ACT
FOR THE GOVERNMENT PROTECTION OF
INDIANS -- AND AN EIGHTEEN FIFTY
AND THAT ALLOWED THE GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE NATIVE YOU PUT HIM IN
BOARDING SCHOOLS -- IT ALLOWED
FOR THE EXTERMINATION IN THIS
POSITION OF NATIVE PEOPLE THAN
THERE WAS ON THE FOREIGN MINERS
TAX OF EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE OF THE
FIRST LAWS PASSED WHICH BEGAN
THE WAR AND IMMIGRANTS HERE.
WHICH DIDN'T ALLOW ANY
FOREIGNERS INTO THE GOLD RUSH
INTO THE MINING INDUSTRY SO.
EVEN MEXICANS WERE CITIZENS OF
OF CALIFORNIA AND UNDER THE
AMERICAN RULE WHERE YOU'VE BEEN --
pAND WE WERE ECONOMICALLY SHUT
OUT PEOPLE COLOR CHINESE PEOPLE --
WERE WERE CUT OUT OF THIS
INDUSTRY AND ECONOMICALLY -- I
GUESS CASTRATED FROM FROM FROM
THE GOLD RUSH AND ALL THE RICHES
THAT WILL COME FROM IT THEN
THERE WAS THE GREASER ACT OF
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FIVE WHICH AGREE
THROUGH THE DOG FOR A TIME TO
DESCRIBE MEXICANS -- IT WAS THAT
DEBATE WITH THE VACANCY ACT
WHICH CRIMINALIZED AND
INCARCERATED NATIVE PEOPLE
MEXICAN PEOPLE BUT IT'S IN A
COMPACT LABOR -- AND THIS WAS
ESPECIALLY TRUE AN ALLEY COUNTY
WITH THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
AND THE AND THE LA COUNTY JAIL
THERE.
WHICH CREATED A ON PRETTY MUCH A
A STATE SYSTEM TO CONVICT LABOR --
SO THAT'S THE HISTORY OF OF THE
SHORT BRIEF HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA THE ORIGINS AND THEN
YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE SAND
EIGHTEEN SIXTIES CALIFORNIA WITH
THE CONFEDERATE STRONGHOLD I
MEAN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH
THE CONFEDERATE STRONGHOLD OF
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY CREATED.
AN ARM OF THE CONFEDERATE
MELISSA CALLED ALI MOUNTED
RIFLES INVOLVED IN THAT MONTH
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT -- TO
INSTALL A PRO CONFEDERATE PRO
SLAVERY GOVERNMENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN AT THAT TIME
WE HAD THE HIGHEST MENTION RATES
IN IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
ARMED THE USE OF FORCE STANDARD
FOR POLICE WAS ESTABLISHED
DURING THAT TIME IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO ALL RIGHT AFTER THE
CIVIL WAR.
SO NOW WE PASSED FORDED TODAY
WE'RE BARELY ADDRESSING THE FACT.
THAT WE HAVE THE OLDEST AND MOST
PERMISSIVE USE THE FOUR STANDARD
IN THE COUNTRY AND WE WONDER WHY
WE HAVE THE SOME OF THE HIGHEST
RATES IN THE HIGHEST TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE DYING.
pARM.
SO I WANT TO JUST HONOR THOSE
WHO REBELLED SINCE THE VERY
BEGINNING ON GOING ALL THE WAY
BACK TO SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
WITH THE SAN GABRIEL REBELLION
WHICH WAS ON LED IN PART BY ON
BY PUTTING A WHO IS -- A NATIVE
WOMAN WHO -- LETTER A VALIANT
AGAINST THE THE THANK ABLE
MISSION IN THE CATHOLICS THERE
IN THE SPANIARDS THERE ON ALL
THE WAY UP FOR TO THE WHAT FOR
BOUND IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
SOUTH CENTRAL UPRISING IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND ALL THE
OTHER BALANCE THAT CAN NAME.
THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE GOTTEN US TO THIS
POINT BECAUSE EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS.
IS IS A REBEL AND EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM HAS A HAS A HAS IS A
SURVIVOR OF CALIFORNIA'S IN
AMERICA'S WAR ON US ON A PEOPLE.
AND THE FACT THAT WE'RE STILL
HERE AND NOW WE'RE IN THIS
BUILDING SAYING THIS TROOP IS A
TESTAMENT TO ALL THE WORK THAT
ANSWER THROUGH THE PUT IN AND
NOW WE'RE PUTTING IN RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
HOME.
YEAH ME OF MY ME AND MY FAMILY
ARE SURVIVORS.
OF MY DAD WAS DEPORTED THREE
TIMES OUT HERE AND NOT LIKE HE
WAS CAUGHT AT THE BORDER AND
DEPORTED A TO POINT.
HE WAS THIRTY ONE YEARS OLD
DON'T EVEN KNOW HE WAS THE
PORTABLE AND HE WAS THE MAIN
BREADWINNER FAMILY WITHOUT THE
BEEN DEPORTED.
AND THEN AFTER THAT WE ENDED UP
HOMELESS MY BROTHER GOT LOCKED
UP I WAS ARRESTED AT AT THE AGE
OF TWELVE FOR THE FIRST TIME I
WOULD GET LOCKED UP EVENTUALLY --
EVERY BIT ME MY BROTHER MY DAD
ONLY THREE MEN AND ARE IN MY IN
MY NUCLEAR FAMILY HAVE ALL BEEN
LOCKED UP AND BEEN IN THE SYSTEM --
SINCE WE WERE CHILDREN SINCE WE
WERE KIDS -- AND YOU KNOW WE
WERE HOMELESS MY MOM WAS A
SINGLE MOTHER US -- SAMMY
EARLIER SAID THAT MOTHERS HAVE
BEEN OUR GREATEST ALLIES THEY'VE
BEEN OUR BETTER HAVE BEEN THE
ONES THAT HAVE BEEN HOLDING UP
OUR COMMUNITIES WELL WE'VE BEEN --
DESTROYED BY THE SYSTEM AND
DESTROYING OURSELVES -- SO LOT
OF LOVE TO THE WOMEN IN OUR
COMMUNITY -- SO.
WITH THAT I JUST WANTED TO NOW
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE DIVISION.
FOR FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS I
GUESS -- AND AND JUSTIN KAPLAN
ALL THE WORK THAT GOD IS HERE
AND WHAT WE WANT TO SEE FOR THE
FUTURE -- AND FIRST AND FOREMOST
IF YOU WANT TO SHUT DOWN ALL YOU
PRESENT.
ON THOSE FOUR LEFT IN DJJ WOULD
LIKE TO SHUT THOSE DOWN
SOMETHING LIKE WITH NEW NEW WORK
IS DOING ON TEN THOSE AN
EDUCATIONAL CENTERS WE CAN BE
DOING THAT -- AWAY WE COULD BE
DOING THAT IN THE COMMUNITY --
JUST BE MORE OF IT AND ALL OVER
THE PLACE -- ME TO SHIP THAT
MONEY THAT'S BEING INVESTED THAT
BEEN INVESTED INTO THE LARGEST
PRISON SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY --
IN THE WORLD AND SHIP THAT IN SO
YOU DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT ALL
MONEY THAT YOU'RE INVESTMENT
FUND I'M ANY FUNDS THAT ARE
MEANT FOR YOU FOR YOU FOR YOUTH
YOUTH OF COLOR.
SHOULDN'T BE GOING TO BE S. T.
C. IT SHOULD BE GOING TO READ
pDEPARTMENT BECAUSE IN.
AN ALLEY -- COUNTY.
HOME.
WE FOUND THAT PROBATION BEEN
TAKING ALL THE JJ CPA FUNDS TO
DO THESE SCHOOL PROBATION
PROGRAMS AND WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT IT AND SO WE DID A AUDIT.
AND ONCE WE FOUND OUT ABOUT IT
WE START ORGANIZING AND WE GOT
ON TO THE JGTC THE LOCAL COUNCIL
TO START TRYING TO SHIP BOTH
FUND THE WAY WE ENDED VOLUNTARY
PROBATION AND NOW THEY COUNTY --
WORKING WITH MR GIPSON AYE A. B.
NINE A ONE TO INVOLUNTARY
PROBATION ACROSS THE STATE --
BUT BOTH FUNDS ABOUT TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS BEING USED FROM
STATE FUNDS THAT'S FOR US FOR
PREVENTION WOULD BEING USED FOR
BOMB VOLUNTARY PROBATION IS
SCHOOLS AN ALLEY COUNTY AND SO
NOW.
WE'VE WE'RE WE'RE ON THE J. J.
GOT PEOPLE ON A DAY TO SEE SEE
AND WE'RE RE DIRECTING THAT
MONEY INTO YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND
SO THAT MONEY EVENTUALLY WILL NO
LONGER BE USED FOR ANY TYPE OF
SCHOOL PROBATION PROGRAMS
ANYMORE -- BECAUSE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN SPEAKING ABOUT
FUNDING SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
ON PROBATION THE BUDGET HAS
DOUBLED.
ON BY ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO GET OVER BILLION
DOLLARS AN ALLEY COUNTY ALLEY
PT'S BUDGET IS INCREASED BY
ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS OR
AROUND THERE AND THE CHAIRS
BUDGET HAS INCREASED ON THE SAME
AMOUNT.
OF THAT WAS DURING THE TIME WHEN
THERE'S A GREAT RECESSION WHEN
SERVICES ARE BEING CUT A LEFT
AND AND A TIME WHEN CRIME WAIT
FOR STARTING TO TO SLOW DOWN FOR
THE RIGHT NOW AT HISTORIC LOWS
ANOTHER COUNTY.
BUT SOMEHOW THEIR THEIR BUDGETS
HAVE BALLOONED AND DAVE
TRANSFORM THEMSELVES INTO LIKE
PROBATION FOR EXAMPLE
INVOLUNTARY PROBATION JUST TO
KEEP THE BUDGET TO GROW THE
BUDGET TO KEEP THIS THAT -- WHEN
WE DON'T NEED THAT AND OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE NOT YOUTH WORKERS THE
NOT ON SOCIAL WORKERS WERE YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED IN SCHOOL OF OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE COMING
BACK AND GIVING BACK AND DON'T
HAVE A PUNITIVE MINDS THAT -- SO
WE'RE TRYING TO RE APPROPRIATE
ALTHOUGH FUNDS INTO YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT LOCALLY
AND AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL AND
HOME WITH THE YOUTH COUNCIL AND
EVERYTHING THAT THAT CAN RUN IT
RUN THE SHOW AND AND BE IN
CONTROL FOR THESE FUNDS ARE
GOING AND HOW THEY MEAN
ALLOCATED -- SECOND WE WOULD
LIKE TO RE WRITE THE WET COLD
ARM AND DECRIMINALIZE STATUS
OFFENSES LIKE TRUANCY AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. TO THOSE THE THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE
COMPUTER SYSTEM OUR WAY TO INTER
MARRIED I'M IT'S FAR TOO EASY TO
BE KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL AND SLIP
INTO THE SYSTEM.
ON A ONE OF THOSE REASONS
BECAUSE SO MANY THINGS TO
CRIMINALIZE THE ARM AND THINGS
IN THE WORK WANT TO RE WRITE THE
ENTIRE RECORDING JUST TO COME
ALIVE THINGS FIND ALTERNATIVE
METHODS OF DEALING WITH THE
YOUTH ISSUES -- BECAUSE THE
SYSTEM THAT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
THEM IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM EXACERBATE TRAUMAS AND
ARE IN OUR ISSUES.
ARM AND THEY JUST THEY JUST IT'S
LIKE A NEVER ENDING CYCLE --
FLEET MUST BE SEPARATE AND
CREATE A YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
SYSTEM -- WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
INCLUDE THE DEFINITION OF YOUTH
UP TO THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE AT
HOME IN ACCORDANCE WITH SCIENCE.
ON LIKE THE END AL WHAT LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE FOR EVERYBODY.
AND THEN WE WANT TO END THE WAR
ON GANGS AND GANG ENHANCEMENTS
AND AND GETTING DATABASES AND
GANG INJUNCTIONS AND GETTING
REGISTRATIONS.
CUT OFF ALL FED ACCESS TO GAIN
DATABASES THAT EVEN THOUGH WE
CUT OFF ACCESS IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT -- WE COULDN'T
CAUGHT THAT AXIS SO.
I CAN STILL GET THERE.
GET PEOPLE THE INFORMATION TO
THE A TF EFFORT TO THE DHS IT'S
HOME IT HEALTH AGENCY -- SO WE'D
LIKE TO CUT OFF ALL BUT ACCESS --
TO TO TO AVOID THAT AND AND AND
AND INCRIMINATION AND STOP THE
CREATION OF NEW DATA BASES THAT
ARE INFORMED BY THIS GANG
DATABASE LIKE IN LA WE HAVE.
ON THE CHRONIC OFFENDER BULLETS
AND ANOTHER GONNA AND PREDICTIVE
POLICING BUT MOVE ON TO THE
PRECISION POLICING WHICH TO
DOING IN NEW YORK WHICH IS LIKE.
LIKE TARGETED FOR GANGS BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT IN NEW YORK
WITH THE BRONX EIGHTY SOMETHING
THEY ARRESTED LIKE.
ALMOST A HUNDRED PEOPLE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT -- OF A ON A
RICO CASE AND MOST OF THEM
WEREN'T EVEN IN A GANG OR
NOTHING LIKE THAT SO THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO BRING NOW THEY
ARE THAT'S WHAT I HEARD AS I
READ ABOUT -- AND ALSO WE'D LIKE --
TO LIKE TO END THE ONE GAME
WHICH IS THE ONE PEOPLE COLOR
AND ALSO ON AVOID CAPITALISTIC
SOLUTIONS ON OF SUCH AS LIKE THE
FIRST STEP BACKWARD THE GEO
GROUP.
IS GONNA GET HUGE OPPORTUNITIES
BIGGER OPPORTUNITIES TO RUN ON
REENTRY AN ELECTRONIC MONITORING
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE.
GOING TO BE COMING OUT OF PRISON
BUT AGAIN GOT ELECTRONIC
MONITORING I'M GOING TO RE ENTRY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE RUN BY PRIVATE
CORPORATIONS LIKE GEO AND WE ALL
KNOW THE COLE BROTHERS AND ALL
THAT WERE BEHIND FIRST STEP BACK
IN.
IN LOVE WITH IT -- ALSO --
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE THAT
INCLUDES UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE
EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
TO HEALTH CARE YOUNG PEOPLE
PEOPLE WITHOUT -- DOCUMENTS
SHOULD ALL HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE.
AND THEN DO A SURVEY OF THE
UNUSED AND MISMANAGED PUBLIC
SPACE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE CAN TRANSFORM INTO YOUTH
CENTERS EDUCATIONAL CENTERS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THINGS LIKE
THAT LIKE AND NOW THEY WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH.
NEW WORDS AND ON CAMPUS ALL IS
AND THEN WHAT WE DID IT ON WE
TOOK OVER ON THE DAVID CAN YOU
DO NOW COURTHOUSE FORMER
JUVENILE COURT HAS THAT THAT HAD.
HOLDING TANKS IN THAT WE TURN IT
INTO A SCHOOL FINANCIAL
COMMUNITY CENTER A YOUTH CENTER.
ON WE CAN DO THAT ALL OVER THE
STATE HOME BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MUCH PUBLIC SPACE THAT EITHER
BEING MIS MANAGER THAN BEING
USED AT ALL IT CAN BE USED FOR A
LOT OF GOOD THINGS -- AND YEAH I
THINK THAT'S SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ENVISIONED FOR THE NEXT
TEN YEARS ON THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK.
AND I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
THAT SPOKE BEFORE ME AND
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM THAT IS
HELP THIS GET TO THIS POINT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR DROPPING SOME GOOD
HISTORICAL KNOWLEDGE.
ON ALL OF US.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
ABBAS A THE ONE SALAS WITH THE
CáC SPEND ANY PROGRAMS THAT
COULD HAVE A LEADER BY SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT THAT WELL
VERSED IN HISTORY SO.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF
CNN AND THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE.
AND OF COURSE ALL MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES IN THE YOUTH THAT ARE
HERE TODAY SO I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK.
YOU HERE TODAY WHO TAKEN THE
TIME TO HOLD SPACE FOR ALL THOSE
WHO WE SERVE AND WE REPRESENT.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THE PROPERTY SEVEN FOR
VALUE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
ADVOCATES IN PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND A PATH FOR OUR
YOUTH AND ADULTS TO EAL. FOR
THE NEXT SEVEN GENERATIONS.
I CURRENTLY OVERSEE THE PROP
FORTY SEVEN LCS IS P. GRANT FOR
COACHELLA VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS WELL AS THE EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS.
THE OFFICE OF CHILD WELFARE IN
ATTENDANCE AS AN ACTIVE PARTNER
IN THE WORK THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DOING.
HER PARTNERS IN THE JOURNEY WITH
THE GRANT ARE THE NATIONAL
COMBAT IS NETWORK AND NATIONALLY
KNOWN AND WELL RECOGNIZED
ORGANIZATION THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES.
THROUGH OUR PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE
INTRODUCED THE FOUR CORE
PRINCIPLES THAT ARE THE
FOUNDATION OF THE WORK OF THE
COMBAT IS NETWORK.
THOSE FOUR PRINCIPLES THAT
PROMOTE CULTURALLY BASED
TEACHINGS AND TRANSFORMATIONAL
LEARNING ARE.
EVERYONE SHOULD FEEL WANTED
WELCOME AND IS A BLESSING.
ALL LIFE HAS A POSITIVE PURPOSE
ALL HAVE CULTURALLY BASED
TEACHINGS TO GUIDE US.
ALL SHOULD HAVE SAVE
COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE AROUND THEM
AND SECURE PLACESTO LEARN AND
HE'LL AND TO DEMONSTRATE LOVE.
THESE VALUES HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED TO OUR STUDENTS
ADMINISTRATION TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT STAFF.
THIS IS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED
THROUGH THE PROGRAM SUCH AS LIKE
WILL DIRECT VOTER.
WHICH EMPLOYS MULTI GENERATIONAL
PROCESS OF LEARNING AND
REMEMBERING ONCE TRUE ON
POSITIVE CULTURE VALLEY'S
PRINCIPLES CUSTOMS AND
TRADITIONS.
THIS INCLUDES PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT AND HEALING AND
TRAUMA INFORMED CULTURALLY BASED
PRACTICES.
THIS WILL HELP US IN CREATING A
POSITIVE INEQUITABLE SCHOOL
CLIMATE.
ALSO PROVIDED OUR TRAININGS IN
THE RIGHT TO PASSAGE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS A HOLDEN OVERLAY AND
CHEN NATURALLY.
THEIR CHARACTER DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS FOR YOUTH BASED ON
INDIGENOUS TEACHINGS.
THOSE TEACHINGS INCLUDE YOUTH
LEADERSHIP AND DEVELOPMENT OF
IDENTITY.
IT ALSO ADDRESSES PHYSICAL ABUSE
SUBSTANCE USE GANG VIOLENCE
ACADEMIC CHALLENGES AND PROMOTES
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE ALSO BEEN
INTEGRATED INTO OUR EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS.
OTHER TRAININGS -- AS WELL THAT
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDED FOR STAFF
OUR CIRCLE KEEPERS AND SELF CARE.
SO THIS LEADS ME INTO OUR VISION
FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO.
FUNDING WILL BE KEY TO CONTINUE
THIS WORK WHICH WILL HELP
TRANSFORM THE PAIN.
AND THEN JUSTICE CENTER
COMMUNITY SOME OF THE ISSUES WE
FACE ARE INCREASED PROBLEM.
SUICIDE BORDER ISSUES FEAR
SUBSTANCE USE VIOLENCE SEX
TRAFFICKING LACK OF ACCESS TO
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND OTHER LIMITED RESOURCES JUST
TO NAME A FEW.
THE CURRENT DATA FROM OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS WELL AS THE DATA
COLLECTED BY A DOCTORATE EVENT
THIS GOT ME AT AND TANYA READ A
FROM THE COMBINED IS NETWORK.
SO THAT THE MIND SET OF TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATION IS SHIFTING
FROM A PUNITIVE AND BIAS MIND
SET TO ONE OF UNDERSTANDING THE
CORE INDIGENOUS PRINCIPLES.
THAT HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED AND
HOW IT APPLIES ON A DAILY BASIS.
MY FOLLOWING STATISTICS SHOW
THAT WE ARE PROGRESSING IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH OUR CURRENT
PARTNER.
WE HAD ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE SUSPENSIONS IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
COMPARED 210-004-0030 SEVEN AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE AND THIS PAST SCHOOL YEAR.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO THERE'S
DEFINITELY A DECREASE THERE ARE
EXPULSIONS WERE SEVENTEEN AND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN ELEVEN AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND SEVEN IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ALSO PROGRESS.
OUR OUR CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM ALSO
HAS -- DECREASED WE STILL HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO THERE AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT WORKING ON OUR
SCHOOL CLIMB IT WILL DEFINITELY
HELP US AND IN THAT AREA.
SO WE NEED TO FUND OUR SCHOOLS --
DIRECTLY TO CONTINUE OUR
CAPACITY BUILDING WITH
ADMINISTRATORS COUNSELORS.
TEACHERS SUPPORT STAFF STUDENTS
AND PARENTS AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WE NEED TO PROVIDE
SYSTEMS THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
PERSONAL WELL BEING.
AS WELL AS OUR OPPORTUNITIES FOR
AN EQUITABLE PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND BEYOND.
THE JOURNEY HAS JUST BEGUN AND I
DO RECOMMEND ALLOCATING FUNDING
FOR A TEN YEAR EFFORT TO CHANGE
THE CURRENT NARRATIVE.
FUNDING SCHOOLS DIRECTLY WOULD
INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO CONTINUE THIS WORK.
AND ADDRESS THE NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SUBSTANCE USE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR PARENTS
AND STUDENTS.
CV UST ALSO PLANS AND
INTEGRATING THIS WORK -- INTO
HEAD START IN ORDER TO BUILD A
PATH OF CONTINUITY THROUGHOUT
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE YOU
WITH THAT THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
OUR CHILDREN OUR FUTURE WARRIORS.
AND ALL THOSE WHO CONTINUE TO
SEEK SPACE TO HEAL AND GROW.
AS ARE MY AND ANCESTORS BELIEVED
WE WERE ALL CONNECTED.
AND LIKE GETS YOU ARE MY OTHER
ME.
WHEN YOU HEARD?
WE ALL HEARD.
WHEN YOU STRUGGLE?
WE ALL STRUGGLE.
BUT WHEN YOU HEAL WE ALL HEAL.
WHEN YOU GROW WE ALL GROW?
WHEN YOU LEARN?
WE ALL LEARN.
WHEN YOU SUCCEED WE ALL SUCCEED?
YOU ARE ME.
I AM YOU AND WE ARE.
ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TO ALL THE
PANELISTS AND OPEN IT UP FOR
SOME QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SOME MEMBER GIPSON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR ONE APOLOGIZE I'VE
BEEN RUNNING IN AND OUT -- BUT I
BEGIN DEMONSTRATES MY COMMITMENT --
TO BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR BECAUSE
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND I WANT TO SAY FOR THOSE WHO
TESTIFIED -- WHILE I WAS HERE I
THINK YOU ARTICULATED YOUR
MESSAGE YOUR COAT YOUR PASSION --
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
THIS COMMITTEE TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES -- SYSTEMIC
ISSUES THAT AS HIS BROTHER'S
DEMONSTRATE IT HAS BEEN ROUTED
IN VERY FABRIC OF CALIFORNIA NOT
THINK AT THE TIME THAT A
PARADIGM SHIFT TAKES PLACE NOT
THINK IT BEGINS RIGHT HERE
BEGINS WITH EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU.
WHO MADE A COMMITMENT TO WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE THE CHANGE --
THE CULTURE IN CALIFORNIA NOW
WHEN A PLOT EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO WORK
WITH COMMITTEE -- I STAND
WILLING READY AND ABLE TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED TO DO TO
DO THE HEAVY LIFTING TO MAKE --
THESE KINDS OF CHANGES IN
CALIFORNIA SO GET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IS A MEMBER.
THIS CALL.
BUT HE WAS SURE ARE ALSO WANNA
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR THE INPUT
AND ADDS A COUPLE THOUGHTS --
ONE MISTER HEWITT WAS SAYING I
THINK THAT IN DIFFERENT WAYS YOU
ALL -- KIND OF THE SAME THING WE
HAVE TO WORK WITH YOUNGER AND
YOUNGER YOUTH AND AND WORK
UPSTREAM.
EVEN THOUGH IT WOULD BABIES AND
AND LEAD YOUNG.
A YOUNG CHILDREN I MEAN WE DO
HAVE THIS EMPHASIS WITH ORG
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WHAT
HAVE YOU AND AGAIN.
UP WITH A LOT OF MONEY BEING
THAT'S GONNA BE INVESTED IS NOT
JUST ABOUT THE MONEY IS HOW THE
MONEY IS BEING USED -- AND SO
I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT AT LEAST
ONE A PLACE WERE WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT -- ABOUT BABIES ABOUT YOUR
NEW PARENTS ABOUT A YOUNGSTERS
BEFORE THEY EVER ENTER SCHOOL
BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY WHERE YOU
HAVE TO START AND SO THAT'S ONE
THING TO KEEP IN MIND AS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE THIS INVESTMENT IN
THOSE A GREAT POINT THAT WAS
MADE -- AND IN TERMS OF A ROOM
YEAH MR GRAMM OF THE WORKING
DOING I THINK THAT IT'S AN WAS
TRANSFORMATIONAL BUT IS ALSO
TAKES A VERY NEW WAY OF THINKING
RIGHT AND AS TO THE CHAIRS POINT
IN TERMS OF THE TECH INDUSTRY IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES.
I THINK ONE THING TO IF YOU'RE
NOT ALREADY YOU MAY ALREADY BE
DOING THIS -- THIS LOOK AT THE
BOOT CAMPS THIS THE CODING --
WILL BOOT CAMPS THAT LAST YEAR
FOR THREE TO SIX MONTHS -- AND
CAN GET YOU A SIX DIGIT JOB WHEN
YOU'RE DONE WITH THEM AND I
THINK THAT ESPECIALLY IF YOU
PARTNER WITH SOME OF THESE --
BUT THE COMPANY IS -- THAT YOU
COULD YOU DO THE INTEL APPROVED
APPROVED -- CODING BOOT CAMPS
WHAT HAVE YOU AND I'VE SEEN NO
PEOPLE IS TALKING ABOUT HIS
HOUSE THAT I'VE GONE TO THOSE
THAT WHICH TOTALLY CHANGED
CAREERS.
AN OUR OUR OUR IN LUCRATIVE
CAREERS IN THE TECH INDUSTRY BUT
THE THE WAY YOU'RE SETTING IT UP
IT SEEMS KIND OF A NICE MATCH --
TO HAVE THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
SOME OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT --
THE MADE REFERENCE TO BUT I
THINK IT'S GREAT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING -- HAVING SPENT A LOT OF
TIME IN -- IN JAILS AND IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY I THINK CERTAINLY --
TRANSFORMING THEM INTO SOMETHING
POSITIVE AND HEALING BECAUSE YOU
TO IMPRISON A REALLY TWO THINGS
I SHOULDN'T BE.
TOGETHER -- AND SO -- I I THINK
THAT ALL OF YOU SPOKE TO THE TO
THAT OF HOW WE MEMBER AND THAT
CONSTRUCT -- AND AS MS ROBBINS
WAS TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW KIND
OF HOW.
NUMBER BARELY ADDRESSING -- TALK
ABOUT USE OF FORCE IN AFTER A
HUNDRED YEARS WHICH IT WAS A LOT
OF THINGS OUR BELLIES ORINDA
DRESSED HOUSE A STATE -- AND I'M
GLAD WE'RE DOING IT BECAUSE SOME
OTHER STATES ON EVEN THERE YET
ARE FAR OFF.
AND SO I DO I DO THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO THINK DIFFERENTLY
THERE'S A SPIN OFF FROM THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE ARE FORMER
CHAIR -- STARTED -- IT'S LIKE ME
TO AND THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE SO THAT'S WHAT I THINK
THAT'LL WORK REALLY NICELY IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THIS COMMITTEE
ESPECIALLY.
HAVING -- FORMER CHAIR JONES
SAWYER -- CHEERING THAT
COMMITTEE SO I THINK A LOT OF
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- CAN
YOU CAN BUILD UPON OF ALL A LOT
OF WHAT WAS -- MENTION TODAY OF
FROM OUR FROM OUR ESTEEMED
PANELISTS -- AND AND THE THE
LAST THING I WANT TO MENTION
WHICH IS YOU KNOW OPEN AND I'M.
BECAUSE I THINK -- MISTER HEWITT
MADE MENTION OF THIS AS WELL
THAT.
THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS HE
REFERRED TO AS RED COUNTIES IS
BLUE COUNTIES BAKER WOULD.
CONVERT IT POLITICAL TERMS ARE
JUST MORE CONSERVATIVE VERSUS
MORE LIBERAL -- BEING IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OR IF YOU'RE IN LA
COUNTY ALAMEDA COUNTY SAM CISCO
WHAT HAVE YOU YOU HAVE SUPPORT
OF BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS.
YOU HAVE -- OF SHARES OR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS THAT ARE
GONNA BE TEND TO BE MORE
SUPPORTIVE MAYBE NOT ALWAYS BUT
THERE TEN DEAD TO BE SUPPORTIVE
AND SO BUT YOU HAVE MATCHING
GRANT PROGRAMS.
OR YOU HAVE THESE INVESTMENTS
YOU KNOW I HAVE MY BOARDS BY
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING KNOW THEY'VE ALREADY.
ARE ARE MOVING GO THERE THE IN
THESE COUNTIES SHUT DOWN
JUVENILE HALL AND AND AND AND
HOW TO BE.
A GUEST OF OPEN QUESTION IS HOW
DO WE GET THESE MORE
CONSERVATIVE COUNTY IS THAT
MAYBE DON'T HAVE SUPPORT OF
SHARES OR BOARD SUPERVISORS OR
DISAGREE ATTORNEYS BUT WE KNOW
THAT MANY OF YOU ARE ON THE
GROUND THERE.
DOING THE WORK HOW DO WE SUPPORT
YOUR WORK WITHOUT THE POLITICAL
SUPPORT.
AT THOSE LOCAL LEVELS UNTIL WE
CAN CHANGE ALL THOSE POLITICIANS
ARE HOW DO HOW DO WE GET.
THE RESOURCES INTO THOSE
COUNTIES BECAUSE I'D NOW IS A
VERY FAIR POINT.
THAT A LOT OF THE MONEY IS GOING
INTO THE COUNTIES THAT ALREADY
HAVE THE RESOURCES BUT IT'S KIND
OF LIKE A SELF FULFILLING
PROPHECY WHAT COMES FIRST.
AND SO I I THINK THAT'S AN OPEN
QUESTION TO THINK ABOUT AS
REPORTING MORE MORE MONEY -- IN
INTO THESE VERY WORTHY PROGRAMS
A LOT OF YOU A LOT OF THOSE THAT
ARE THAT SPOKE ON THE PREVIOUS
PANEL WORKING ON HOW DO WE HOW
DO WE AYE IF WE DON'T WE CAN'T
CHANGE THE MINDS AND HEARTS.
OF THOSE ELECTED LEADERS THAT
HAVE CONTROL OVER THOSE PURSE
STRINGS HOW CAN HELP ME FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO STILL GET THOSE
PROGRAMS THE SUPPORT THEY NEED.
EVEN IF THOSE POLITICIANS AT THE
SMALL DAY IN TIME ARE NECESSARY
SUPPORTING THEM SO THAT'S AGAIN
OPEN QUESTION FOR US TO KIND OF
THINK ABOUT BECAUSE IT CERTAINLY
SUPPLY CAME TO MIND.
WHEN CHAD AND MENTION THAT?
GOOD QUESTIONS WITH ANYONE LIKE
TO TAKE A SHOT AT I WAS JUST
GONNA -- SAY THAT I KNOW THAT
THAT'S A REALLY DIFFICULT YOU
KNOW THING TO TACKLE BUT I THINK
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT THINGS IS
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
DISTRIBUTING FUNDING OUR GRANTS
OR ANYTHING.
IS THAT YOU LOOK AT THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND HAVE THE TRACK RECORD AND
HAVE PROVEN THAT THE SYSTEMS
THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY
UTILIZING.
THEN WILL IMPACT THE COMMUNITY
AND I THINK.
THAT NEEDS TO START THERE.
BECAUSE THIS IS LIKE OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE COULD HAVE JUST
FOCUSED ON THE U..
AND THAT'S GOOD RIGHT WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON OUR YOUTH AND GROW THEM
BUT IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AS
MUCH LIKE A GOVERNMENT SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW THERE'S THINGS THAT YOU
CAN'T CONTROL SO THIS IS WHY THE
APPROACH THAT WE TOOK WITH THE
WITH THE NATIONAL BY DOESN'T
WORK AS TO YOU KNOW NOT NOT ONLY
ARE WE HERE WITH THE STUDENTS
BUT WE HEAR WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AN IN HOUSE TO
MEET IN THE MIDDLE.
SOMEWHERE.
IN A AND AND I KNOW THAT'S
DIFFICULT TO DO IN IT AND I KNOW
I'M READING THIS AND YOU'RE
THINKING WOW.
BUT IT WASN'T THAT EASY THE
FIRST YEAR NOBODY WOULD LIKE
WHAT IS IS WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU
WANT ME TO TOUCH AND FEEL MY
HEART LIKE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
YOU KNOW BUT BUT OVER TIME YOU
KNOW WHEN THEY STARTED IN A TO
INTERNALIZES AND SEE THE WORK
THAT IS GOING ON IN THE AND I
HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH THE
INSANE THAT.
THE PUSH THAT IS YOU KNOW COMING
FROM FROM THE STATE AND FROM THE
ASSEMBLY IS HELPING.
BECAUSE IN THERE YOU KNOW EVEN
IF PEOPLE JUST DO IT JUST
BECAUSE IT'S THE CURRENT
NARRATIVE THAT'S OKAY.
IT THERE JUST NEEDS TO BE THAT
PATHWAY FOR FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN EITHER JUMP BONNER
YOU KNOW.
JUMP UP AND NOT BUT BE QUIET NOT
CAUSE ANY MORE PROBLEMS AND
THAT'S IT YOU KNOW THE OUTCOME
THAT I THINK WE CAN HOPE.
FOR IS THAT THOSE WHO ARE
PASSIONATE AND WHO ARE REALLY
VESTED IN WHAT THEY'RE DOING ARE
GOING TO AND THOSE THAT ARE NOT
AND CAN JUST.
YOU KNOW TAKE A STEP BACK AND
THAT'S OKAY WELL LEVEL MANY WAY
FROM AFAR YEAH WELL AS I GUESS
IS YOUR BUILDING THE MOMENTUM
FROM THE GROUND UP.
THE GRASSROOTS.
THE DOWNWARD PRESSURE AND JUST
SQUEEZE ABOUT THE CAN EITHER
GUILT.
JOINT OR STEP ASIDE [inaudible]
THANK -- YEAH I JUST WANTED TO
ADD I THINK.
I THINK YOU YOU HAD EXACTLY ON
THE HEAD AND ARM I THINK A WAY
FOR US TO TO TANGIBLY DO THAT
THE VERY LEAST THIS THIS BODY
THIS LEGISLATURE CAN DO THAT IS
BY CREATING YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WE'RE ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE IN OUR YOUTH SERVICES
UNDER THAT DEPARTMENT -- AND
IT'LL BE TOO ENTICING BILLS
CONSERVE COUNTY THIS TO MISS OUT
ON OUT ON THESE FUNDS OF THESE
MONEY AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND THEN SECONDLY -- I THINK
BRINGING BACK SB FORTY THREE I
BELIEVE WAS THE NUMBER BY MINING
WHICH WOULD HAVE CREATED A PILOT
PROGRAM -- PILOT FUNDS FOR FIVE
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT APARTMENTS IN
FIVE COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
THAT WOULD APPLY.
ARM IT WAS KILLED I THINK THAT'S
A TESTAMENT TO WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE CONSIDER
COUNTIES THE LOT OF POWER IN
PROBATION STUDS A LOT OF POWER
TO SEND SEEN.
THAT -- THAT THAT THE STRONGHOLD
THAT THEY HAVE OVER CALIFORNIA'S.
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG
PEOPLE COMING TO AN END -- BUT I
THINK IF WE CAN BRING THAT BACK
WE CAN SLOWLY START BUILDING.
ON AND AND CREATING DEVELOPMENT
ALL BECAUSE STATE.
THANK YOU.
I'VE GOT A QUESTION AS IT
RELATES TO OUR SCHOOL CLIMB IT.
AND ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW WE'VE
GIVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF DISCRETION
UTILIZING LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULAS.
WHAT COULD WE DO MORE TO ADD
MAYBE THE WORD IS INCENTIVIZE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS? TO UTILIZE IN
PRIORITIZE SOME OF THESE
RESOURCES -- TO IMPLEMENT YOU
KNOW WHY THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
CERTAINLY A PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
SCHOOL -- BUT OUTSIDE.
LOVE TO HEAR WHAT -- WHAT COULD
WE DO?
IN THE LA BECAUSE THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE BILL OF RIGHTS WHICH WAS
FOUGHT FOR BY FOLKS IN THIS ROOM
AND OTHERS BE REDUCE SUSPENSIONS
BY OVER 70% BY ELIMINATING
WILLFUL DEFIANCE IS A REASON FOR
SUSPENSION BUT THAT WAS SEVERAL
YEARS AGO AN EX EXTRAORDINARY
SUCCESS BUT WE FOR LEARNED
RECENTLY.
IS THAT -- ARRESTS OF KIDS ON
THOSE CAMPUSES IS GOING UP AS OF
THE ORIGINAL VISION WAS THAT
RESOURCES FOR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE ANOTHER SERVICES WERE
SUPPOSED TO REPLACE THE NEED FOR
SUSPENSION.
AND IT WHAT WE'VE SEEN AND WE'VE
SEEN SOME OTHER PROGRAMS WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY THAT THAT
PART DOESN'T HAPPEN SOMETIMES A
REFORM HAPPENS WITHOUT THE
SERVICES AND I THINK WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY WE JUST REALLY
CAN'T AFFORD TO MAKE THAT
MISTAKE AND WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY IS.
A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF UNITY AROUND
LIKE WILL NEVER MAKE THAT
MISTAKE AGAIN AND LET'S MAKE
SURE THE RESOURCES ARE THERE.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW MAKING SURE
THE RESOURCES ARE ACTUALLY
ALLOCATED IN SCHOOLS FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND FOR REAL
ALTERNATIVES TO SUSPENSION WHICH
INCLUDES TEACHER TRAINING BUT
ALSO SPECIFIC SERVICES FOR KIDS.
AND ALSO THERE'S A REAL OVER
RELIANCE ON SCHOOL POLICE AND
SOME OF THESE -- SCHOOLS AND SO
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT TO DO
ABOUT THAT BUT I THINK YOU KNOW.
SCHOOLS AND KIDS ARE LOOKING FOR
CARING ADULTS AND SCHOOL POLICE.
IF THAT'S THE SOURCE OF CARING
ADULTS ARE SOME REALLY SERIOUS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES TO THAT
SO I WOULD LOOK AT THAT AS WELL.
ELSE WANT TO GIVE TO A SHELTER
QUESTION.
OKAY.
I WANNA ALSO WHAT DOES ONE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE -- HOW MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE HERE TODAY?
AND I WHAT I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT THEY'RE HERE TODAY THEY'VE
BEEN IMPACTED BY EVERYTHING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND WE CAN'T
FORGET THEIR STORIES BECAUSE
THEIR STORIES ARE WHAT'S GOING
TO MAKE.
TO IS WHAT'S GONNA MAKE THE REAL
IMPACT IN.
TALKING ABOUT US MOVING INTO
OTHER COUNTIES WHETHER YOU'RE OF
MORE OF A RED COUNTY I THINK WE
WE NEED TO DEFINITELY INVEST
MORE IN YOUTH ORGANIZING --
AROUND THESE ISSUES AND AND AND
HELP THEM TO MAKE IMPACT -- MORE
SO THAN ALL OF THE OLD FOLKS --
ME I'M ON THEM TO ABOUT ME --
INCENTIVIZING INCENTIVIZING
SCHOOL PROGRAMS IS THAT WHAT THE
QUESTION YEAH I'M LOOKING AT THE
FUNDING THAT WE'RE GIVING I MEAN
EVERY YEAR WE TELL THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
THERE WERE INCREASING FUNDING TO
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS K. TO TWELVE
SYSTEM RIGHT AND THIS YEAR WE'RE
GONNA INVEST MORE IN A PUBLIC
SCHOOL IN.
EDUCATION -- SAYING WILL THAT'S
GREAT AND CERTAINLY THERE ARE
OTHER YOU KNOW STANDARDS AND
CURRICULUMS THAT NEED TO BE
TIGHTENED ADOPTED.
COMPLETED BUT WERE ALSO SEEN
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CHALLENGES
WITH OUR SCHOOL CLIMATE IN THE
IMPACT IT'S HAVING.
ON DRAMATIZATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE
SO SHOULD THERE BE SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE DOING LEGISLATIVELY.
TO CONDITION THE ACCEPTANCE OF
THESE DOLLARS TO GOAL TOWARDS
THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS AND AND
IF SO WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE.
I DON'T HAVE ANY.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER EITHER
REALLY COULD NOT.
IN THE ORGANIZING YEAH TAKE THE
PRESSURE.
GREAT THE PRESSURE ON MY ON THE
LOCAL AREA -- BUT THE FUNDING
YOUTH ORGANIZING I LIKE THAT
IDEA BECAUSE I THINK ON WITH THE
KIND OF CENTER BY THE SCHOOLS WE
CAN WE CAN.
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
ORGANIZING AT THEIR SCHOOLS TO
TO GET THESE PROGRAMS DONE
LOCALLY.
SO I WANTED TO SPEAK -- REAL
QUICK AS FAR AS A RESOURCE
OFFICERS SO -- OUR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT A TO THEM ACTUALLY
DISMISSED.
ALL OF THE RESOURCE OFFICERS
FROM OUR CAMPUS THIS PAST SCHOOL
YEAR.
SO SHUT UP TO TO OUR BOARD
MEMBERS AND I KNOW WE HAVE ONE
HERE IN THE AUDIENCE LEFT EARLY --
AND THE REASON THAT ONE NUMBER
ONE AND ALL THAT I'M OUR BOARD
MEMBERS ARE ARE PROGRESSIVE.
AND I KNOW THAT -- MANY OF THEM
DO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THE WORK --
THAT IS BEING DONE AND SO THEY
WERE ABLE TO TO DO THAT NOT ONLY
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT THAT
WAS NOT AND YOU KNOW GOOD USE OF
RESOURCES FOR SURE -- BUT ALSO
BECAUSE WITH THE LC FF DOLLARS.
HEALTHY A FIFTY DOLLARS.
BEEN A LONG DAY -- THEY ARE
FUNDING AS SO THERE'S A MOVEMENT
TO INTEGRATE P. B. I. S. AND HAS
BEEN FUNDED FOR COUPLE YEARS
NINE OR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SO ALL THE SCHOOLS -- WITHIN THE
NEXT YEAR TO HAVE TO BE -- PBS
COMPLIANT JUST ACCORDING. TO TO
THAT -- TRAINING -- THERE IS
SOME FUNDING THAT IS GOING
TOWARDS -- SOME OF THE RJ
PROGRAMS.
AND THEN WE YOU KNOW OF COURSE
WE HAVE THIS GRANT SO I THINK
CONTINUING TO FIND OPPORTUNITIES
SUCH AS THESE.
BECAUSE I'M YOU KNOW WORKING AND
I'VE BEEN IN THE WORK IN FRISCO
THIS YEAR FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
SO YOU KNOW LIKE I MENTIONED
BEFORE -- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE SYSTEMIC LIKE A LOT OF
OTHER SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE.
AND I THINK HAD THIS GRANT NOT
COMMAND AND THEY WERE EXPOSED TO
THE WORK THAT IS BEING DONE --
WITH THE WITH THE COMBAT IS
NETWORK.
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD NO KEY IN ON
A CLUE NO YOU KNOW WHAT IS IS
HOW IS THIS CUTE OR SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND I AND I SEE THAT -- ONE OF
THE BIGGEST THINGS AND THAT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT AND IS IT WAS A
CHALLENGE FOR US IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
IS THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
STILL THEIR MIND SAID EVEN
THOUGH THEY DO CARE.
THEIR MINDSET IS STILL TEST
COURSE.
TEST COURSE OF COURSE OF COURSE.
I DON'T CARE IF THE KID IS
HUNGRY I DON'T CARE IF THE KID
IN SEE PLUS MY I DON'T CARE IF
THE KIDS YOU KNOW PARENTS WERE
DEPORTED AND NOW HE HAD TO STAY
WITH A NEIGHBOR.
SO THERE WAS NOT A LOT OF FOCUS
ON THAT AND EVEN IF YOU LOOK AT
THE STATE.
MEASURES THE THE SUCCESS OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT BY WHAT THEY
CALL NOW WITH THE DASHBOARD.
WELL THAT DASHBOARD IS ALL
ACADEMIC.
IT MEASURES THE ACADEMICS.
IT'S MEASURING -- ATTENDANCE BUT
IT'S NOT MEASURE IN ANY OF THE
SOCIAL INDICATORS.
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST FIGHTS THAT WE HAD WITH
DINNER OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
CAN'T TELL YOU THAT IT'S A 100%
RESOLVED BUT I KNOW THAT WE'VE
MADE GREAT STRIDES.
IN JUST SAYING THAT YOU KNOW
THERE THERE NEEDS TO BE THAT
SHIFT THEM AND WE'RE SEEING IT
NOW YOU KNOW WHAT THE DATE OF
THAT -- THAT THAT WE HAVE WITH
YOU THROUGH THE GRANT.
WHERE TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS ARE STARTING TO
SAY HEY YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
RIGHT?
IF THIS CHILD IS COMING INTO MY
CLASSROOM AND HE HAS ALL HIS
BAGGAGE WITH HIM.
HE'S NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
COMPREHEND THE LESSON THAT I'M
THAT I'M TRYING TO TEACH.
SO YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT'S LIKE A
WHOLE BIGGER PICTURE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN I
LOOK AT THAT DASHBOARD THE
MEASURE SUBGROUPS.
AND ALL OF THAT BUT THERE IS NO
MEASUREMENT OF ANY OTHER TYPE OF
WORK AND HOW.
THOSE INDICATORS -- CORRELATE
WITH THE WITH THE THE DATA
THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING COLLECTED.
SO THAT'S ONE THING AND AND
DEFINITELY -- YOU KNOW JUST
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS
I KNOW I HEARD THE THE FIRST
GROUP A GENTLEMAN THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS A NOBODY WANTED AS THEY
I WANT IT.
TELL ME WHAT I GOTTA DO AND I
LOOK THAT UP A LITTLE BIT AND
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I'M THE
REQUIREMENTS WERE FOR THE
FUNDING AWAY I WOULD HAVE PLAYED
FOR EITHER JUST BECAUSE OF THE
WAY IT WAS YOU KNOW.
THEY WERE -- FORCING YOU TO MAKE
LONG FORSMAN YOUR PARTNERS.
WELL YOU CAN'T DO THAT IN A
SECOND I JUST MET YOU I'M GONNA
MARRY RAILING.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE YOU KNOW
LIKE WE NEED TO GET TO KNOW EACH
OTHER YOU NEED TO BUILD THAT
RELATIONSHIP ENOUGH.
YOU NEED TO YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO
HOLD SOME SPACE THERE AND THEN
YOU KNOW AFTER WE GET TO KNOW
EACH OTHER WAY YOU KNOW WE COULD
BE THE BECOME.
YOU KNOW OF FRIENDS OR YOU KNOW
WHATEVER BUT THERE YOU CAN'T
JUST FORCE PEOPLE TO YOU KNOW
THIS IS NOT LIKE YOU KNOW
REALITY TV RIGHT.
AND AND I THINK YOU KNOW JUST
BEING HAVING THOSE HONEST
CONVERSATIONS AND FOLKS WILL BE
TAKING A LOOK AT AND WHEN
THERE'S FUNDERS YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE FUNDING.
AND ARE THEY REALLY INTERESTED
IN FUNDING OR THERE IS STILL
FUNDING THEIR OWN IDEOLOGIES.
YOU KNOW SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL OF YOU.
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE GONNA
OPEN THIS UP NOW -- TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS I DO ACKNOWLEDGE OF MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER KALRA WHO'S
BEEN WITH US -- ALL THREE HOURS
HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH BECAUSE
AND FOR ALL OF YOU AGAIN WHO ARE
SPOKEN TO AT THIS TIME.
WILL OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
WE HAVE THE ROOM FOR ANOTHER FEW
MINUTES AND SO FAR.
THOSE OF YOU WHO WILL COME UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION WITH.
TAKE YOU KNOW MAYBE FORTY FIVE
SECONDS A MINUTE OR SO IT WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT GIVEN
THAT -- WE DON'T HAVE THE ROOM
FOR A WHOLE LOT LONGER BUT THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE.
FIRST OF ALL ARE THE ONES ARE
SAYING THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS AND ALSO I OWN ALSO SAY
THANK YOU TO SEND ME AND MARK
FOR BRINGING UP RENDON HARRISON.
AT THIS EVENT.
AND ALSO LOST TO ALSO BRING UP
THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE BEING HELD
A FATHER'S FAMILY CALLED AN OPEN
EVERYTHING OUR SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE I AM ONE OF THE SAID.
I AM WANTED TO SEX SEX SEX
STORIES OUT OF IT WOULD HAVE
ANOTHER I HAVE GRADUATED NOW.
AND YEAH AND NOW.
MY PROBATION NOW -- THANKFUL TO
FATHER FOUND HIM STANDING THERE
BEING FREE -- SOME OF FREE AND
TOM OFFER BASIN WHICH IS IN A
FEW WHICH IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS MONTH -- I'LL BE GETTING
OFF OF PROBATION [inaudible]
AND THAT'S ALL BECAUSE THAT'S
ALL THANKS TO FOLLOW THE
FAMILIES -- I HAVE BEEN ON
PROBATION FOR THREE YEARS. THREE
SEVEN INFORMATION -- HAS BEING
AND THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
VIOLATE ME TWICE FOR SOMETHING
THAT WAS IN MY CONTROLLED ALSO
IN THEIR CONTROL.
TO BECAUSE I NEED THEIR HELP
THEN GIVE ME THE HELP THAT I
NEEDED SO.
SO THEN WHEN WHEN THAT THING
CAME OUT FOR THE FOR ME BEING
VIOLATED I ASKED.
PEOPLE FOLLOWS HOUSE I MEAN IT
IT.
AND WHEN THEY WENT TO COURT THE
JUDGE ENDED UP. FOR THE FIRST
TIME THE JURY THE JUDGE SEEN MY
MUG SHOT MY SHOT THE PICTURE
THAT MY PULL OFF USING THEM.
AND ALL THE SUDDEN SHOW GOOD
CITING SO -- WHAT THEY DID WAS
THEY CREATED A BY A PACK?
OF ALL MY CERTIFICATES AND ALL
THE LOVE THAT I HAVE IN ALL THE
PICTURES AND THE GOOD MEMORIES I
HAVE OF SHOWING THE OTHER SIDE.
THE SIDE THAT DOES NOT USUALLY
SOME IN THE COURT IN THE COURT.
SO WITH WITH THAT.
I WAS ABLE TO STAY OUT OF
JUVENILE HALL AND AND I'M VERY
THANKFUL FOR THAT.
BECAUSE YES FEW DAYS GO ALL IS
IN A MEETING SAYING THAT WHERE
KIDS TO GO INTO YOUR AND WE ARE
YOU KNOW THIS BECAUSE I GO INTO
YOU AND ALL THE THEY COME OUT --
MODERATE THIS LET'S SAYS FOR
LESS.
THEY AREN'T ALONE.
THEY HAVE MORE TO BE SUCCESSFUL
BEFORE THEY WON'T DO NOW THEN
WHEN THEY COME OUT.
THEY HAVE MORE TIME WHEN THEY
COME UP IN THE MORNING THEY HAVE
MORE ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE MORE
ISSUES THAT HAVE SOLVED WHEN
THEY COME UP AND THEN WHEN IN.
DEATH THEY NEED MORE HILL IN AND
THEN WHEN THEY WON THEN.
BEFORE THEY WENT IN THEN WHEN
THEY WENT OUT.
AND WITH ALL OF THE FAMILIES NOW
THEY'RE ACTUALLY I'M ACTUALLY
GETTING.
THE RESOURCES I NEED WITH THE
TOM HAD BEEN DOING THANKS TO THE
TERM RECOVERY CENTER THAT WE
HAVE A STOCKTON.
THEY ARE HELP ME WITH THAT.
AND NOW I'M ON THE ROAD -- NOT
HELP MY COMMUNITY.
AND HELPING THEM NO MATTER WHAT
YOU KNOW HELPING AND IN A GOOD
WAY THANKS TWO THOUSAND FAMILIES.
THANK YOU RATHER.
HELLO MY NAME IS RON YOUNG AN
ORGANIZATION'S FATHERS OF
FAMILIES.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
MIKE DOWN A LITTLE BIT SO WE CAN
HEAR YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE.
I LIKE TO THINK ON THE CHAIRMAN
AND THE SELECT COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE. TO ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEM OF THE SCHOOL PART THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
AND HOW ONCE YOU GET INTO THE
INCARNATION.
YOU IS LIKE A CIRCLE YOU CAN
NEVER BACK OUT.
EVERY TIME YOU GET OUT YOU GET
BACK IN.
BECAUSE ONCE YOU GET OUT YOU
HAVE LIKE.
A WASHER CHANCE OF BEING
SUCCESSFUL AT NOON IF YOU
WEREN'T.
AND ALL LIKE TO THINK THAT.
YOU LIKE THAT YOU ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM THAT HOW [inaudible]
IF YOU.
IF YOU ADDRESS THE PROBLEM THE
HOW IF YOU WERE A STUDENT AT A
SCHOOL.
THE THEY WILL MOST LIKELY
SUSPEND YOU OFFER SOMETHING THAT
WASN'T REALLY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THEY JUST WANT YOU ARE
THE SUSPENSION SO THEN THEY CAN
GET MONEY. FOR HELPING ON FOR
NOT HELPING YOU SO THEY'RE
BASICALLY BENEFITING OFF OF YOUR
PAIN AND SUFFERING.
AND ALL LIKE THE HOW MAY I
PERSONALLY -- LIKE A LIKE IF THE
COURSE WOULD ACTUALLY SEE YOUR
HUMANITY.
AND YOUR INDIVIDUAL
INDIVIDUALITY.
INSTEAD OF USING YOU AS NOT AS A
PERSON OR JUST PERSON.
NOT AS A PERSON OR SOMETHING
THAT THEY JUST USE TO GET MONEY
[inaudible] FOR OTHER THINGS
THAT THEY DON'T NEED.
LIKE THE PROBATION YOU THEY USE
THE PROBATION FEES SOMETIMES TO
PUT MONEY IN THEIR OWN POCKET SO
SELF SUPPORTING.
ORGANIZATION SO THAT THEY WILL
NEVER RUN OUT OF MONEY.
BUT IF YOU'RE PUBLISHING A YOU
JUST GET OUT OF PRISON IT'S HARD
TO STANDING ON FEET WHEN YOU
HAVE TO PAY MORE MONEY.
IF YOU JUST GOT OUT OF JAIL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
HELLO -- MY NAME START TOWARDS
I'M WAY THE FATHERS OF FAMILIES
AND ONE OF THE YOUTH THAT
GRADUATED.
FROM OBERLIN NOTABLY.
AND I'M PART OF THE HIT SQUAD
WHICH STANDS FOR HILL IN
INTERGENERATIONAL TRAUMA
[inaudible]
AND THINKING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI ON JOHNNY BIOS JUST WANTED TO
TAKE THE COMEDIAN CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING US TO MAKE YOUR SPACE
OUR SPACE.
AND ASSURING -- AND ALLOWING US
TO SHARE OUR OPINIONS AND
CONCERNS -- IN OUR COMMUNITY
HOPEFULLY OUR VOICES STRONGLY
HEARD AND USED TO SHAPE OUR
COMMUNITY INTO A BETTER SYSTEM
AND HOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HEY MY NAME IS ALEXANDRIA -- A
YOUTH ORGANIZE THAT FOLLOWS A
FAMILY -- I'VEBEEN WITH THE
ORGANIZATION FOR THREE YEARS AND
THEY'VE BEEN THEY IMPACTED MY
LIFE A LOT THEY HELP ME GET
THROUGH -- CALLED I MEAN I
COLORS NOT YET.
HIGH SCHOOL I GOT TO HIGH SCHOOL
I GRADUATED THIS YEAR -- THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
RPG GUYS LISTEN TO US LISTEN TO
OUR YOUTH AND TAKING THE TIME
FOR US AND FALL IS A FAMILY --
I'M IN A COUPLE OF THE ONE TWO I
GRADUATED FROM HOLDEN NOBLY.
AND I'M HELPING THE YOUTH TRYING
TO EMPOWER THEIR VOICE AND TEACH
HIM HOW TO EMBRACE THEMSELVES
[inaudible]
AND I'M IN ALL RIGHT NOW WITH AT
ANY YOU KNOW AND THE RIGHT
PERSON.
IS.
THAT A I'M WITH.
IN HIS LITTLE GROUP -- THE ORGAN
THAT LITTLE ORGANIZATION IS HELP
JUSTICE.
PAT HIS AND HIS GO OUT YEAH.
OF THESE IN CONCRETE -- WHERE
WE'VE BEEN PLANTING TREES OUT
AND STOCKTON BECAUSE THE AIR
QUALITY IS KIND OF LIKE IS NOT
GOOD YOU?
WOULDN'T KNOW WHEN I'LL HAVE.
BUT MY ANTI SHE'S BEEN.
SHE GOT AS MOVE OFF JUST WALKING
AT THE ARK AND GOING TO SCHOOL
BECAUSE OF THE BAD AIR QUALITY
SO UP I APPRECIATE HIM AND HIS A
LITTLE GROUP THAT HE GOT GOING
ON SEASON CONCRETE AT DON'T
FORGET IT.
THEY EVERY TIME THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS ARE
YOU IN MARIN THOMAS I'M WITH THE
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES I'M WITH
YOU JUST COALITION.
MY EXPERIENCE GROWING UP IN LA
AND I'M JUST ONE OUT OF MILLIONS
TELL MY STORY.
ON MY FIRST I WAS A VENICE HIGH
SCHOOL -- WE HAD A SCHOOL
PROBATION OFFICER THAT.
PRETTY MUCH STOP ME ON A DAILY
BASIS EVERY DAY WHEN HE WAS
EVERY DAY WHEN HE SAW ME WAS SAY
YOU'RE ON PROBATION WHEN I
REALLY WAS AND I TOOK IT AS I
TOOK IT AS IF HE THOUGHT I WAS A
BAD KID.
HE WOULD CALL ME BY MY LAST NAME
HE SAY LIKE YO MARTIN YOU KNOW
YOU'RE ON MY ROSTER RIGHT WERE.
YOU KNOW YOUR PROBATION RIGHT
AND EVERY TIME I ALWAYS SAY NO
I'M NOT BUT HE WILL TRY TO
CONVINCE ME THAT I WAS BUT I
KNOW I WAS IN ALL NEVER FORGET
HIS FACE.
HE WON BY THE NAME OF GARCIA HE
ALWAYS WEAR LIKE A SUIT AND DARK
GLASSES THEN ONE DAY.
WHILE ATTENDING VENICE OUR GUNS
WILL FIGHT WITH ANOTHER STUDENT
I WAS KICKED OUT FOR FIGHTING I
WAS FOR FOR I WASN'T REFERRED TO
ANOTHER SCHOOL I WAS NEVER SAT
DOWN.
WITH THE STUDENT OR TALK TO
ABOUT WHY IT HAPPENED.
WHEN I WAS KICKED OUT I WAS OUT
OF SCHOOL FOR MONTHS AND MY
MOTHER DIDN'T KNOW I WAS
EXPELLED?
SO I WOULD LEAVE MY HOUSE EVERY
DAY AND WILL LIE TO MY MOM AND
SO THERE I WAS GOING TO SCHOOL.
BUT I WAS REALLY IN THE STREETS
MAKING IT LOOK LIKE I WAS DOING
SOME EVENTUALLY I FOUND.
OUT I FOUND OUT ABOUT ANOTHER
SCHOOL CALLED UNIVERSITY HIGH
BUT WHEN I WAS THERE BUT WHEN IT
WAS TIME FOR ME TO GO TO CLASS
IT WAS HARD FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WAS GOING ON BECAUSE I WAS
OUT OF SCHOOL FOR SO LONG --
WHEN I ONCE UNIVERSITY HIRED
GUNS WHO A SITUATION WITH THE
TEACHER WHO MADE A RACIST REMARK
TO ME IN A REACTIVE INNER ANGRY
MANNER?
I WAS ARRESTED.
A TWO WEEKS LATER I WAS PUT ON
PROBATION FOR THREE YEARS HOUSES
I WAS SIXTEEN AT THE TIME.
ON MY PROBATION OFFICER SIGN ME
UP FOR HIGH RISK HIGH NEED
CLASSES AND ANGER MANAGEMENT.
MY MOTHER COULDN'T AFFORD THE
FEES ALONE.
I ENDED UP I ENDED UP NOT TAKING
THE CLASSES AND MY MOTHER WAS
PRETTY MUCH FORCED TO PAY.
FOR ON SOALL I GOT IN THOSE TWO
YEARS OF PROBATION Và DRUG
TESTED.
ALL WAS HE MILLION IT WAS A
HUMILIATING EXPERIENCE ALONE.
YEAH IT WAS A MILLION EXPERIENCE
I WAS I THOUGHT I'VE I FEEL AS
IF I HAD NO FRIEDMAN MY WAS
THREATEN TO NOT BE HOME FOR
CHRISTMAS I WAS SINCE THE
JUVENILE HALL.
THEY TELL ME THIS IS WHERE I
WOULD BE FINE AND I STRAIGHTEN
UP IN ME PERSONALLY I FEEL LIKE
THE YOUNG PEOPLE ME SUPPORT LOVE.
ME SOMEONE TO LISTEN TO ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE NEED MORE YOU
CENTERS IN MORE JOBS FOR EVERY
YOUTH YOUTH.
AND BUS PASSES SO WE DON'T FEEL
TRAPPED SCENE OF THINGS THAT
WILL HELP US IN THE LONG RUN NOT
AFFECT THIS.
SURE.
HI ANGIE NAY I'M HERE WITH
FATHERS AND FAMILIES I BASICALLY
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. FOR
INFORMING ME ON INFORMATION OUT
IN NO BEFORE I CAME HERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- BLESSING
THE BLESSING I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN GARCIA AND COMMITTEE
SPACE THE THOSE THE STATE -- I
AM ANTHONY ROBINSON JUNIOR.
THAT ERIC WAS TALKING ABOUT BUT
NO -- REALLY I JUST WANTED TO
ALL TAKE HIS MOMMY RIGHT YEAH
YOUNG PEOPLE SPEND ENOUGH TO
DECIDE TO SPEAK FOR HIMSELF AND
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT.
AND WHEN I INVITED THE YOUNG
BROTHER DERON TO WRITE SOMETHING
DOWN RIGHT JUST TO GET ITSELF
TOGETHER.
HE TOOK ANY RATHER START THE
OPPORTUNITY AND INSTINCTIVELY I
THOUGHT IF THEY WILL.
I WONDER WHAT HIS PARENTS ARE
LIGHT.
THAT WOULD INVESTING IN TO WHERE
HE WOULD TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WRITE DOWN A THOUSAND IDEAS SO
THAT HE CAN ARTICULATED SELF IN
A SPACE RIGHT THAT BECAUSE
SEASON TOO MANY TO MOST FOLKS.
I'M FORTUNATE AND BLESSED AND
ALWAYS PARENTS RIGHT AND ALSO TO
WORK WITH A LOT OF THE YOUTH AND
FATHERS IN FAMILIES BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'M ALWAYS --
MINDFUL OF LIKE YOU SAY FORM THE
COURSE RIGHT AFTER DOING TWENTY
YEARS IN PRISON.
AND RECOGNIZING THAT I'M
STANDING HERE -- THE LEGAL FOR
ME COST READY VOTERS RIGHT I'M
STANDING HERE.
BLESSED FROM.
HAVING TO LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT
SEVEN GENERATIONS BACK BUT ALSO
UNDERSTAND YOU LOOKING SEVEN
GENERATIONS FOR SOLID INVITE US
ALL TO DAY TO TAKE THE TIME TO
LOOK INTO THE EYES THAT YOU.
I MEAN REALLY LOOK INTO THEIR
EYES AND ACTUALLY SELL OR
MEDITATE UPON THE QUESTION AT
WHAT TYPE OF INVESTMENT IS MY
ACTIONS EVEN. FOR THEM WHAT TYPE
OF FEATURES MY ACTIONS LEADING
FOR THEM WHEN YOU REALLY LOOK
INTO A LARGE AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT INTERSECTS ANALOGY RIGHT
THOUGH SO SHE DETERMINES OF
HEALTH THEY USUALLY GOLDEN
NEGATIVE WAY.
WHY DOES IT ALWAYS A FOR A
MODERN ARE USED TO HAVE THE
PROJECT THREE RD CAPACITY TO
SPEAK ON THEIR OWN BEHALF?
ESPECIALLY IN SPACES LIKE THIS
WILL MY BROTHER HAS ANY
BASICALLY GAVE IT THAT HISTORIC
NAFTA THAT THE SPACE WAS NOT
ALWAYS WELCOME ME FOR FOLKS WHO
LOOK LIKE US.
SO FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO WOULD
PROBABLY STAND UP AND ARTICULATE
THEMSELVES ARTICULATED BETTER
BECAUSE SOMETIMES THE MOST OF US
A GROW FOLKS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
COME UP WITH. FOR MEET AFTER
BLESSING RIGHT ADDED INFORMS THE
WORK AND ALWAYS TELL PEOPLE ONE
OF THE BENEFITS OF DOING GOOD
WORK.
IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE
GOOD WORK.
YES THEY BLESSED THANK YOU.
FOR GOOD EVENING EVERYONE THANK
YOU FOR THIS TIME IN HIS FALLEN
SHORT CHAU NEW FROM VERIZON
PHONES ARE SOMEWHAT CAM
EDUCATION -- EQUITY ORGANIZER'S --
SO HAPPY CINEMA USE HERE OF
LEARNED A LOT IN MY TWELVE
THIRTY YES OF IN THE U. S. --
UNDERSTANDING I TO YOUR
IMMIGRANT OR YOUR BALL HERE
OPPRESSION DOES NOT DISCRIMINATE.
ON SO THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TO IN
A SUPPORT ORDER YOUTH ON IN ALL
THIS IS BETWEEN IN OUR AGENCY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY GOD BLESS YOU ALL.
MY NAME IS SERVING ALVAREZ --
WITH THE YOUTH JUST COALITION
PRESENCE AND SELF COALITION.
OF A BACK WHEN I WAS --
SEVENTEEN SIT IN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS IN THE SALE WAITING TO GET
PROCESS AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
AND KNOCKING ON THE DOOR AND
BANKING TRYING TO GET SOME WATER
TRYING TO GET SOME FOOD --
GROWING UP YOU KNOW I NEVER
THOUGHT I WOULD END UP IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT.
AND JUST GROWING UP AND THEN
REALIZING THAT LIKE I NEEDED
HELP I NEEDED A MEANT FOR I NEED
IT.
BROTHER HAIRY MAYBE YOU KNOW I'M
SAYING I NEED AT THIS OTHER
BROTHER HERE GARCIA TO HELP ME
BECOME A MAN MADE ME BECOME A
YOUNG FELLOW.
THAT THE MEMBER SOCIETY I NEVER
GOT THAT OPPORTUNITY.
AND YOU KNOW I'M RIGHT NOW
TWENTY FIVE AND I STILL DON'T
HAVE MY HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA DUE
TO THE POOR CONDITIONS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE INSIDE A PRISON
SYSTEMS AND THINGS LIKE THAT AND
WE DON'T NEED TO BE HAVING OUR
KIDS IN THERE.
AND NOT BEING EDUCATED AND NOT
BEING TRAINED TO THE TO BE
SUCCESS WHEN OUR COMMUNITIES.
SORRY ONE APPRECIATE CHAU.
AND YOU KNOW JUST.
ANYTHING YOU KNOW -- TO BUILD A
BETTER MAN IN OUR COMMUNITY IS
ALWAYS EMPOWERING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S TYLER CUT AND I'M WITH
FATHERS AND FAMILIES.
I'M A YOUTH LEADER I'M A PART OF
HIT SQUAD AND SEEDS OF CONCRETE
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU.
FOR TAKING THE TIME OUT TO
LISTEN TO US THROUGH SAMMY.
ANYA -- BUT UNTIL HUNDRED AT
LEAST CERVANTES SOMEONE A LONG
NIGHT OF THE FIRST QUARTER THE
INDICATE USE FELLOWSHIP.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
PERSON SENDING YOU IN FRONT OF
YOU RIGHT NOW.
ISN'T COMPLETELY DIFFERENT FROM
THE PERSON.
GREW UP IN SOUTH SACRAMENTO I
WENT THROUGH THE HIGH SCHOOL AND
THAT OUR OWN.
YOU KNOW FOR ME ALWAYS SAY WITH
JUST ONE PERSON TELLING ME WHAT
DO YOU WANT TO DO WITH THEIR
LIFE.
I WHEN SIXTEEN YEARS MY ENTIRE
LIFE WITHOUT ANYBODY EVER ASKED
ME THAT SINGLE QUESTION.
AND WHEN A PERSON OF WHEN I'M.
IT WAS MYSELF REAR OF HIGH
SCHOOL IN A SERMON THE DAY -- AS
LIKE IN THE LIVE REELS IN THE
BACK OF THE COMPUTER ROOMS AND I
WAS SITTING DOWN WITH -- MICHAEL
LIND.
CEO AND FOUNDER OF IMPROVE YOUR
TOMORROW HE ASKED ME A QUESTION
HE WAS LIKE.
PALM BUT ALL.
HUNDRED WE WANT TO DO WITH YOUR
LIFE.
AND FOR ME THAT CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF MY ENTIRE LIFE
MOVING FOR UP TO THAT POINT.
HOW CLOSE IN AND NOW OF HIGH
SCHOOL IN IN OUR CLASSROOMS A
FULL?
MY FIRST GENERAL SCIENCE.
NOW WITH MY COUNSELOR AND ASK
FOR THE EASIER.
MATH COURSE -- I WAS NOMINATED
AND WHAT'S THE OVER MY LIFE AND
HONESTLY I DID AND WHEN I LOOK
PASS FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN BUT IT'S
ALMOST FIFTEEN NO USE ARE YOU
SELLING ASKING -- CORN WHATEVER
I COULD SELL ON THE STREET TO
MAKE UP TO HELP ON MY FAMILY.
AND WHEN.
WHEN A PERSON WHEN IN A BILL
ESPECIALLY SHOWS SOME SUPPORT?
NJ SHOWS LOVE TO YOU THAT
CHANGES YOUR LIFE.
AND FOR ME THAT CHANGED MY LIFE.
AND I WON AND WON THE COMMUNITY
AND THE PEOPLE HERE TO KNOW THAT
AND THAT I'M A SUCCESS STORY
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE INVESTMENT.
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE LEVER OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO
YOUTH AND A WHOLE THAT CONTINUES
THAT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN AND
I'LL CONTINUE THAT.
WITH MY OWN SELF AND TRYING TO
BE A MENTOR AND BE THAT PERSON
TO ASK THE INDIVIDUAL NEED.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO WITH YOUR
LIFE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
SHARING?
THAT HAVE BEEN SET YOUR WAY OUT
WITH THE THE SENATE SERIAL
FOUNDATION A PROGRAM MANAGER I
MANAGE THE CALIFORNIA FUNGIBLE
AS MEN OF COLOR -- I WANTED TO
ASK THE QUESTION ASH KALRA --
HAD -- SUBMITTED RIGHT THINKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET THE RESOURCES DOWN -- TO
COMMUNITIES AND COUNTIES -- WITH
THAT I CAN ACTUALLY RESOURCE --
THOSE COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND CBO
THAT ARE LOOKING TO ACCESS THOSE
RESOURCES AND THE WORLD IS MADE
A MENTION THAT CURRENTLY --
WE'RE USING THE BSE SEE AS A WAY --
TO AND YOU KNOW BRING THE MONEY
DOWN TO THE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
AND I NEED TO CHANGE -- LAST
YEAR UNDER THE CHAIR OF ALREADY
JONES SAWYER WE WERE IN
DISCUSSION ABOUT THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THE BOLD IS FOUNDATIONS
PLAY -- AND SUPPORTING THE
ROLLOUT OF THESE COMMUNITY FUNDS --
MRS TO MISTER JONES SAWYER HAD
TALKED ABOUT -- THE NEED TO
TRACK DOLLARS -- THE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT COMMUNITY
PARTNERS ARE THE ONES ARE
ACCESSING THOSE LAWS NOT
NECESSARILY COUNTIES OR OTHER
AGENCIES -- THAT ANY TAKING OFF
THE TOP RIGHT OR USE THE FUNDS
FOR WHAT THEY'RE NOT INTENDED
FOR RIGHT WE TALK ABOUT THE THE
INVESTMENT WHEN THEY GOT PASSED.
AND THERE WAS LANGUAGE IN THERE
RIGHT THAT FORCED -- IT MAY BE
HARD FOR TO BE PARTNERS ACTUALLY
ACCESS THOSE DOLLARS AS BE WAS
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER RIGHT AND
SO PART OF THE WORK I THINK OF
THIS COMMITTEE RIGHT IS TO
ACTUALLY -- CREATE THAT LANGUAGE
IN THE ENVIRONMENT -- AND THE
SYSTEM IS RIGHT IN THE PROCESS
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
DOLLARS GO DIRECTLY TO COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND THERE'S NO YOU HAVE
TO WORK WITH THEM YOU HAVE TO
WORK WITH US YOU HAVE TO DO THIS.
TO APPEASE -- THOSE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS IN THOSE SYSTEMS RIGHT
THAT ARE CONTINUALLY HARMING OUR
COMMUNITY SO -- YOU KNOW ONE
THING IS DEFINITELY WHERE WE
INTEREST IN WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE -- WERE PARTING WITH
THE LINES WAS ONE OF COLOR WE'RE
PARTNERING WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE SEEING IT ALSO VALUABLE
OPTIONS TO TO ROLL OUT THOSE
DOLLARS WE HAVE -- AGAIN THE
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY PARTNERS
THAT WE KNOW WE ARE FUNDING
ALREADY FOR THE WORK -- WE ALSO
HAVE SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO TRACK
THE DOLLARS AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE GETTING REPORTS BACK
ON TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY USING THAT
MONEY FOR THE USE.
FOR AND ALSO THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE WORKING
RIGHT ON SO THOSE POINTS WE OPEN
THAT THAT THAT PARTNERSHIP UP TO
YOU ALL TO MAKE SURE THAT.
ON AS WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH NEW MONIES
COMING OUT THAT WE ARE PARTNERED
WITH YOU ALL AS A POTENTIAL
OPTION RIGHT TO COME TO GET OUT
OF THE SYSTEM AND GET DOWN TO
COMMITTEE PARTNERS IN AND WE
DON'T DO THAT WOULD BE AWESOME
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BIJAN HOME FROM
NEW WORTH I'M SITE COORDINATOR
AT OUR NEW WORDS ARE SOLUTION
CENTER.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US TO COME IN -- HAVE THE
SITTING IN HIS PLATFORM --
REALLY JUST LIKE TO SHARE A
STORY WITH YOU HAVE A KID AND
AND MISTER WILLIS THIS IS A
SECOND YOUR POINT.
BECAUSE ADVOCATE THAT -- IS ON
PROBATION A KID THAT IS INVOLVED
IN GANGS AND YOU KNOW DAILY WE
TRY TO YOU KNOW TO THE HELP OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE CHANGE THE
COGNITION RIGHT.
HOW THEY THINK HOW THEY GO ABOUT
YOU KNOW THEY WILL LIFE -- YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE A KID THAT IS
INVOLVED AGAIN TRY TO GET HIM.
TO MAKE A BETTER DECISION.
HIS RESPONSE IS WELL IF I LEAVE
THE GAME THEN I LIVE INSIDE THE
NEIGHBORHOODS OF A LEAVE THE
GAME I HAVE TO THE NOT ONLY WERE
ABOUT.
THE GETTING THEM FROM ON MY BACK
ALSO HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT.
THE OTHER GANGS THAT ARE WHO'D
BEEF WIT WITH THAT ALSO HAVE TO
STILL WORRY ABOUT THE COPS
BECAUSE I'M GETTING FALAM AGAIN
FILE I'M GETTING JUNK MAIL RIGHT
SO.
BECAUSE OF THAT.
I CAN REMOVE MYSELF FROM THE
GAME BUT EVERYONE AROUND ME
STILL.
CONSIDERS ME AGAIN WEBER.
RIGHT YOU THINK OF ADDICTIVE
BEHAVIOR.
RIGHT.
IN ORDER TO REALLY GET RID OF
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE TO
ELIMINATED WITH YOU HAVE TO
REPLACE IT.
WITH SOMETHING ELSE YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO FEEL THAT WE HAVE TO
FILL THAT GAP.
EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE DOING I
CHALLENGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT IT
WHEN YOU GO BACK TO YOUR OFFICE
AND YOU.
YOU KNOW BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT
THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THE
THINGS THAT YOU'VE HEARD.
WE NEED TO ALL.
AND MORE.
WE NEED HIM ALL IN WERE TAKES A
VILLAGE TO RAISE ONE KID RIGHT
THINK ABOUT HOW MANY KIDS WE
TAKING ABOUT THE BOMBING YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
THEY NEED AT ALL THEY NEED MORE
MORE OF A MORE OF IF YOU.
HOW TO FOLLOW UP RIGHT?
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS WITH
AWFUL BUT THE SIGNS THAT THIRD.
MAMA FALLS IN FAMILY SOMEWHAT
KEY AND I HEARD A COMMON
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT THE
WHOLE DJJ IN HHS TRANSITION
RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TALK ABOUT
THAT THE RESIGNATION ME I'M
FORMERLY INCARCERATED A I WENT
IN AT THE AGE OF FOURTEEN AND I
PRO AT THE AGE OF NINETEEN AND
YOU KNOW THEY SAY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES BUT WHAT DOES
THAT REALLY LOOK LIKE AND IT'S A
IT'S A SHAME.
THAT WHEN I ASKED HIM BECAUSE I
WENT FROM BEING A PRODUCT OF DJJ
AND NOW I'M IN A POSITION ROCK
GO BACK IN A LIGHT IN THE YOUNG
MEN A WHAT REALITY IS WITH THE
GOING TO BE RELEASED.
TO AND SO TO ME YOU KNOW HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES I FEEL LIKE
IT SHOULD BE HEALTHY BUT IN ALL
ASPECTS OF HEALTH RIGHT YOUR
SPIRITUALITY YOUR MENTALITY YOU
EMOTIONALLY.
AND PHYSICALLY.
SO YOU KNOW ME PERSONALLY I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT THE
FATHER THE FAMILY EMBRACE ME
UPON MY FIRST RELEASE BECAUSE I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TROUBLE WAS
I DON'T KNOW THE HOW MUCH IT
AFFECTED ME.
UNTIL MISTER SAM UNION REP AT
ARMS AROUND ME AND EMBRACED ME.
AND THEN THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO
LET THE YOUNG MEN KNOW AS
THEY'RE COMING OUT TO THEIR
FAMILIES RIGHT.
IS THAT THERE'S RESOURCE THERE'S
OPTIONS OUT YOUR SOUL I'M I HAVE
MET THE PRIVILEGE OF GIVING THEM
RESOURCES -- UPON THEIR RELEASE
ONCE THEY FINISH THE PROGRAM
THAT I RUN YOU KNOW IF THERE FOR
SOME WALKING COUNTY THEN
OBVIOUSLY COME TO US WE EMBRACE
YOU.
FURTHERMORE LIKE IF THEY'RE
GOING.
TO SELL THE LA RIGHT WE GOT Y.
J. C. THERE'S A HOMEBOY
INDUSTRIES OF THE GOING TO
FRESNO WE GOT BOTTLE SO NEIL
SALINAS WE GOT ME BY.
AND IT'S JUST YOU KNOW BRING
THAT AWARENESS THAT THERE IS
OPPORTUNITIES BUT THERE'S NOT.
AS MUCH PROMOTION ADVOCACY FOR
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES INSIDE OF
THE INSTITUTION AND THAT'S WHAT
I WANT TO DO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE NO ONE ELSE -- LINED UP TO
SPEAK.
LET ME JUST SAY THANK YOU AGAIN
TO ALL THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED ON
THE PANELS.
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE -- SHARED
YOUR THOUGHTS.
AND DURING HIS PUBLIC COMMENTS.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT -- UP.
IN NO OTHER PLACE A I WOULD
RATHER BE TODAY FOR THREE HOURS
AND TO HEAR.
POWERFUL TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD
TODAY THE IDEAS.
THAT HAVE COME FROM YOU KNOW
THAT POWERFUL TESTIMONY FOR
FUTURE LEGISLATION.
AND FOR OTHER REALIGNING OF
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
HEARD FROM THE FIRST GROUP OF
PANELISTS -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S GETTING ON THE GROUND. TO
THE COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE DOING THE WORK
AND ULTIMATELY SEEN THE OUTCOMES
THAT WE HEARD ABOUT TODAY FROM
SOME OF THE PRESENTERS AS WELL --
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE
YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL Là REST OF
THE EVENING COVERAGE YOU ON ONE
OF FOUR TO WORKING WITH YOU
THANK YOU THIS MEANS OBJECT